[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
oh
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome to round five of the
tata steel chest tournament my name is
fiona style anthony and i'm delighted to
be joined by once again grandmaster
robert has robert you're looking super
fresh this morning how are you
well i'm proud of you for getting your
name correct today uh we did have a day
off yesterday just to make sure that all
the pronunciation was gonna happen right
but fiona it's great to be back i know
everybody missed the action from tata
still yesterday but today will be
another great day it was no rest for the
wicked you were still here entertaining
the masses but we here in waikanse
myself the players did have a rest day
let's have a look at what happened uh
before the rest day so two days ago
uh we had overall a quiet day um but
then
there was one game that kept us here
until the late hours that was pragnanda
getting his first win in uh this masters
event against nils grandelius
and the other robert was quite a
rollercoaster of the game with
mamedyarov beating duda
two very different games despite both
being decisive as you said mama jarov
judah that looked like you go either
player's way dude is king out in the
open and then prague he had everything
under control it was a very professional
game from the youngster so he beats
niels grendelius and unfortunately for
neil's he's at the bottom of the
standings while pragnando sits in the
middle
yeah so we'll see well we're looking at
the standings right now we still have
vinnie gujarati alone at the top
fantastic start to the event for him
he's on three out of four but he's being
chased by a pack of five players who are
on two and a half so just half a point
behind and that chasing pack is led by
none other than world champion magnus
carlsen jacqueline meridiere also got
into that group uh with his win and we
also have rapport yes panko and uh
jordan van forest
not a bad bunch led by magnus carlson
but when you have the defending champion
here in vikings jordan von forrest at
two and a half in the four he did
already play magnus that was such an
entertaining battle so all of these
players have chances even as far down as
the players in one and a half i think
for neal's unfortunately at half out of
four that's too big of a mountain to
climb but for everybody else they're
still right in this tournament of course
we still have nine rounds to go it's
such a long
event and here we see the matchups for
today i love this camera view as always
plenty to look forward to but i robert
this one maybe anishgiri against video
to one of our top matchups of the day
we know that they're good friends
they've created tons of great chess
content together but today they are
mortal enemies they face off over the
chessboard for all the glory and for
important tournament standings
indeed and well we just saw another
matchup pop up there which i think you
had already highlighted as one of your
favorites for today that is a jordan van
for race who has had a great start to
the tournament once again uh and he's
playing shakia mamedyarov and the two of
them they are known
for not holding anything back very
interesting ideas so what do you expect
from from that match up
the only thing i hope they hold back is
the draw offer that's the only thing
that can prevent this game from being
super exciting both players are
incredibly innovative we know that
jordan von force brings his best to tata
steel he is the champion from 2021 and
chakra mama jarov he is an absolute
legend if you have not seen his best
chess games where have you been he is
always exciting he's ready to sacrifice
at any moment he plays g4 on move three
that is my favorite matchup of the day
yeah i'm very very curious to see what
happens i think we could get something
fresh right out of the opening but let's
not jinx it then we talked about anish
giri against vidiq gujarati the two of
them are great friends later on we'll
show you a tweet about how they spend
the eve
of the rest day and then of course while
the first pairing there nils guandelius
he's been struggling but he will have
the white pieces against magnus carlsen
his former boss niels was also part of
magnus second team for the last two
world championship match before the one
against nepal
the good thing about him not being his
boss anymore is he doesn't have to worry
about being fired so if he is the one
who ruins magnus's tournament so be it
and that's a really tricky pairing
because nils is so strong he can beat
magnus in this individual game so you do
not want to look past the pairing you
cannot afford that in chess indeed and
while robert the action is gonna get
underway in just under 10 minutes
i'm very excited but the people watching
us at home they too can get involved how
can they do it
how can they get involved you ask me the
questions that i actually know the
answer to they can vote on the results
of these games and you will want to do
that because there's a lot of prize
money at stake so go to chess.com events
navigate to the tournament select a game
click vote and select your winner you
could win a piece of the 1 000 prize
pool for best voters or free diamond
memberships remember that voting ends
after the 10th move of each game you do
not want to miss your shot at those
prizes
and we will be back in just a couple of
minutes for the start of round five so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
welcome back everyone uh andrei
yesipanko while he beats magnus carlsen
last year but robert this year once
again he's off to a great start today
not an easy task he will be playing none
other than fabiano carrana but he has
the white pieces what do you expect from
this matchup
andre is somebody who goes a bit under
the radar we know that he's beaten
magnus carlson everyone focuses solely
on that fact but he can also beat
everybody else in the field and he is at
plus one he's just behind vida gujarati
and he's playing five minute carwana who
is probably looking to get a win of his
own and of course we see other players
we saw dubov there and uh well right now
fabiano not on his board
uber was looking really sharp there
every day has been rocking a different
suit we see
niels grandelius has just arrived for
his clash
against magnus carlsen who i think
pretty much every day has been the last
to arrive
in the playing hall
and we see him exchanging a few words
with one of our arbiters
alex
and there we have the full view of the
playing hall the challengers and the
masters both played there that means 28
participants fill out those tables and
who's playing here i can't see that
oh actually magnus well i said that
until now he was always last but he's
arrived two days early and what is he
what's he
curious about something
the players are reading something next
to their boards
do
so the players they're receiving some
information
about uh things that might be happening
in vik over the coming few days but
we'll have more time to to discuss that
tomorrow fabiano meanwhile has arrived
at the board ready
to do battle and the two of them look
ready robert
they do and you see the players all
getting settled we have pragnanda the
youngest participant in this tournament
he won a very nice controlled game in
round four but report he lost the first
round fiona now he's gone two and a half
three sam shanklin not having the event
that he probably wants to have just yet
but a win would start that trek
and robert well we're starting in one
minute two days ago we had two decisive
results which i had actually predicted
in the chat but i know that doesn't
count i never got your opinion um so
today we have one minute to go before
the start how many decisive results
after everyone's come back here nice and
rested
well we have
the mama jar of hoodie so i feel like we
are going to get three decisive games
today i'm going with three what about
you kiana well i'm gonna try and outdo
you once again everyone had a rest day
some of the players almost had two so
i'm gonna go four
and uh just as i said that it looks like
the games have liftoff and we see here
well the two friends anish geary and
vivid one e4
is
on the board there robert and i don't
know if we should start by bringing up
the birds live view
and maybe we can get an overview of
what's what's happening
okay well in the top right between von
flores and mama jarv there's a whole lot
going on there i don't know if you can
see this but precisely zero moves have
been played yet and elsewhere we're just
getting the opening turn from the
players
uh well it's going to be interesting to
see some of these
choices i mean we see a magnus carlsen
go to the rossa limo potentially with
his knight c6 and move to that should be
a familiar sight that's the second board
on the top row from the left and that's
a familiar sight because he played that
the entire 2018 world chess championship
yes uh indeed so we'll we'll see what's
going to
uh to happen there
i'm surprised that with it who we see on
the camera
do you think e4 might have come as a
surprise to him what does anish usually
open with
it could hardly come as a surprise
because at this high of a level the
players usually what's known as playing
with both hands where you play e4 or d4
and here we see that vid has responded
so
there's a lot of psychology that goes
into even playing the first move fiona
part of it is preparation but other
parts of it is like what information do
i want to give my opponent i have played
games where i have sat and thought and
i'm putting thought in air quotes for
like five minutes on the first turn just
to have my opponent feel like i wasn't
expecting that move and that i hadn't
prepared for it so i i doubt that vidit
was surprised by e4 and he did just play
a petrov
yes so the patch of one of the openings
with this most solid
reputation and well so far we're going
down um the main line here
and fabiano caruana he's playing in this
tournament he's not playing this game of
course but we know how strong he has
been with the petrov as his main weapon
from the black side and he's been very
vocal about this fiona that not only is
it an opening that can help you equalize
but they're also some serious bite if
white is trying to play these more
challenging lines going for a win and
anish plays the very principled d4 move
d5 will likely be the response and we
were surprised in round four when report
played the petrol so i guess can you
maybe elaborate on why we were surprised
that report did it but perhaps not too
surprised that vidi has done it himself
yes so i think rapport well we've talked
about it plenty uh he is known for his
interesting uh ideas he's a very
fighting player quite an aggressive
player so seeing a player like him
employ that the petrov comes as a
surprise but today vidit he is the
tournament leader he is playing with the
black pieces in general uh the player's
approach in these kind of elite round
robin events is that a draw with the
black pieces is fine and they often try
and get something with the white pieces
of course that's not always the case but
that is i think the general strategy
and i'm sure that going into this game
with it will be thinking a draw is a
fine result here so it's it's not
surprising to see him take a more solid
approach that's not to say that if the
opportunity arises he will not uh grab
that
very true i mean he did win with the
black pieces against daniel dubov but he
wants a solid position against nishkiri
and anish came on the broadcast after
his short draw against karjakin in round
four we were analyzing the game between
shanklin and report and said this is my
course i made an entire course on
chesapeal about this so he is probably
intimately familiar with so many of
these lines in the petrov that he says
i'm ready for vidit and i would like to
take down the tournament leader indeed
and well robert i'm curious what do you
have to say i'm keeping an eye on the
chat and i see that a lot of
our viewers are expecting a fast or a
friendly draw in this game what do you
have to say to that what's your what's
your expectation
no i think that's
wrong
i think that anish came into today's
game hoping to get an advantage now if
he doesn't get an advantage because
vidit knows exactly what he's doing he's
well prepared he's able to come up with
good responses over the board here then
the game could end
a draw but why would anish who is at
minus one he's one and a half of the
four just make a draw he wants to win
this tournament he loves this event he's
an ambassador for it so i think he has
no interest in settling for a half point
unless the dust has been settled and
then it's clear that that's the only
result that makes sense i absolutely
agree with you i think despite the facts
clearly they are friends and with the
white pieces and given the tournament
standings i agree with you i think anish
will try especially as you said it's an
opening he's so intimately
familiar with so we will see what
happens here i see some people are
shocked that the chat could be wrong but
it happens chad you can't always be
right we shall see what happens here but
now let's go back to the bird's eye um
view and well some of the games seem to
be springing into life already
yes and i do want to just make one quick
point about the game we're just looking
at and it's that the move rook e1 is not
the most common move so anish geary's
latest move is not the most popular line
which means that he might be catching
did it out of his preparation because if
avidit decided to play the patch off
just for today or you know he wasn't
sure that anish would play e4 move one
because anish also plays d4 that perhaps
he is caught bitted off guard and will
see vinnette think at this point
and i see that in the chat a lot of the
eyes have gone already to the game that
you were singling out uh before we even
started run for race
against uh mamedyarov and maybe we can
take
a closer look at what's happening there
shocking right that the game that i said
would be the most interesting is in fact
looking like the most interesting game
and if we go back to the start we saw
that it was a spanish and a6 bishop a4
knight f6 all of this has been played so
many times and when you castle you give
up this e4 pawn but fiona anytime you
give the e4 pawn and there's a king on
e8 if the center opens up that can be
very dangerous for black indeed with
white having already castle dwight is
ready to open the center to bring a rook
to e1 and
there should always be enough play here
for white
i think very often black will just
give give the pawn back
exactly because if you get greedy it's
not going to be fun for your king in the
center and it's important to play b5
first because not only will there be a
potential pinned on the e file the
bishop on a4 would pin the knight if the
move d5 was played first so you see b5
played this is all theoretical territory
and then d5 so the pawn takes on e5
bishop to e6 you need to defend your
pawn that's hanging on e6 and in general
this seems like a strange setup because
black has pushed a bunch of pawns
forward white has a pawn in enemy
territory black has a knight in his
opponent's camp and these situations i
mean the players have studied this
through and through very deeply we see
here the choice was a4
and c3 fiona to my knowledge that is by
far the most popular move along with
knight to d2 and instead we see jordan
no surprise come up with a bit of a
surprise
so jordan's bringing a4 here on his
opponent
a for a much rarer move as the one uh
that you have just highlighted and well
let's try and understand uh what are the
ideas before
behind this early a4 push
yeah try to open up the queen side the
rook on a1 the rook on a8 if you can
distract this queen to a8 remember what
this queen is doing from its current
square it's protecting the d5 pawn so if
you were to make a mistake like say
bishop to e7 now you have a problem
because after and there it goes right a
takes b5 a takes b5 you take on a8 queen
takes a8 and that queen is distracted
away from this pawn on d5 so b4
is kind of a forced move from black
because of how direct white's threats
are and in the game he went before and
quickly jordan played bishop to e3 and
fiona we're getting into
not quite yet but we're about to get
into novel territory and jordan he's so
well prepared he comes up with these
ideas uh it's seemingly in every
possible opening and
it now depends on how much
and how recently mama jarvis looked at
this line
yeah i mean it's incredible uh after
just two moves ago after bishop e6 we
were in a territory where there was
thousands of games and just two moves
later we're almost uh on completely
novel ground as you just said
fisher b7 now the question is uh what is
jordan's next idea now that the black
pawn is on b4 i guess
b3 isn't going to be quite as tempting
any longer so how do you develop the
last remaining pieces the nitrous gonna
come to d2 anyway or what do you think
yeah the knight will come to d2 either
now or in the near future and one idea
that white needs to keep in mind and
black needs to be ready for is this move
a5 it's a common idea to separate
black's queenside pawns because if you
can establish
a5 and b4 you have this pawn chain and
then you don't have to worry about your
queen side pawns but if white throws in
the move a5 either now or at some point
this pawn on a6 is stuck in place which
means that if the queen comes to e2 for
example you'll always have to watch out
for that pawn being loose and bishop a4
could hit you by surprise blackwell
castle and get out of the immediate pin
but at some moment that bishop a4 move
can be quite a nuisance so it opens up
new possibilities for white but at the
same time fiona this pawn on a5 could be
a long-term target that white himself
would have to deal with
yeah so a very interesting position here
already just what we expected some early
novel territory and double-edged
position and a game i'm very much
looking forward to
we will leave jordan to it
for now and let's bring once again the
the bird's eye view
uh back
and uh well we've brought back the
bird's eye view and robert immediately
my eye goes to the game between nils
grandelius and magnus carlson uh because
uh three days ago we saw niels guendeles
play an early
g4 against richard rapport which ended
up
well it didn't backfire but the game
didn't go nilsgrandelius's way but once
again the pawn has found its way to g4
when there's a will there's a way and it
seems that in this tournament they want
to push those g pawns so let's go back
to the start of this game it was a
sicilian we saw knight c6 played and
instead of playing bishop to b5 and
getting into russ limo territory neil
says i'm going to play the sharper lines
open up this board pawn d4 knight d4 e6
knight to c3 queen c7 if this looks
familiar it's because report won a game
against niels grandelius from the black
side as you were uh referring to and
bishop e3 is the choice of niels in this
game if i'm not mistaken fiona we saw
this g4 line as you point out in the
same exact position and
report did not take on d4 so magnus
having that game the recent history in
mind he chooses to take this knight
yeah very interesting to see neil is
going down the same exact line so
we will see who of them
will be able to spring the first
the first real surprise and niels is
thinking here after uh b5 so magnets
immediately trying to take some ground
uh on the the queen side
and you called it in that game a few
days ago that the bishop needs to come
to b7 the pawn can go to b4 and because
white's king is going to go the queen
side having your pawn out on b5 is very
useful because it can help launch an
attack now the big problem for black
right now is the bishop can't move from
f8 and we see neil's castle but the
bishop can't move from f8 because the
pawn on g7 is under attack and if you go
knight f6 which develops and covers that
pawn we know why the pawn's on g4 it
will
at some point or right away go to g5 so
magnus is going to
slowly develop he can even consider
bringing his knight over here to the
queen side with knight e7 to c6 that
move seems very slow but it does kick
the queen out of the center and c6 isn't
a bad place for the knight and
alternatively just play bishop b7 rook
c8
maybe try to play for b4 and a
quick checkmate but the point is that
you're aiming your pieces towards the
white king and towards the center it's
quite natural development from magnus's
perspective
indeed um but good to see niels not
shying back you know it didn't go his
way the first time but he's sticking to
his guns for sure he will have done some
work on this line as well both players
had plenty of time yesterday thank you
to the chat we will update the round
number on the top right uh screen side
of the screen it is indeed round five
and yes so this uh
this game here going to be very very
interesting between
two the two scandinavian players who
know each other as so well
shall we move on from there for now
can i ask you a quick question before we
do sure
so we're talking about niels is
struggling in this event half out of
four magnus he always wants to play for
an interesting game and try to win but
when you look at this right magnus is
getting what he wants in terms of
a fun game with chances for both sides
but as i was hinting at earlier i
sometimes am concerned when a player
wants to win and magnus is a very
objective player he's the best player in
the world and has it for a long time
do you sense that magnus is just really
his goal coming today is to win this
game that is his one goal
that's a it's a tough one i think
magnus in general he is quite good i
think absolutely yes
he wants to win but i think he's quite
good at sensing
when the position um when he's losing
his grip on the position i think
we've seen this so often when a position
is getting a bit out of hand and when
magnus
is at risk of finding himself
in a worse position he seems to be so
good at just steering the game
into
equal territory
so
i think magnus will be happy with what
he got here a very fighting position
with chances for both sides
but he's i don't think he's gonna go all
out
at any any point and he'll keep his cool
as we see the jacket come up there with
magnus so often that's a
sign that things are about to to get
serious
it is and you said he is going to remain
cool he wants to he's getting a little
hot i guess in the jacket but either way
i do agree with you that magnus he's not
going to go all out from the very first
stage of the game but as we've seen for
example against andre yes panko last
year he plays very aggressively in
certain moments and that game had
backfired we'll see how it goes today
but from the perspective i want to win
with the black pieces this is the
opening you
clearly would want its chances for both
king in the center for black castle king
for white but open c file and you know
pawn can go to b4 as we're mentioning so
both sides have the chance even if white
initially should be quite happy with how
the opening is gone yeah having said
that i think niels himself will also be
very happy because um i saw a lot of
comments in the chat you know this
should be an easy win
for magnus niels has been struggling i
think uh far from neil from easy because
well i know neil's well
and nils is a player who's not so easily
affected by a bad start he's a very uh
optimistic human being in general and
it's not so easy to bring his mood down
especially early doors in the tournament
yes it hasn't gone uh his way but what
better way to get back into the
tournament than by beating
magnus carlsen and i think he's
absolutely capable of it so
um i think magnus is not the the only
one who will be looking to get a big win
here
for sure and it's a rare position so
both players
likely on their own already or will be
on their own very shortly in terms of uh
what they prepared queen d2 that
that looks like for me a move that might
have been prepared at home because
you're retreating your queen uh i
understand it for sure one of the ideas
for black with having the rook and queen
here is b4 another could be bishop to c5
so queen e2 deals with both at the same
time
b4 doesn't threaten checkmate down on c2
because the queen guards it but it's
just an interesting moment where queen
e2 played quite quickly and so i have to
believe that niels is still in his
comfort zone he's worked this out and
bishop b4 pins the knight tries to win a
pawn but white now has bishop d4 so you
sort of clear the square for your bishop
and black does not want to make this
movie e5 this is how you lose chess
games uh very quickly
because after e5 there's a problem down
on d7 bishop takes e5 distracts the
queen i will
check your king win your bishop and just
win the game on the spot so just to
point out that niels knows exactly what
he's doing and now fiona i agree with
you we can go elsewhere and find another
interesting game well we just came from
the bird's eye view actually and one of
the first things
i spotted was on the right most uh
bottom corner of the board there's a
little h4 pawn which has gone forward it
doesn't look like it's anything crazy
for now but maybe we can
uh go there anyway unless there's
something else i mean rappers against
pregnant under also looks really
interesting i think today is going to be
a good day robert when i look at this
bird's eye view
um report against prague is very
interesting and i've played that opening
before but look at magnus i mean he he
had his head down on the table and
it looks like he's the first one
registering some upset some surprise but
we did just look at the game and he
hasn't moved so he's just trying to
figure out what to do next but it is
already a very
fun battle between the players and
we're getting word just uh so everybody
can know is that in the game between
niels and grendels and magus carlson
that queen d2 was played by orientari um
against a player uh
suvorov back in last year so that game
is known to the players uh that they are
still following a a single game it seems
but the game will continue and we'll see
how the players do in this one but i
agree with you the h4 move by dubov
that one looks fun
and maybe we can start then um
after that check-in with uh rapport i
mean we're really spoiled here i think
uh the organizers have done such a great
job with the invites this year when you
have a tournament with duboff with
rapport with jordan with mamedyarov
i think there's so many i don't want to
it's hard to even i shouldn't have
mentioned anyone because i think there's
so many interesting players in the field
that that i don't want to it's hard to
single someone out but every day we've
been treated
to some some fresh ideas and some
aggressive chess so just what the fans
want to see
and i mean in this game we just
mentioned the h4 pawn for white but what
about this a4 pawn for black like
what has happened here let's start over
reset the pieces d4 by do buff no
surprises there and we see that
shanklin he gets a queen's gambit
decline structure and as per usual
duvall goes for the catalan he loves
toffee and kettle this bishop matt he's
rubbed off on magnus carlsen his
preparation has been nice for the world
champion and we see here bishop before
check and a5 so
fiona i think some people would say can
i just give my opponent double pawns
isn't that good for white what do you
tell them when they make that error in
judgment yeah i think here is one of the
the
examples where this wouldn't be ideal
because if we have a look at it
if we capture on b4 well black will
recapture with
the apon and although that is a double
pawn the bigger problem is
along the a file
blacks rook now looking down and how is
white ever going to
uh to liberate himself here it's not
going to be easy
also the the pawn on b4 and robert i've
been paying close attention to what
you've been saying when the pawn is
three squares away from the night it
dominates the night because the knight
cannot develop either to a3 or to c3
which are two natural developing squares
and yeah this pressure along the a file
so black is not would not be worried
here about this exchange
i agree completely that pawn is a
strength rather than a weakness which is
why sorry jump the head too much in this
game after a5 bishop g2 you sort of
ignore it black castles white goes queen
c1 and now this move is another funny
looking decision but it makes perfect
sense it defends this pawn on c2 so then
the question becomes why didn't he
defend the pawn by going queen c2 like
what could possibly be the difference
here and at first i would say i i don't
know i don't see why you put the queen
on c1 it doesn't actually make so much
sense to me um but we both moves deal
with dtx4 so what is the added benefit
of queen c1 that's what the real
question is and i think it's not
immediately evident but as the game
continues here with natural moves knight
to d7
castles bishop goes back to e7
sam didn't want to trade on d2 because
after knight takes on d2 you're giving
white some development you took a piece
that wasn't very active it allows the
knight to get out and white's queen
while it's on the first rank is still
doing a great job of
waiting for this file to open which it
will and then you can put your rook
behind it and i think that white gets a
slightly better position because of the
quality of the bishops in
particular yeah this makes sense so
sam instead deciding to drop back his
bishop
to e7
and well i'm still waiting robert to
find out about that queen on c1 so for
now rook t1
bishop f4
and h4 i mean i honestly i i wish i
could give
an answer right now like why is that
queen on c1 like what is the benefit of
the queen being on c1
i
i don't know because when i look at this
position i kind of wish my queen was in
c2
like unless i can sacrifice on h6 at
some point
well that's what i was going to mention
i was like no there's no way i mean
bishop takes h6 it has to be a thought
at the very least but you see here the
evaluation bar reacting and i think
black can just make this move knight to
g4 and the queen is kicked out it
doesn't have the g5 square if you go
queen to h5 over here black has this
move f5 and normally there would be a
repetition available like queen g6 check
and queen h6 but you don't have queen to
h6 because my knight is covering the
square so the king can safely tuck
itself in the corner and if you give a
check here your queen is quickly getting
trapped because my king goes up the
board and your queen now has no safe
squares rook h8 next will trap the queen
yes so i mean this sacrifice certainly
doesn't work just yet
and it's hard to see i mean of course i
would love to make it work but i don't
see how i'm gonna do that so i'm curious
i have to say
to see if duboff is going to to play a
move well he has just made
just i think put the knight to e5 i'm
curious if we will find out at some
point why the queen is on c1 rather than
c2
it might just be for the threat being
strong in the execution like the threat
in bishop takes h6 at some moment will
be concerning for black so perhaps it
restricts some of sam's options and the
queen at c1 also takes care of the a3
square not that that's the reason why
it's on c1 but a3 is an idea that black
sometimes plays because if a3 is met by
b3 then black controls the dark squares
right that's r that would be really nice
opportunity for black for the long term
although this pawn could have gone too
far so it does take care of this a3
square it does have
possibilities with bishop takes h6 a
piece sacrifice especially now that this
knight is on e5 so i i mean this really
it seemed like a joke at first fiona
that bishop takes h6 but it kind of
seems like this is what it's all about
yeah and i love what you said about the
threat being stronger than the execution
a well-known saying and also well that
will keep them
on his toes because at every turn you
have to make sure
that there is no
uh threat that the sacrifice doesn't
work so we see someday actually you know
i feel the players are all dressed very
sharply today after the rest day i don't
know what that's about maybe there was
time to do some laundry or i don't know
what's going on but everyone looking
nice and fresh and sharp today
yes they are especially mama jaro that
hoodie
looking fresh we know that that's a good
signal for the chest that's going to be
played but you are right the players are
dressing for the occasion and that's a
very
serious and important round
five here in vikings a so now we put up
the bird's eye view fiona and you know
you ask me what game i want to go to i'm
gonna return the question to you because
you mentioned report against pragananda
which is a game i'm very interested in
attesway i believe is the thing to say
right now
yeah it wasn't me it's our producer
bless you bless you vic
and well this rapport game i also see
yes panko against karana has suddenly uh
caught my eye
with
the king the white king with well we
have opposite side castling although the
black king currently still in the center
but that looks like it's going to be a
sharp sharp
battle so robert where do you shall we
start with rapport
okay let's do that
you you chose i was worried that i was
going to have to it's too difficult for
me because all the games are interesting
but we will take a look
as mama jarv brings the hoodie up up to
the mouth deep in thought we will bring
up
the game between rapport and pragnanda
so
hey i guess that's what we know now is
that when he brings the hoodie up takes
a little nibble it means he's about to
make his move but we do have this game
between reported pragmata this is a
theoretical position and i have
experience in the black side of this
position in particular but also a little
bit from the white side so i can comment
some here
d4 knight f6
the opening stage here quite normal the
nimzo indian defense and queen c2 the
main line uh played
countless times
castles a3 and after this trade here
fiona
d5 bishop g5 c5 so this is a very
aggressive way for black to play and you
look there's a king in the center so
pushing your pawns at the board like
this and challenging white center here
it makes a lot of sense from the
perspective that white is quite a ways
away from castling kingside
yeah so i was gonna ask you i think for
the players who aren't familiar with the
nimso
and the ideas so what is the idea behind
giving up uh your bishop pair so quickly
and then
playing actively in the center is it
mostly based on what you're saying about
the lack of development on the on the
king side for white
it's entirely about that because black
went bishop to b4 that was one turn and
bishop takes c3 that was two white you
know had a knight develop then queen c2
pawn a3 queen takes knight that's
already several tempe spent trying to
get the bishop pair now this is known
territory still but c5 is trying to
really take advantage of the fact that
black is castled the king is safe over
there and black's pieces will quickly
come out because as we see after the
pawn was captured on c5 d4 the queen
comes to g3 in line with this king and
prognom says not a big deal i'll play
knight to d7 and the reason it's not
such a big deal is because bishop h6
does threaten checkmate in one move but
the knight just drops back to e8 and
you've committed yourself to a potential
checkmate that is easily defended and
this pawn on c5 is now under attack and
one big thing in this position is with
this pawn on a3 you often would like to
put it back on a2 because when this pawn
is captured you look at a square like b3
black often puts this pawn on a5 can
even put it down on a4 and just start
operating
on the flank on the queen side because
white has no pieces over there so it's a
really dangerous position potentially
for white as we return to the game
position and you see report thinking
i don't believe that he's too well
versed in this opening maybe probably
not have surprised him with it to begin
with but i mean i'm looking at this game
for you enough chances for both sides
this early because white objectively is
fine and knight f3
is the move that probably should be
played here but the way that the time
management has been with prognom that
well in the lead he had good preparation
in round four against niels grandilius
this is a moment where report needs to
be very careful yeah absolutely i was
just gonna point out the time situation
which seems to to confirm
uh your your hunch that uh richard
report was surprised here somewhere by
pragnanda who i'm sure will have drawn
even more confidence from his win from
two days ago so
i mean what am i every game we come from
like this is gonna be really interesting
but today i have to say i'm genuinely
really excited for this round five here
shaping up uh interestingly everywhere
we're going to take our very first a
quick break of the day and then we'll be
back with all the action here from round
five so we'll see you very shortly
[Music]
welcome again in waikanse
for bending for bending here in the door
hey
[Music]
foreign
welcome back here to round five at the
tata steel chess tournament and robert
during the break none of us went
anywhere we were just busy looking at
the bird's eye view and what a day of
chess we have ahead of us today
how are we supposed to focus on any one
individual game when they all look like
this if we just
look at the
s top row second from the right yes of
panko against caruana there's a pawn
that's stormed up the g file both sides
of castle queen side black is currently
up a pawn but there knows double pawns
the c file so white's trying to get very
active we have the game between niels
grandilius and magnus carlson right
second from the left in the top row
there's no b-pawn for whites his king's
in danger but black's kings in the
center and even if it castles the open g
file means that the king will never
really be safe fiona every single game
even duda against karjakin where black
is up a pawn but white's ahead in
development
i don't know where he's actually not a
single dull game here today and maybe we
should return briefly to nils grandelias
against magnus carlsen where we see
magnus has just decided to give up not
upon uh give up upon in the center so
let's catch up with what's been
happening here because
things are getting crazy
okay well bishop b4 was in fact played
after queen drop back to d2 bishop d4
defending the knight hitting g7 f6 we
mentioned how e5 would not work because
the problem with the d7 pawn hanging so
f6 played g5 let's crack open the
diagonal please let's go for black's
king h6 i mean
this is a
response that clearly was studied
because h6 is just a funny looking move
but it does make sense you are forcing
white's hand you cannot reinforce it
with h4 because after h6 g5 your rook on
h1 is loose you can't take back that
would drop a pawn so niels was forced to
capture he chooses the h6 square and so
this is a good lesson in fact because if
you take on f6
or h6 the knight will capture back but
they say knights in the rim are dim
yeah you want to
not invite the to deny to join the game
uh via f6 so capturing on h6 definitely
the logical uh choice here
and after uh the recapture we saw niels
now play a3 and asking that bishop what
it's going to do
it said i'll return
the favor and surprise you by taking
this pawn on a3 and you're like wait
what is magnus doing he's just losing a
piece with giving up a bishop no after
paul takes a3 there's move e5 this
bishop has to move and if it leaves d4
the c3 knight is loose we have two
pieces staring down the c file which
means that you have to play a move like
knight takes b5 we saw that move in the
game hitting the queen on c7 so you
can't take the bishop pawn takes knight
bishop retreats to b2 what a funny way
this game has gone and then d5 by magnus
so the
evaluation bar is going up in white's
favor as we get to the move d5
i'm not sold on that and it's not to say
that niels doesn't have good chances
here of course he does but with this
king on c1 so wide open
i don't know who's better i don't know
if the players know who's better even if
the engine says something it's where
depth comes into play here because down
the road this king will remain in some
danger this rook on h8 would like to
join the party and d8 eventually
what are you thinking here fiona i think
that if i'm niels grandillos and i mean
i don't have any insights but i think
very likely up until this moment nils
had been following his preparation
because you can't be playing all these
down this crazy line in
very close to
no time if you're not very well familiar
with what you're doing
um and
if d5 is the first move that catches him
by surprise
the question then for the player becomes
well is this move am i not familiar with
it because it's not so good or has
magnus and his team have they looked
at this deeper than i have is this
magnus over the board inspiration i
think this is really a critical moment
and well maybe we can talk about why did
the bar shut up the way it did
well at first sight it looks like one of
the pawns is hanging with jack the pawn
on on b5
it certainly is and i think that is why
the position is so favorable for white
and this is where having the engine is
so useful because while we don't have
the moves we see oh this is great for
white but this is if we if i try to get
into the mindset of the player and i
think what would i do
if i'm faced with this position i would
definitely want to take on b5 with check
and then i would think where is this
king going i don't want to play bishop
c6 i just lost the pawn with check i
don't want to keep trading and then lose
this pawn as well so i'd want to make
the move king f7 this rook is going to
join the party with rook to d8 and if
you take on d5 we see that these pieces
are still barreling down at the white
king and bishop takes d5 would distract
the the white queen but this would be a
big mistake because queen takes d5 is in
fact checked so i can't take your bishop
and then next move return and protect
against the checkmate so what i would do
instead is red8
putting up more pressure on the d5 pawn
and this is where things get hectic
fiona if you played d6 that sacrifice i
wanted to make work move ago now it
officially does work if your queen takes
my rook you get checkmated down on c2 so
this is the type of game that magnus is
going for he wants to open the board up
even if it costs him two pawns he
learned a bit of a lesson from jordan
von forrest and he sees it that white
king is in some serious jeopardy
and i'm i'm curious here if we can go
back to the
because this one suddenly looks like the
white king is in some trouble but if i
capture on b5 and after work
after king f7 this is the moment where i
wonder
do i have anything better than capturing
on
d5 because if i can avoid it i would
like to
add to stop your all your pieces from
coming into the game
and yeah i think this move bishop a4
retreating move defending the checkmate
pretty permanently this is an important
move and from a distance it's kind of
odd looking and bishop takes b5 check is
of course clear to the players but
bishop a4 the e4 pawn is hanging but if
you take e4 you have a bishop backing up
the pawn the issue is queen d7 happens
with check and black is unable to trade
queens because if you do trade queens in
comes the rook with the check winning
the bishop on b7 if you do not trade
queens where is your king going right
you go king g8 i'm gonna run away from
you the bishop drops back to b3 with
check now where king to h7 okay i found
safety right no rook g1 and i don't care
if it's a queen or a rook on d7 i'm
aiming straight for the g7 pawn and you
can't protect it with a rook without
losing that rook on the spot and then
the game because you can't take with
both rooks your queen needs a defense of
the rook on c8 so you're just
getting blown off the board here if
you're black so bishop a four few and i
think that's the retreating move
necessary to hold everything together
and then play for more i love that move
bishop a4 because in this position here
we see the bishop on b3 does such a
beautiful job of attacking and defending
at the same time holding things together
on c2 but covering and looking down this
all-important diagonal and well ben
feingold's then never play f6 and here
we see some of the dangers uh with all
these holes uh along the the light
squares
yes this bishop a4 move i don't think
that magnus would take because he would
see that this is a losing continuation
and just one more variation to show that
if the king came to f8 the bishop
doesn't get to b3 but the problem is
your rook on h8 is going to be lost we
trade queens and then rook d a check
thank you very much your king has to
move you lose the rook so these
positions i think that magnus would have
to play the move d4
and he does have this pawn chain
aimed towards the enemy king which is a
good thing but the bishop comes back to
b3 check and the game continues i think
this is where
using an engine and only an engine is a
big mistake because
it's not like white's king is perfectly
safe we know that white is better but
should be better but it's not that
straightforward because white does have
some long-term problems here the extra
pawn is this pawn on a3 where in a pure
end game that can be useful but in the
meantime black has a well-placed rook
the pawn structure is extremely healthy
these pawns here they can't really move
the pawn e4 stuck of course and if you
ever move the f-pawn e4 is in some
trouble so white is better at for the
time being but there's some long-term
potential for black in this position and
one inaccuracy from white can turn the
tables in magnus's favor even if niels
would be better to start
yeah and well niels has gone
into the tank so i think it's fair to
say that d5 has come as a surprise to
him
and i think he is going to take his
sweet time here to figure out do i want
to capture on b5 if i do what's my
follow up what are the long term um
and the long term ramifications here so
i think we can go back to the bird's eye
view
uh and see what else is happening but
certainly such an exciting game here
between niels and magnus
and you said think tank and i know that
yanchez of duda went to the think tank
and report finally went knight f3 after
quite a thing so some of these players
in really fascinating battles at the
moment but not too familiar at least in
terms of home preparation
and uh robert is it time for us to check
in with jesse panko and karana because
that is another game where
pawns are all over the place deep into
the enemy territory both kings have
castled queensland and i hope you can
shed some light for all of us into
what's happening uh in this game
well fiona i know you're gonna be mad on
behalf of ben never play f6 except in
this occasion where it's a very good
move because the last one played with g6
of course white wants black to take and
the rook enters the action so keeping
that file closed is a good decision but
we should go back in time just to see
how we got here because i know how we
got here i don't think the audience can
tell just from the current position but
here queen c2 all of this is standard
stuff until g4
g4 you gotta love it alexander chabal of
the how many times do you win the u.s
championship i don't want to get the
number wrong but it was it's many times
four or five who knows too many he's an
absolute boss but g4 is a was a popular
decision of his uh as he you know he
continues to play sharp lines like this
and the point is if you take on g4 which
probably did not the rook comes to g1
and then if the knight moves you drop
your pawn on g7 so it's a trade of pawns
in an interesting way that gives white
all of the activity so fabiano he
decides to play h6 bishop d2 still not
capturing on g4 because of this rook g1
maneuver then taking on c4 so look at
this
why rook g1 now i've been willing to
give up the pawn but when you take on c4
of course you should take back right the
answer here is
it's not so simple because this pawn on
g4 is misplaced when black plays b5 and
bishop b7 you don't want your pawn on g4
right it's one of these positions fiona
where we know the structure
but it's usually with this pawn back on
g2
indeed
so
with the pawn
uh on g4
maybe you can explain i mean i'm really
struggling because i'm not familiar with
this position so what difference uh does
it make uh
now in in this position here
yeah the thing is in these lines where
we usually get b5 the bishop retreats
now it would probably show the e2 and i
think it has to uh not the most active
square so you would want it to be on b3
or d3 because it aims into more of the
position but you need it to come to e2
because if you play say bishop b3 just
to show some of this bishop b7 and c5
happens
very quickly and your knight is loose
and there's a rook behind it so
b5 c5 is what black wants in so many of
these positions but the inclusion of g4
is very detrimental
to white's position so all of a sudden
this one pawn move it's actually of
gigantic consequence
it's a very committed decision by uh yes
penguin so if we go back uh to the game
rook g1 b5
and now striking in the center so all of
this is this g4 i guess is very rare but
has it been
played much you talked about shabalov
yeah at this point i would imagine we're
in noveltier
approaching it but it does it is
justified uh this pawn center for white
is obviously very strong and you want to
push e5 with the fork you have two pawns
in the center to only one for black so
white's center is great but you've given
up a pawn and fabiano knows how to deal
with it by playing e5
yes maker castles you don't want to open
up the position with your king in the
center so flabby plays queen c7 king to
b1 and this isn't one of these moves
fiona we've talked about it when you
cast a queen side you want to bring your
king away from the center so you play
king to b1 but in a position like this i
wonder if there's a better way to more
be more direct because kv-1 may be a
tempo loss that allows black to finish
his development yeah i guess
prophylactic moves in general
are good getting your king into more
safety but i guess the question you're
wondering about is could we have done
something more direct on the kingslight
g4 has already been played um and well
the question would be is it could do we
have time to play h4 and try and get on
with the attack on the king side
that's really the essential question and
black has counters over here on the
queen side as well don't count out b4
and things of that nature but h4
to
my first instinct would be the move just
going as quickly as possible uh it's not
like this attack is leading to checkmate
so black doesn't have to fear that he's
going to lose in the spot but he
has to think of g5 here and what to do
um
i'm really not sure fiona i'm going to
be honest it's one of these positions
it's such a mess and i would have to do
what the players are doing and sit and
think for like you know 45 minutes i
have we have the bar offset that says
zeros how helpful is that right
black is up up a pawn
but it's just zeros so you're telling us
a whole lot thanks engine you're really
a good pal
well at least on the plus side h4 it
wasn't played immediately but after king
b1 bishop b7 he played h4 now of course
not the same story because it comes a
move later than what we were looking at
and fabi now uh deciding to go queenside
as well which makes sense of course you
don't want to castle kingslide into the
white
pawn storm
because bad things would be happening
here in the very near future
so
faviano going queenside and g5 still
appearing
on the void we saw the the trade um of
pawns
the knight dropping back to g8 and then
this g6 f6 and that leads us to the
current position on the board robert
yeah and i mean look at yes panko he's
really focused here he's down upon he
has compensation because he has more
activity for his pieces the bishop on b7
staring into its own pawn bishop on d6
staring into its own pawn and you could
free up the bishop on d6 by taking on d4
but then you welcome this knight into
the game and you have weak light squares
on e6 on f5 and a knight on d4 is
perfectly placed to jump into those
squares so it's not easy for either
player as they jockey for position and
b4 is never out of the question that's
the thing it looks like a bad decision
at least in
first glance because you lose the sight
of the pawn c4 but kicking the knight
away from c3
if white is not careful that could have
devastating effect especially if you
could follow up with an eventual c5 as
e4 becomes a little bit tender and
honestly if we just quickly hop back a
few moves to this moment
we're talking about kingdom b1 i mean
after h4 you still have to consider this
move b4 at all times and then after the
night moves you play b3 because the e4
pawn isn't defended and i was thinking
about this i wasn't sure
in my head and i should have shown it
over the board but like with this kind
of position of course it still says
zeros like
what like when i look what do we have to
do
i don't think about evaluations i don't
think about numbers i think this is
crazy it's so hectic but the point
everybody is after a takes b3 pawn takes
b3 i'm just doing everything i can to
distract the queen from the e4 pawn and
if you say i'm gonna keep the e4 pawn
get away now black plays c5 and this
king is in some danger so it's clear
that white would you probably take and
knight takes e4 and then we get this
kind of position where the bishop comes
out to c4 this king is in big danger and
there we see the bar going up a bit but
it's uncertain right we made the moves
that were
maybe c5 instead that could be a move
that keeps things and yeah of course
that's the move that keeps things uh
level but this position you don't think
in terms of evaluation you think about
the complications this king is not saved
this king will never find true shelter
either white has a better center for the
time being but there's an attack on this
king the e4 pawn is loose
my head hurts
and it's not again i'm not gonna get any
better today report with all the other
games we've worked out going uh if we
come back just to the current position
on the board after f6
i'm curious what yes panko who we see uh
we see him there at the board
um
i'm curious how do you proceed here you
have given up upon
and now uh
how do you want to to go on about this
which of the pieces do you think are
well placed
for white which are the pieces you want
to improve
um
what what do you think is the idea here
for sepenko
and that's exactly how you think about
the game you know which pieces are on
their best squares which can go to
better ones and you asked me for
yesapanko and he just decided to take i
think on e5 but what i was about to say
before he made that move is that knight
e7 was going to be black's move almost
no matter what now of course he's going
to take back on e5 but knight to e7 was
the plan f takes e5 back here would be a
mistake because look at those light
squares we just talked about f5 and e6
now it's f7 and e6 all of these light
squares are a problem and i'm going to
fork you
somewhere over here uh no
you can't do anything about it really so
it's a not a good situation so he's
going to take back with a piece on e5
fiona and i think it has to be the
bishop normally you'd want to take
on e5 with the knight and try to trade
off knight for night but then knight
comes to d4 and you have this problem
once again on these light squares it's
not the end of the story black fights on
but you can see how uncomfortable it
gets quickly so that's why i think
process of elimination
says that bishop takes e5 will be played
and you don't want to give up your
bishop for a knight in an open board but
at this point in time this knight on e5
is very strong this knight will come to
e7 and black can complete the
development and remain upon ahead
so very double ledged stuff here we will
see if yes the panko's pawn sacrifice
pays off let's go back to the bird's eye
view
for now
and we see well that for example is
still thinking uh after d5 and uh robert
what else is happening
too much
way too much is happening uh something a
little strange is happening the duboff
shanklin game i i think we can go that
for just one second before we go on over
to the duda against karjaking game which
we haven't looked at but i just want to
quickly show you the last few moves of
this game because i hate to predict
early draws and i don't think we will
get it in this game but look at this
fiona knight h5 bishop e3 knight f6
bishop f4 knight h5
bishop d2 so the bishop is just trying
to figure out where it's going to go it
went f4 to e3 back to f4 now to d2 and
the knight went right back to f6 and
okay robert good news we just saw duboff
on the camera the bishop did not drop
back to f4 so we're not going to get an
early draw here uh instead danny lubov
has retreated the knight to d3 i don't
know if you want to stay here or with
that relief out of the way if you want
to move on to do that and karjakin
yes i just wanted to make sure that we
were not going to see a repetition i
love the fighting spirit by both those
players for shanklin with the black
pieces i think it was his best decision
to go 95 and retreats you can't blame
him that's objectively the best choice
and for dubai he says i have other
options let's go for them but let's go
to this duda game against karjakin
because fiona i was very surprised that
we talked about it
a little bit during the break that
karjakin went for the queen scam but
accepted
yeah the queen scandal accepted quite a
rare guest uh at the top and i i don't
recall
sergey uh playing it but do you have any
more insights
i
for me it's the first time i've seen a
game of his in this particular line it
is a guest that's for some of the top
players fabiano carwana has played it
leonardo dominguez has played it so it's
not
you know impossible that it happens this
isn't the only time but it is rare
because you hand white the center and we
keep talking to catalan positions like
that where white gets two pawns in the
center and then black has an extra pawn
but usually in the queen's gambit
accepted black doesn't keep the pawn so
b5 by carjacking he made a quick draw
with the white pieces round four it
seems to me fiona he was ready to fight
for a win from as early as move one
today
yes absolutely
he's had plenty of time to prepare uh i
think even two days ago you know and
against aneesh that quickdraw maybe even
sergey himself wasn't too happy with
that was just you know caught uh by
surprise in the opening but today well
yeah we definitely have got a fight on
our hands here with uh sergey trying to
hold on for now to the extra pawn on c4
by playing v5 and duda immediately
trying to challenge
the pawns on the queen side
we saw the exchange now on b5 and well
we already talked about this kind of
position from the other side where the a
file
opens
so
robert what is the the compensation here
for white what are what are the ideas
well you look at white center you see
two very healthy ponds here black is
upon a head but in general the ponds in
the center are so great because that's
where your pieces go that's the
principle of chest develop your pieces
control the center and so when you have
pawns in the center it limits the scope
of your opponent's minor pieces so
this is where the compensation comes
from knight c3 immediately goes after a
pawn queen b6 bishop e2
just quick development for
duda and this move i wanted to get to
the game because knight h3 knights in
the rim are dim don't you usually say
that but as the game continues here one
of the big ideas for white is to play f4
and maybe move like f5 so the knight on
h3 it can't be attacked because the only
way to attack it is to give up your
central pawn which you do not want to do
especially because this knight gets the
d5 square as well so you
played bishop b7 to develop yourself and
now the knight is justified f4 maybe f5
this knight can still hop into f4 back
towards the center or to g5 so i
actually think this game is really
hectic even though there's not too much
tension at the moment it's unclear what
black should do about this king fiona
because if it castles king side you know
white's just gonna throw everything at
it and if you stay in the center mike's
still going to throw everything at it
yeah i mean i really liked the look of
this at first sight for yanchez of duda
um
i am also like you just pointed out
concerned about
the black king
where is that going to go i think that
will be a sort of the main plotline for
the remainder
of this
game but sega karjaking when he decided
to play queen's gambit accepted he knew
that this was sort of the territory he
was going to get into so uh well we'll
see what he has cooked up here
so now robert let's bring back the the
bird's eye view unless there's something
you wanted to say
about this i'm just i'm just in my head
variations are swirling through my head
just trying to figure out what exactly
is going to happen here black's so
underdeveloped white with the beautiful
center but karjakin is a pawn ahead so
if he can
fend off an attack for the next bunch of
moves then he can stabilize his position
finish his development then he will be
in good shape but for now you see his
face he is ahead on the clock he's the
one who chose this variation but it's
not going to be easy to
move forward from here
so we're back in the bird's eye view for
now uh robert let's quickly um maybe
i'll i'll put you to a challenge dear
challenges uh within a few moments tell
us what's going on in each of the games
and then we'll go on a short break
during which we'll hear from our
producer big checking in with the
challengers section
okay well i'm going to go for a cop out
in the top left between geary and vidit
because we need more time to dive into
that game it may be even material only
one pawn has been traded per side but
the action is just heating up there
there's a lot of tension in particular
on the e file then in grand elias vs
carlson he took the pawn on b5 with
check the black king will get out of the
way we're looking at some of these
variations with the bishop drops to a4
white's king is safe for now but black
has this wonderful pawn chain as
compensation carwana took back on e5
with the bishop if yesterpanko wants the
two bishops advantage he will take on e5
with his knight that is the top row
second from the right black will take
back with the knight two bishops healthy
pawn structure black is up a pawn but
white has quite a deal of initiative and
then with yvonne forrest against mama
jarv in the top right that one i would
really need to dive more deeply into the
pawn went up to a5 a6 will be a target
the queen on d3 means the bishop can
come to c2 to line up with it and go for
the attack e5 to e6 is an idea at some
point the bishop on a7 don't forget
about that that's a piece waiting in the
wings for the situation to open up
bottom left right hard report against
pragmata e5 played and ignored if white
took the pawn e5 the king on e1 is not
happy so instead of capturing he just
won't rip to d1 then due to cardiac and
we just looked at it i don't want to
repeat myself so finally last but not
least dubov went knights d3 no move is
played by shanklin he will sit he will
think he will ponder his options and
we'll have to find out what we get back
from break
robert you've done great it was quite a
challenge with
the kind of games we have going on here
today i can't wait to be back with all
the action but for now let's check in uh
with big and the challengers and we'll
see you after that
[Music]
yes welcome back to round five of tata
steel chess tournament uh my name is
voter big i am the producer for this
event so if anything goes wrong you know
how to play you know who is scolding
robert has when he's taking too long uh
on one game so
for now we're going to check in with the
challenges every day next to the masters
we also have the challenger section who
are trying to be
obviously going for first place and the
winner of that tournament will be
playing in the master section next year
and today we have a look at a game of
aryan aragy against roman vocal the
german and they are playing an
exceptional game we have a lot of tricks
i'm very excited to go in this so
let's have a look this is round four
obviously the day before the rest day
uh and black just played the move rook
to e8 hitting the spawn on e4 building a
little bit of pressure now uh volgo
actually had a crazy combination uh
going on here and we're going to dive
into that
he played bishop to f3 we see the bar
going down a little bit it's a defending
move it makes sense you know the c4 pawn
is a little bit
weak but what you could have done
is e5 and we say you know what aryan
take the pawn we don't care and if you
take that pawn
with the uh with the pawn you cannot
take with the queen she'll lose it you
can play another pawn we don't care like
a kid in the mcdonald's place play place
he doesn't know where to go so he just
moves forward
crawls forward and obviously
he took if you take with the pawn here
which makes a lot of sense you have to
move
rook takes f6
bishop takes f6 and knight to d5 hitting
both that queen and that bishop so
beautiful sacrifice of two pawns but
obviously
you don't need to
there's one other move that black can
play and it is queen to e6 which is move
away from it
and here's this is where the fun starts
it's not even on this list i was looking
at the engine we were just you know
we're trying about
you can still play brook takes f6 bishop
takes f6
knight jumps to e4
and if you move your bishop back
here it goes
you still play rook with a6
what why well if you take it
and this is
i ca i'm sorry i couldn't make this
stuff up
bishop to g4 hitting that queen saying
where you gonna go
you're stuck here you cannot go there
you cannot go back and if you well
actually
you can't say gunsling4 i apologize i
was wrong but then you lose your bishop
obviously with check and then your rook
so it kind of stuck and if you take the
bishop
you're still gonna get the royal fork he
hits the rook he hits the bishop the
queen and with a check and white is
blasting through this position
so the best move actually for black is
to just
i don't care
just take your pawn
and after some traits
uh white actually sacrificed two rooks
for this one queen a crazy combination
all the way from the start which all
started by the move e5
unfortunately this is not what happened
he played bishop f3 and after knight to
g4
we had a trait
kick the bishop out
and now white played e5 with a very
interesting idea that after bishop g6
he's like uh-oh i have some issues here
on the foul this is going to hit my
knight this pawn is going to fall so
i'm going to play rook to f5 you see the
bar drop but the idea about it is pretty
simple if we take we trade trade and
here we play knight to e4 and you can
see all the pieces here on the light
squares and they're actually very hard
to be brought out they're very hard to
be kicked out and white is actually in a
very decent position trying to put some
pressure here on the king sideman with
queen f2 putting some pressure on f6 so
this is not a terrible position it's not
the best but you can see maybe queen c2
hitting that king there all these pieces
are light squares and with this
bishop you boxed in this pawn cannot
kick away this rook it's actually a very
decent position however
a clever trick that was missed by robin
knight to b4
and after say
we trade trade
we jump in here
we take
we take and we see this battery on the
e-file going all the way down the rooks
are released this bishop is very very
strong and what happened in the game
this is a little bit too far in the game
i do like to show a little bit more
we did see a trade here knight e4
is actually exactly what happened and
you can see here minus eight uh
i'll play it out we did see white uh try
to make something happen but after a few
retreating moves the queen came to the
center
and after this final thing
we traded off the pieces we took on g4
and that was open we had orion erigaicey
three and a half out of four and he is
playing an incredible tournament
obviously he did amazing uh at the riga
blitz tournament he did amazing in uh
warshau in poland as well he's a young
talent going towards the top trying to
get as much recognition and fame as
prank london as fitted as another even
he is
not even the future as robert hess would
say
he is the today so an incredible game by
him it was a lot of fun to analyze i
hope it didn't take too much of your
time of the broadcast and if so we're
going to hear it right now from fiona
and robert
[Music]
welcome back and robert just said it
there during the break
we are absolutely spoiled
today with every single
game having
burst into action but robert you think
there you thought there was one place
where we should start
i think with the tournament leader
gujrati with the black piece against
aneesh giri the hometown hero in the top
left of our screen here that seems like
it's the place to go
i've just been so happy to
look at all of these games the players
clearly got their rest because they have
their work cut out for them and if we go
back in time fiona we we're looking at
this opening just in passing uh c4 was
played here c6 and at this point with
the pawn coming to c5 obviously this is
the first interesting moment because
after bishop c7 you've cut off the
defense of b7 from your your queen
but chat would never make this mistake
right fiona they would never take on b7
this free pawn
well
i think maybe one or the other person
might be tempted to take the pawn on b7
but you always have to be so careful
when aligning both queens and
especially if your own queen isn't
defended then there might be
um
oh my goodness
discovery a discovery that's right i was
drinking deflection i knew it wasn't me
and i just does this happen to you
sometimes you know exactly the word but
it just won't
come to the forefront of your mind
it happens regularly also english is
your third life what language is english
for you my fourth
you're a song excuse me your fourth
language so you're forgiven uh you're a
polyglot you can
forget words as much but then again i
did record a whole series for chess.com
on all the tactics you need to know
you need to know the tactics not the
name of the tactics it's okay it's okay
well
b7 not captured because the queen is
lost knight c3 played instead and knight
takes c3 would not be a good move
because after knight c3 bishop takes f5
instead of taking back on c3 you see the
eval bar it's trying to figure out queen
takes f5 this pawn on b7 can be captured
but you also should probably just take
this pawn this knight should be first
and then maintain the pressure against
this pawn forcing black to play b6 after
which you play bishop a3 things like
this and white is just ahead in
development black is a bit cramped so
queen takes b7 looks like it would be a
good choice but as you see on the eval
bar here it's not so good because queen
comes back to d7 if you take here this
knight comes to e4 and the queen is
trapped in the corner we just showed you
why the queen can't go to the seventh
rank because bishop takes h2 is check
which means the knight a6 is the next
move for black and the queen is caught
so it's a really funny sequence it's
really deep line but that's why queen
takes b7 for a while is kind of out of
the question but after that b takes c3
move it's still good for white but i
want to get to the game because knight
a6 knight e2 this is a really critical
moment for vivid the knight came to e2
to go to g3 and when the knight gets to
g3 fiona no longer is there a check with
this bishop so by rerouting the knight a
niche is actually attacking the b7 pawn
yes indeed and well we will
see if you if you are black
one of the questions the knight that has
just gone to a6 what's the future for
that night how are you going to deal
with defending the pawn on b7 are you
gonna defend it indirectly by maybe
moving your bishop are you going to put
a rook to b8 can you have a push at the
b6 pawn well certainly not while there
is still a knight on a6
so
a lot of questions here forbid it what
do you
think robert how would you deal with the
defense of the b7 pawn
i don't like the look of it but i'd
probably play rook a to b8 where
i defend the pawn directly i mean it's
such a passive square for the rook the
knight can't get back in the game but i
do have everything under control so
that's the bit of good news i'm
struggling to see other nice ways to
defend i know that if i move my bishop
from c7 i defend the pawns and bishop a5
also comes to mind it is a one move
threat the rook will move out of the way
and then there's just this awkward setup
of pieces over here which i don't like
because white can play a3 move the queen
and play b4
yeah and well at least one question i
think has been answered here for sure
and robert i know you'll be devastated
that the chat might have been wrong
about this
but uh that game certainly does not look
like a friendly a friendly draw
between anish and and with it
no they're fighting and of course niche
came in today to fight and we know
they're friends they were eating
together the other night they had a nice
meal with their trainers and robert just
as you say it there it is uh the tweet
that we're talking about but this was
posted by vivid a couple of nights ago
before the rest day so we see uh there
uh at the bottom left corner as arya
antari grandmaster aryanthari from
norway who is here uh as
a second for
anish
giri and then we see on the bottom right
vidit the the take the selfie taker and
uh next to him is grandmaster alan
greenfeld from israel who is his own
second
so very wholesome treat great to see
the two friends having dinner together
but it's a different thing you can be
friends over the dinner table but two
days later over the board
there are no more friendships
i'm just mad i wasn't invited
that's just not cool anish did it
that's
we'll have a word with them i was quite
jealous as well because i
i've been planning to ask them where
they got the indian food from which
looked
very nice there is no indian restaurant
in vaikanse so it must have come from a
bit further so i'm planning to
investigate but robert we very much um
hope to have you back in vikranzo with
us next year
i don't want to be there if it and
anisha going to be there because i know
that
they will shoot me friendly messages but
they don't invite me to their gathering
so it's all right i'll be okay but we
should also move on from their game so i
don't have to sit here all sad
well we'll we'll try and find the game
to cheer you up robert and we're back in
the bird's eye view and maybe the next
game we have to check in with is niels
gwendelus against magnus carlsen because
after a long thought niels decided to
take the pawn on b5 and the last time we
came from here we thought magnus was
going to go to f7 but somewhat
surprisingly maybe or interestingly he
has decided to go to f8 instead
let's bring that game up as we were
discussing earlier king f7 and that was
my doing i was tunneling on that move
because i thought what do we like to
have in chess connected rooks magnus
says you don't know what you're talking
about i'm the world champion i'm going
to play king to f8 and i understand it
because he didn't want to allow this
bishop to a4 and we were talking about
just to show that one more time that d
takes e4 is not possible with queen d7
check available to white the king is
just in huge trouble you're going to
lose material so that's why magnus
instead plus king to f8 and the point is
after e takes d5 the bishop can still
take because there is no king on f7
queen takes d5 was check with the queen
uh king there excuse me now queen takes
d5 loses the checkmate on c2 so this
opens up the board f3 is under attack
over here the c file is open the knight
can come back to the center with f5 so
all this stuff becomes available to
black and
if queen comes to b4 check i think he's
just going to slide his king over to g8
and he may go down two pawns here fiona
because queen b3 pins the pawn protects
the pawn c2 but the queen doesn't want
to do the bishop's job it was so much
nicer when the bishop was on b3 because
you're not tying your most valuable
piece to a pawn the problem with a queen
protecting something is that when the
queen is attacked it almost always has
to move when a bishop is attacked
if it's protected then you don't have to
move it so after e takes uh sorry knight
of seven first to block the pin e takes
d5 we get in this position with a
blockade this queen on b3 not a stable
defender the rook can come to b8 at some
point the king will move out the way
this rook can come down the h file
somewhere
so much energetic play so many options
for black that even if the evaluation
bar says something neither player cares
yeah i mean i think this is one of the
games where we'll just sort of have to
try and discard the bar
because
magnus he clearly has an idea in mind
um
rook king f8 looks strange of course uh
well one of the questions you might be
wondering we talked about king safety
but i think in this game robert there
was just never any moment for magnus
really uh to to castle
no and we have grandmaster nim in the
chat who played in pogchamps and is
rooting for nils and you know this is a
good instructive moment for many people
because we hear that we need a castle we
need to connect our rooks play in the
center
all the rules are out the window this is
a game where it's mayhem the both kings
are going to be in some danger into who
is able to both defend and attack
simultaneously you can't go all in for
your opponent's king if your king's in
danger and you don't want to be too
defensive you don't want to be like a
turtle in the shell you need to stick
your head out every once in a while and
try to poke at your opponent's king so
here king f8 i really like the choice i
think it's better than king to f7 and
there may be some forcing lines here
fiona but it's not going to be easy to
calculate no and we see nils there well
on the big screen
doing some calculations he was about to
reach out make a move but i think niels
has got to be happy as well to have
gotten a position okay it's going to be
a tough game for sure but
it's a game where all three results are
on the table and
i think he overall should be quite happy
with what he's gotten he has just made a
move and well you said you don't really
want to bring your queen to b3 so neil
decides he's not gonna get too greedy
but he wants to to bring that bishop to
b3
did you see the evaluation bar though
you know i don't i don't like it but it
went from adv advantage for white to
now it's a
50 50 battle and the big difference for
magnus you know the king being on f8 is
that after d4 there's no bishop b3 with
check so black essentially gains a tempo
compared to the variation where the king
was on f7 bishop b3 still may be a good
move but now the knight can come to f7
the knight can try to come to d6 then
try to work his way all the way to c4
for example so
magnus saves himself an important tempo
and
something else here is the rook is
developed on h8 that may seem ridiculous
what do you mean the rook is developed
we put our rooks in the center the rook
has an open file in front of it so
especially if the queens came off if we
just force the queens off i know i do
this sometimes you all get mad at me
because the terrible move just let it
happen queen a5
i can take a free queen i get it
everybody but we're not going to do that
here we're just going to queen d8 we're
going to trade queens and then this type
of position is let's say even take with
the knight but the point is that this
rook
is on a great line so it is developed
where it currently sits it can go to h3
attack f3 h2 pawn is isolated and that
means it needs to be defended by a piece
rather than with a pawn and so then
black will have plenty of compensation
in a situation like this with the rook
on h8
yes so uh i liked what you're pointing
out to work on h8 although it hasn't
moved it is an active
piece in this position and actually i
think maybe one more time just to be
completely clear here i saw a question
in the chat after nielsen's last move uh
bishop a4 when the bar went down i saw a
question in the chat what was the
winning move because it looked like the
bar was so high up but i think robert
it's really
important to to really
explain magnus no he hadn't blundered
magnus isn't necessarily a magnus well
definitely isn't in a losing position
here i think
maybe the engine uh is not as a super
deep uh depth and sometimes it's hard
for them to understand these positions
where one side gives up as much as as
two pawns
and still has play
and as we know well there's a big
difference between what the engine says
and what the players feel engines are
better than humans the chess even magnus
carlsen so the line we were looking at
with queen b4 checks something like this
where the king hides on jade even when i
you know you make the move uh queen
before check which i actually did look
because i wanted to verify
that is the best move as the depth as
the moves happen and the depth goes up
saying actually this is really not so
clear here with queen of b3 and then
knight to f7 white is better e takes d5
knight d6 we're talking about this
variation but when players who don't
have the evaluation bar they sit and
think about this position i promise you
many of the top players probably
what would you say 75 percent maybe even
90 percent a very high percentage would
say i'm taking black here 90 is too high
i mean you have two extra pawns for
white but a large percentage of players
would say i'd rather be down the
material in going for the attack than
being up the material white can
stabilize but it's not going to be easy
with the queen and the rook so perfectly
placed here a move like say bishop d3
let's protect against checkmate looks
like a good move oh wait a second the
evaluation bar is going down and why is
that maybe it's because d5 can be
targeted the rook on h8 is still in a
good spot queen c5 comes to mind the 996
is so strong here d5 is in trouble so
i get it the evaluation bar says
something we all want to be like oh why
does we it's how could he make a mistake
we don't want to get our pitchforks out
and go for the players because the
position is so complicated
that natural moves bishop d3 protects
the pawn on c2 but then it gets into
trouble in d5 if instead you play bishop
to e2 i want to save my bishop and i
want to get out the way i promise you
that a move like rook h4 is going to be
nasty that rook is coming into the game
and
white has all these threats that he'd be
dealt with and the black king suddenly
is the safe one
yeah indeed so
so much more to this position than just
the evolution bar going up and down
robert let's bring back the bird's eye
view as magnus ponders his
next
move
and
i mean today is really just such an
incredibly messy day i don't even know
usually my eye goes to one game in
particular but today it's just
i mean this bird's-eye view looks like
someone just threw a million pieces at
random all over the place
yeah and it's making me make bold
statements like giving percentages which
i never ever do it's just such a wild
day here uh we see from game to game
look at the car wanna gaming against
jessapanko it looks like fabiano based
on the bar there has a big advantage and
i can believe that he's up a pawn e6
just played by jordan von forest his
knight is under attack on d4 he says i
don't care you take my knight i get your
bishop that one looks exciting of course
the game between duda and karjakin where
karjakin's king has not left the center
and then we have rapport against
prognonda where during the break fiona
we're talking about that game as well
that's the bottom left-hand side of the
screen that game is really interesting
because white's king is in the center
white is up a pawn but i think that
black has good chances so pragnanda
playing some great chess
yeah i mean i don't even know maybe we
start with
jesse panko against karana and we could
go in that order yes panko and then van
forest and then report what do you think
okay i i'm gonna listen to you and
yeah this position i'm i'm gonna side
with the eval bar i like to fight it
against our engine overlords but i look
at this position and if we go back even
a turn bishop takes e5 the knight came
to e2 so 92 looks like it's trying for
knight d4 i i guess um
i don't
really like that move if i'm being
honest it feels like
you're down upon and retreating and
black's response c5 takes care of the d4
square and opens the bishop up to the e4
pawn all at once i think that was a step
in the wrong direction fiona yeah i
think in general uh
i'm curious to see what is the essay
pancreas next move could he have missed
something even if we look at him on the
camera he doesn't look too happy
as a rule of thumb of course there are
exceptions i think so important what you
were saying if you are the one that's
given up uh material in general
retreating moves are not the way so 92
does look curious especially because c5
not only as you mentioned
takes away the square on d4 but also
looks down at the pawn
on e4 and the knight from e2
well it was looking at d4
and the other squares it can jump
through none of them look too
enticing f4 is not even possible because
black is looking down with both the
queen and the bishop
and knight g3 i mean
what's the idea knight g3 knight f5 all
seems um
very slow
it is because black will complete
that final piece development and knight
to e7 hits this pawn takes away f5
trades will help black here i mean if we
go back just even a move from where the
game is this knight on c3 it stops c5
because the b5 pawn even if that pawn
we're not hanging the d5 square is quite
important so
yeah this decision to play knight e2
perhaps taking on e5 just securing the
pair of bishops it does look like in
black can stabilize either with knight
takes e5 or even with pawn takes e5 we
didn't like pawn takes e5 before when
the knight could jump to g5 there is no
knight there
anymore so knight f6 could be next and
yeah black's up a pawn
white does have the pair of bishops an
open board i would still take black in
this position i i really would i think
it's easier to play
well if you already would have taken
black here then of course there is no
question as to the current position
which is a so much better
version also the bishop from f1
at least that was looking down at
the pawns uh on on c4 and on b5
right now where can that go it cannot go
to to h3 where it might want to go but
the rook from h8 is looking down the h
file
um so yeah it's hard to hard to see a
an active plan here for for white
at first sight so
robert could today be the day that
fabiano scores his first win here
he has a great position and like the
other game the rook is developed on h8
you're pointing out that the h3 square
is unavailable which is really important
because bishop h3 would be a nasty move
so that's not available and fabiano's
position looks great
the bishop on f1 not doing very much you
mentioned how at least it was staring at
the pawns over there on the queen side
and a move like a4 trying to break down
the pawn structure
are you really going to take on c4
that's the big question because after
say b4 queen takes c4 i'm already
looking with like knight b6 queen c6
aiming at e4 aiming at a4 and in general
you don't really want to push pawns in
front of your own king and
i'm really not liking the look of this
position for white no and it looks like
yes panko himself
um
i mean i don't know him super well but
you can almost tell from the body
language that
he is not as happy
uh you can almost sense that something
has gone a little bit wrong here but we
will come back here
uh for now well
today it almost feels like we have to go
to bird's eye every time in between to
make sure we don't miss any dramatic uh
developments but we've seen the van
forest my mediarov game that pawn is
still only six marmadyarov hasn't made
his decision yet so maybe it's time for
us to to jump in there
let's do it let's go to
jordan the
champion from 2021 and vikings a against
mahmoud who's the champion of people's
hearts especially when he has his hood
up right like he does right now the move
c5 was the last move played by the way
robert just about to go back to the hood
um
niels
two days ago told me that it was
actually really cold in the playing hall
so it looks like that
might just be the reason it might just
be cold protection
that's it's good to stay warm
he's just warming up in the tournament
he won his last game and this one's
getting really sharp because c5 was the
last one played by black and then e6 is
the response so many of us say i need to
move my knights under attack but the
pawn attacks the knight and also
threatens c4 with a fork of the bishop
and the queen so you can't move your
knight without losing material and so
this was all planned by jordan we can
even take a couple moves back here
knight d4 played so c5 i take your
bishop that's clear bishop d7 knight f3
welcoming c5 because of this move
six and fiona i i think that's a free
pawn right just pawn takes e6 why not
and as you'll see
knight g5 i put your pawn on the square
so that i can take it and there's a
checkmate thread on h7 so you're filling
the square and essentially removing the
guard because that f7 pawn covered e6
but if your f7 pawn is on e6 there's no
extra pawn coming to f7 to defend it so
knight g5 is a wonderful tactic with a
double attack a very nice move here
which would leave jordan with a
a huge advantage so we see that shahi
had no interest in taking on f6
instead he dropped a bishop back uh to
e8
what a move i i don't know if i would
have been able to play that move i would
have thought about taking this knight or
playing c4 that's still available to win
this bishop in this bishop trade but he
goes bishop e8 here
and if takes on f7 he will be able to
take back with his bishop and you see
the evaluation bar plummet the reason
why this knight's under attack c4
remains a threat that's going to win a
piece as it's a fork if you try some
funny business with knight g5 now i
block your checkmate threat with bishop
g6 and i stop checkmate while attacking
your queen i win your knight on d4 at
the very best for white you get two
minor ps a rook excuse me for two of
your minor pieces but that's going to be
completely losing for example in this
line you win the rook but i already took
one night i will take a second and
just to
finish this variation
two pieces are way better than a rook
here
yeah so this cannot uh be the way for
jordan instead do we have to get one of
our pieces out of the way and create
some threats how do we do that well we
can retreat the bishop to c2 we're
threatening checkmate on h7 and at the
same time we stepped out of the
the fork with uh
with c4 hitting the the bishop and the
queen yeah bishop sits c2 only moved
very important move and now there's a
big question for mama jarov you know
that your
king is in trouble how do you block the
diagonal do you play g6 which allows a
trade on f7 but opens up the f file and
that could be nice you also have the
bishop pair or do you play a move like
f5 which leaves white with a pass pawn
but also leaves black with the
opportunity to bring the bishop over to
b5 once the knight retreats and maybe
this e6 pawn while passed has wandered
too far so later in the game i can start
attacking it with my pieces and you
can't defend it with another pawn
yeah i mean this position is crazy i
don't know what to make of this for now
white will have to move the knight
from d4 which is attacked
it's such a so hard to say is this pawn
on e6 is that a strength is it a
weakness black also has some holes on
the dark squares there's a big hole
on e5 uh thankfully for black white
doesn't have a dark squared bishop any
longer but
i find these well this position so hard
to evaluate robert so i'm very thankful
to our silicon friends who informs me
there's once again just a zero zero
equality
but isn't that worse in a way because
you're like
thinking about the position so i don't
even know which side that would take and
then the evaluation bar says zero so
it's kind of like uh it's supposed to be
level it's dynamic equality but that
doesn't really inform you that much
that's the
answer to the evaluation the objective
evaluation but it doesn't tell you the
why what you should do here
is there but why and we always are
trying to figure out the why
so i think this position is really
complex they'll sit and think for a
while jordan trying to
figure out do i take on f7 first do i
drop the bishop back to c2 how am i
gonna go about this e takes f7 we just
discussed it's a very bad move he will
not play that he will play bishop c2 and
he's just trying to come up with his
next few moves after bishop c2 and will
mama jar play g6 or f5 yeah plenty to
consider for both players here so we'll
leave them to it
and bring back the bird's eye view
i know well we're going to go to rapport
and pragnanda but i also see
ozzy malek's in the chat no yeah olisie
malek's
asking is duda losing well we see that
the bar has dropped uh down into black's
favor so first we'll check in which
report in pregnant and then we'll go and
see what's happening in the duda game
okay well i do not like the look of
reports position
we see that on the screen here in the
bottom left and we'll pull the game up
so we can analyze a bit but the position
is such that
white is up a pawn
and this has been a theme in some games
extra material doesn't mean you have an
advantage necessarily and right now
white doesn't have an advantage your
king is in the center how is your bishop
going to get out you'll have to make a
move like e3 but when you make a move
like e3 you're opening up the board more
while your king remains in the center so
we should go back a few moves at this
point knight f3 was played and e5 this
is a standard response from pragnanda i
played this position from the black side
since i was like 13 years old and you
have to be willing to part with material
knight takes e5 that looks like a second
pawn that you can capture but black
doesn't even need to capture this knight
you can take this pawn on c5 and what
you've really done from black's
perspective by playing e5 was open up
your bishop on c8 you want you're
opening up the e file for your rook this
knight can come into e4 or if white's
not careful can come into b3 this queen
has a5 check
at some point not now because b4 would
be a good response but there's so many
threats in this position fiona that
white is just moving the same pieces and
capturing material and black is opening
up the board for his pieces in a way
that's not going to be fun for the white
king to see indeed so uh richard decided
well he did not want to allow any of
this instead trying to keep
things together by putting the rook
2d1
black also activates his rook but
yeah this king is a serious concern
robert you told us at the start of the
show you have experience with this
position especially from the black side
i guess you would be quite happy here
playing uh in prague's shoes
i would and i've lost games from the
black side it's not like
i play this and i win of course not i
actually have had some difficulties
because uh in this position white i
believe should castle queenside and it's
a position that's really tricky
generally speaking i mean the pawn c5
can't be captured just yet because now
the pawn will be captured and the rook
is in a good spot so you have to time
things very well and e3 is coming the
rook is in line with the queen here so
you can open up the board more when your
king is safe and not the king is safe
here but it is at least a bit tucked
away so
rook d1
it makes sense cows and queen side very
difficult to play when you have pawns
that are advanced the way that these
pawns are but rook d1 rookie 8 and b4
black quickly strikes with a5 opening up
a new front of the attack knight
retreats to d2 and a takes before a
takes b4 this is where we are in the
game and fiona black with the great
center with control of the open a file
really the only thing that has white in
this game and probably feeling decent is
that you have the extra pawn and if the
queens get traded and white's king gets
safe then maybe we'll feel that presence
of the extra pawn but for now
it's not the story it's about the king
and i would play e4 for black e4 looks
really very tempting um
to just
ask that king i mean the pawns are
getting closer to the enemy king which
right now looks uh rather
rather terrifying only one completely
stuck and we don't see how that king is
gonna get castled anytime soon
look at those black pawns i mean usually
the pawn center is with the pawns on d5
and e5 but here those pawns have just
taken
even more ground both into
dwight's position and yeah i'm loving
loving pragnandaz
the way he's handled this
you know you play e3 i'm going to get my
bishop at a long last and then you see
d3 happen and black just sinking his
teeth in the position and you see the
bar is not sure it's like oh white could
have some chances here the only way to
get this bishop out is to play f3 and
chisel out this pawn structure but when
you play a move like f3 you're creating
new problems for your king so there
is a potential that white is able to you
know get all the pieces out and
challenge black's dominating center here
but it
looks really iffy at the very least
indeed uh and well will can see prague
two days ago he won his first game here
in the masters can he make it 200 trot
we'll find out later today for now let's
quickly go back to the bird's
eye view
i mean
i'm repeating myself robert but every
single game is just on fire today
even the duboff shanklin game
that game they repeated some bishop
moves a couple times and is duboff
currently down a piece
he sacrificed a piece temporarily but he
has two pawns for it the rook on a8 oh
my gosh even the game that was looking
the quietest is now also
heating up
shall we you know what we'll do we'll
stick to our promises of having a quick
look at duda karjakin then we'll go on a
very quick break and then with renewed
energy we'll come and try and come and
figure out what's happening in that
dubai shankland game
yeah let's take a look we last saw the
knight was on h3 and whitehead just
castled black plays knight f6 and here
duda decided to strike with the move e5
and we can see that the evaluation bar
is not thrilled about it the knight can
get this d5 square
and there was a trade which duda was
okay with because his knight came to f4
putting pressure on this bishop and i
think
instinctively we want to move the bishop
away we don't want to give it up but
karjakin knows better if he moves that's
not the bishop that's the bishop if he
moves bishop back to b7 saving that
piece in comes moves like bishop e3 and
d5 and b3 and i'm just trying to open up
the entire board against your king on
e8 to start with d5 makes perfect sense
you're trying to threaten this e6 pawn
if it's captured your knight comes in
it's going to be a bad situation for
black the bishop can come to f3 as well
so that's why he went knight c6 and duda
did not take on d5 if you capture on d5
pawn takes d5 back this pawn looks like
a bit of a target but so is the pawn on
d4 so you need to defend this pawn on d4
and by the time you do that black will
be able to develop the bishop from f8
put the rook on d8 and castle kingside
so the knight on f4 fiona is actually
stronger i would imagine because at some
point after bishop e3 black went rook to
d8 but this knight can come to h5 which
is really annoying for black to deal
with yeah the knight on h5 would be
looking down at the pawn
on g7 which makes it difficult for black
to develop uh his final piece the bishop
for my fate because as a black you
really want to i think just get castled
uh kingside so an annoying move from
that um
perspective
after rook d8
so that is the live position on the
board so
are you sorry you're saying knight h5 is
an option here yeah
it's an option here but it just you keep
it in your pocket so like that's the
annoying thing for black is like as soon
as you move your bishop from
f8 then the knight can come to h5 you
can also put the knight on h5 now but i
i
would want to challenge black a little
more for the time being i'm just not
sure
where to do that from
by the way sorry fiona but look at the
clock karjakin well oh my goodness
do that down to 35 minutes only i hadn't
seen that
that is
a huge
huge time deficit we're only on move
and while duda also clearly uh not
looking too happy on the camera
yeah i'm trying to come up with a move
for him here he's trying to do the same
and knight takes d5 we're talking about
that as an option it still exists after
knight takes d5 that
black will still take with the pawn if
you take with the rook that's how you
get yourself in trouble you see a bishop
you see a queen bishops usually win that
battle and it's not the end of the world
after bishop f3 because rook d7 or rook
d8 something like that let's go back to
d8 oh that's the wrong move ah because
bishop takes c6 and rook takes a7 so
rook d7 is in fact better and d5 looks
like it just wins material but the pawn
on d5 is pinned to the queen this is
really important because it would be
losing for black if not for that fact
and so bishop c5 finishing development
and you can't take on c6 without losing
your queen
um incredible lines here
so plenty to figure out for do that
because the tactics at the moment seem
to all be working in
black's favor but he's gonna have to
come up with a plan soon here as time is
ticking down we are back in the birds no
we're back on our cameras robert we're
gonna go on a very quick break but what
a day of chess it is you don't want to
go away i think today we're in
for a lot of treats so we'll be back
with all the action here in just a few
minutes
[Music]
so
tournament ambassador win in 2022
robert that is the question
uh we don't know the answer but what we
do know is that things are happening in
his game where vivid has just played g5
he has indeed and what
what a day it's already been and it's
going to continue to be the last few
moves we saw 92 we saw
quite a bit of time spent on f6 which
makes sense a pawn three squares away
from a knight limits the knight so the
knight on f3 uh doesn't have too many
places to go to it also covers his
important e5 square and after a3
here comes g5 fiona and this move it may
look aggressive but in some ways it's
defensive because i believe that vidit
is uncomfortable he's down
half an hour on the clock he's trying to
figure out what to do and white's plan
is much more obvious to come by he won
a3 he wants to move his queen maybe
queen c2 play for b4 and when you make a
move like g5 all of a sudden you create
threats of your own which means that
white can't singularly focus on his
ideas on the queen side
also could there be some element of
taking away any possibilities of knight
h4 and make sure that
light squared bishop can stay on that
diagonal drop back to g6
that's a great point that the bishop can
tuck behind the pawn and that way it
can't be kicked because knight h4 would
have been annoying for this bishop on f5
so you're absolutely right and
this position
you know you don't really want to play
g5 but if we look where white's
attention is focused it's not on the
king side so g5 you typically don't push
pawns in front of your king because your
king becomes exposed easier to attack
what attack i mean look where black's
pieces are look where whites are it
doesn't seem like this king is in any
danger so i do like the move g5
yeah we'll see how anish reacts i mean
can he just continue with his plan
anyway of trying to get b4 in or do you
feel he should react to g5 in a way
let's see so queen c2 would be
the way to try to make b4 happen looks
reasonable i'm trying to figure out
what's happening on this diagonal is
there some pressure against this knight
then i is defended but maybe in general
bishop on g6 is just a good square for
it at some point if
white really ignores the king side don't
be surprised if f5 f4 becomes an option
you can throw your h-pawn on the board i
don't think you want to move this h pawn
but you can
at some moment and you know it's unclear
even after b4 how much white is really
getting here b5 is covered for now and
oftentimes even when b5 happens you can
ignore it move your knight back towards
the center so
it's interesting this game is really
really interesting
we will come back to it i think we'll
bring up the bird's eye view for a
second because another game where a lot
has been happening is anish
anish's fellow countryman jordan then
for race we can already see from the
bird's eye view that things has have
changed drastically there so let's catch
up
and it's the second game in a row where
mama jarv will have a material imbalance
of two minor pieces for a rook let's
just go back a few moves we saw e6
bishop e8 played by mama jarvis strong
move and here it looks like jordan he
was hopping forward trying to deliver a
checkmate going for the f7 pawn as well
and after f5 he's sitting here like my
knight's under attack c4 is this fork
that
i see coming i have to make him like
knight f7 because if bishop takes f7
now it's justified
rook f7 in comes the knight to e6 that's
a light square that my knight is planted
on i can bring a rook to e1 to reinforce
it i've stopped c4 by attacking your
queen even if you attack my knight with
queen to d6 getting out the way i can
play rookie one there is no c4 with the
queen unprotected on d6 i can just take
on c4 and win your pawn so that's not
going to work out for black so that's
what jordan was going for but fiona
mama jarov had other plans
he did have other plans he said you
think i have to take with the bishop
absolutely not rook takes f7 was played
by shaq and well the bar seems to agree
with him i saw of course a few shouts in
the shot
of the jordan has blundered so why is
rook takes f7 as so much stronger than
than taking with the bishop
we don't expect our opponent to take
with the more valuable piece but in this
case it's a great decision the reason
why after pawn takes rook bishop takes
back e6 is covered you need a tempo move
with this knight c takes d4 the obvious
threat but after that c4
hits the queen hits the bishop that is a
fork you don't have knight e6 because
the bishop covers the square which means
the knight has to move somewhere else
and in the game it was knight takes f5
but after c4 here this is a problem
bishop takes c4 do not just take back
because someone took your piece that
would be a mistake after dc for queen d8
check the rook would take and the knight
on e7 lost its defender white wins this
night wins the game being up in exchange
so what mama drive didn't said is he
took the knight on f5 and here at this
moment now jordan has a tough choice
does he take back on f5 does he try to
take this pawn in a6 but no matter what
he captures black has two minor pieces
for the rook that is good for the minor
pieces especially when the white king is
the one that's going to be in some
danger and the question i have for you
fiona is we saw mama jarv survive a
position where he had the rook for two
pieces uh a rook and um some pawns for
the pieces
now it's
jordan's turn to have the rook in a
couple pawns do we think that jordan has
some chances here and looking at the
body language
do you think that jordan already feels
like he's going to lose this game
i feel your i think jordan feels very
uncomfortable and and to answer the
other question i think this game uh is
very different from the game we saw two
days ago between
mahmoud yarov and duda because what is
the difference in this game uh
mamidierov's king is very safe on g8 two
days ago it looked like a life was
looking good for duda with the two
pieces but his king exactly robert was
in the middle of the board
so here it looks like shaq is just going
to get this nice material
um
advantage with the two pieces against
the rook with no compensation really for
for your in terms of black uh kings
being weak there's also not really any
uh pawn structure damage so i think what
what's on the horizon here for yoden
is a lot of suffering and no fun
and a big problem for white is that
these pawns the queen side pawns are on
the board because what you'd want to do
and it's a long ways away but if you
could trade the queenside pawns and say
trade the queens
now there's not as much to attack from
from black's point of view which means
not as much to defend from white's point
of view so that's the dream but it's not
gonna happen this bishop on f7 protects
this pawn and if the queens come off
let's say rook d1 just to sort of force
this i know you don't have to trade
queens
but we get to a position like this and
now white is okay i guess because
there's some threats but in general
having pawns on both sides of the board
is going to be an issue for white if
black can coordinate well because now
white's rooks will be tied down to some
pawns and then black has more pieces
right you have two pieces for a rook so
your bishops can start
maneuvering swinging into the position
and after rook to d1 queen f6 is that's
tunnel vision see i know i want the
queens off in theory but in this
particular position worsening my pawn
structure that's not the way we need to
find a better way and so queen moves say
to f8 makes more sense to me but i've
that's what we're trying to envision is
what future do we want for our pieces
for this game to take and a queen trade
on the right terms would be good for
black but even with the queens on the
board a bishop on a7 aiming at f2 it's
white's king that's in more danger than
blacks
yeah and we talk about the problems for
jordan but for mamidyarov i mean this
could potentially be his second uh
victory in a row
depending on what happens in the anish
giri game well
could be joining the leader pack uh
tonight and he's always a force to be
reckoned with
things are looking great here today for
him with the black pieces we will come
back to this game let's bring back the
bird's eye
view
and i mean robert i don't know when are
things going to get any easier here
because
things are mad
maybe we have to go to the the dubai
shankland game where duboff has
temporarily as you mentioned before the
break
given up
a piece for now so shall we go and
figure that out and then magnus carlsen
some things are happening there so we'll
head there next what about that
let's do it so we're going to go to the
duboff game because it was the tamest
game of the round and all of a sudden
white sacrifice appeased for some pawns
rook is hanging in the corner let's just
go back a few moves we saw the
do you think robert that what happened
was duboff took a stroll around the
playing hall saw all the other games and
thought
what is going on here i shall not be
outdone so easily came back to the void
and just threw a piece in there
i you know he did look at the other
boards like wait a second i have the
most boring game that's never happened
to me in my life and it looked like it
could have ended in a repetition they
were repeating bishop f4 knight h5 the
bishop finally came back to d2 and the
knight came back to f6 so this was good
play by shanklin he wasn't just playing
for a draw he was trying to make the
best moves and the knight does belong in
the center covering squares like e4 but
the knight was good on h5 kicking the
bishop away so look at this knight d3
back knight b6 c5 let's push our pawn
forward but shanklin was happy to waste
this time with his knight it wasn't a
waste the pawn went up to c5 which means
b6 will chisel at the pawn structure and
the bishop on c8 will finally be freed
that's what black means is to open up
the board and to help this poor bishop
on c8 so bishop b4 pawn to b6
captures now c6 is under attack doesn't
care about that bishop b4 queen takes c6
is played here and bishop a5 fiona the
rook is hanging on a8 that's why queen
takes c6 was even possible there's two
pieces under attack tranquil says go
ahead take my rook because after queen
takes a8 queen comes and takes on b6 um
there's a problem here where's that
queen going the answer might be nowhere
and yet the eval bar says of course
zeros
okay and uh well robert let me ask you
the the simple question here why
why i think there's only one way out for
the queen if you make a move like knight
to c3 say you're just saying i'm going
to get out of there the answer is no
bishop b7 happens you could take on a4
to hit the queen on b6 we just saw a
position where
mama jarov has the two minor pieces for
the rook so rook takes a is possible but
why do i have to give up my queen let's
play queen c7 if you're going to take my
queen it's going to cost you a rook not
a piece queen a7 is not good enough rook
8 still traps the queen it can't get out
of here without
being captured so that would give black
the material edge so that's why
knight c3 is not possible but knight c5
stops bishop to b7 and stops bishop to
a6 because the knight covers the square
now knight takes c5 gets rid of the
piece but after d takes c5 the queen's
under attack
it's still trapped over here in the
corner of the queen 65 but there's no
move for black to trap it bishop can't
go to b7 bishop can't go to a6 it can go
to d7 but then the queen has the a6
square so somehow this position
is level it looks wildly complicated to
my eyes but the eval bar
it's not confused it's not scared it
says yeah somewhere down the line this
should be equal but def must have seen
something here
or maybe he's looking for more who knows
but after bishop a5
he hasn't taken on a8 he has played b7
thumbs up for me
so b7 and well it looks like he's going
to get
his piece back as both the rook on the 8
and the bishop on c8 are hanging and
sam well he has quite quickly captured
the pawn uh that looked like
uh the normal move and after queen b7 so
uh duboff has got his piece uh back
he's currently got an extra pawn as well
that pawn on b2 and my question is can
sam win that pawn back is rook b8 an
optional
what do we do now is black
there's a problem this knight on d3 is
really well placed so rook b8 you'd want
to win the pawn unfortunately defended
robert that was so sneaky
i could tell what you were thinking
though you're like okay black can get b2
and white will get a4 i knew where your
brain was going and even that would be
an advantage uh for white
likely so the knight on d3 is just
perfectly placed here and what black is
going to still try to do is go after
this queen the queen e7
this queen still doesn't have that many
squares but if you eventually go to a
square like c6 or b5 the a4 pawn is
loose and there's no useful discovery
for instance i'm going to make some kind
of random move like e3 just
you know
a decent looking move and if you bring a
rook to b8 say this one the queen comes
to c6 and you're going to go after my
queen again but i can take your pawn and
your bishop has nowhere good to go to
take advantage of the fact that there's
a rook behind it so i i think that white
would be able to snake this queen out
and try to take this pawn on a4 so
that's bad news for sam shanklin where
the computer sees that it's not that bad
for black he of course recognized this
compensation but white is upon ahead and
i think it's a pretty clear pawn that
maybe black will find a way out
i'm not liking the position though yeah
i mean
incredible to me how duboff managed to
make something happen here and so fast i
think we didn't see it coming partly
because our attention today
so focused elsewhere here the main focus
seemed to be let's hope they don't do
for go for the early three-fold
repetition but yeah absolutely looks
like danny now in the driver's seat
we'll come back to this one and for now
let's bring up the bird's eye view again
for a second
and robert before we dive into the
magnus game is there anything catching
your attention
everything
i mean seriously every single board has
my attention
fiona
i mean in the top right we see that von
forest decided to keep his bishop by
taking the a6 pawn uh he has more
material on the board but that means
more material for black as well so the
knight went to d6 and coming to e4
caused problems for von forrest king
what happened in the duda game there's
like a trade of pawns on c4 there in the
middle and the the bottom row middle
position
what report against pragmata there's a
king on a fade the pawn went to d3
then i don't know where to go you tell
me and even in the
neos game against carlson i think we
probably have to go the world
championship yeah i think we should
start with that but things are really
happening everywhere we'll start here
come back to the i think the bird's eye
view we love it in general but never has
it been as so useful as today because
today it literally feels with every
minute that goes by
something is happening on some void
i mean look at this game and all of a
sudden black is the side for choice i
don't know
if
i i mean it's hard to evaluate to assess
the positions the players don't think of
these terms but this is what happens
when your king is feeling unsafe and
there's a lot of pressure the last few
moves by niels bishop b5 check and then
bishop a4 allowed d4 this was something
we were talking about a long while ago
fiona that this pawn chain is really
strong for black especially because it's
aiming towards the white king it's all
heading in the right direction and the
rook on h8 is the surprisingly powerful
piece that after bishop b3 knight f7
queen b4 check
i think the king can just move out of
the way here to g8 walking into a pin
but the pin is not so dangerous because
white doesn't have more material to
start attacking the black king
yeah and i i'm i'm curious i have to say
if king jade magnus is thinking i'm
i'm not too sure even what the
alternatives are what about the queen
trade queen e7 who do you feel a queen
trade would favor
uh well i think because white's up a
pawn here it will favor white
not so much i don't think that black's
in any big trouble but i do think that
in a position like this without the
queens on the board that this bishop in
particular on b3 is nice and there is
some hope for the bishop on b2 to later
get in the game
i'm not definitively saying that white
is uh doing that well i mean look at the
eval bar off to the side it says that
it's uh actually pretty close to level
and we can see that the rook on h8 well
placed isolated pawn on h2 the f3 e4
situation is stuck you can't move the
pawn to f4 because the e4 pawn will be
hanging the bishop isn't great maybe
there's some hope of a future on this
new diagonal on a3 but yeah black
clearly is solid despite being a pawn
down
i would like to go back actually to to
the position that we saw if magnus plays
king g8 i understand what you're saying
that pawn chain does look nice for black
to rook on h8
but on the other hand i'm curious if you
can explain to me how you're going to
continue from here because
i thought as black i would love to get
the knight into the game which for now i
cannot do because it is
pinned to my king i don't really see is
my is the black king going to go to h7
or uh how are you going to continue
increasing the pressure here it's a
position basically what i'm saying if i
wasn't looking at it with an engine i
would never
think that black is the one that's
better here
no it's a really good point because if
we just go back to the game just for a
second and before we make them with kg
on the board we see that bar says
minus 0.9 so in black's favor and well
honestly that was a big hint right
because queen e7 i'm looking at like i
don't think black is that much better
there if better at all after queen to e7
so that leaves king to g8 and it's scary
looking move because you are walking
into a pin so to answer your question
after king jade you know how is black
going to make some progress i think this
rook is going to try to work along the h
file
white needs to keep pretty much his
entire attention
towards the queen side so if this rook
can get in the game then it's going to
cause quite some serious problems and
once the rook leaves then the king can
follow behind it and it's not like the
black king is completely safe and
actually rook h3 could at some point if
the c2 pawns defended walk into a bishop
e6 i do have to be careful uh
about where to put the rook but
um it's
yeah i think that this rook can maybe
come to h4 that's a safer square and
then the king can move and the knight
then will try it's a long story right
there are so many different options here
in the position but having the eval bar
at our disposal that's making it much
more helpful right because if we didn't
have it or if it just had zeros now
we're all confused when it has advantage
for black
without the queens it's not going to be
that advantage and that's why i came to
kingdom g8 one of the the other
questions i had is as white and i know
it's going to take some time but i was
wondering can i if king g8 happens can i
try and engineer some counterplay on the
g file and i start maybe by rook d2 to
keep an eye on the pawn on
h2
while i try and dance swing the rook
over to g2 and the other rook to g1
that's a really good idea i think that
another option i'm just trying to figure
out all the possibilities in this
position so rook h4 comes to mind rook
h7 if i just want to sit defensively for
the time being but in positions like
this if we can get a knight versus
bishop we've talked about some previous
days the bishop pair is really strong
because you cover both color complexes
but when one of those bishops is traded
off then the knight can go to the color
that the bishop is not on so if i can
trade off these bishops this knight will
venture into a square like c4 right so
that's another option at some point for
black is i think i need to save my king
but eventually maybe i'll bring my
bishop to c4 and not just trade queens
which can happen but trade those bishops
that's really an important feat for
black to accomplish
i think that's a great point and yeah if
you just sit tight with the rook on h7
i'll struggle to make progress a lot to
figure out here well we will see for
starters does magnus play king j8
doesn't look like he has made up
his mind just yet with
the time ticking down for both players
we will come back here
in a bit robert let's bring back the
bird's eye view one
more time
uh where'd it go so many interesting
games the look at vidit pushing all his
pawns on the king side that looks like a
lot of fun
um
maybe we have to start there because i
think
otherwise we might have a riot
in the chat we don't want that to happen
so let's start with tournament leader
vidiq gujarati we left it off just a
move ago
when vidit pushed his g pawn to g5
anish did meet that with queen c2 we had
been wondering what's anish going to do
is he going to continue preparing the b4
push well also he's putting pressure
along that diagonal
and that it said none of that concerns
me let me throw my h-pawn up the board
as well
i'm trying to think about how to phrase
this i like it because vidi is not
afraid and he's also about to be even on
the clock
i'm not sure i like it from perspectives
i don't know where the attack is coming
from but i also don't really see what
white is to do here uh one thing that
comes to mind is you mentioned there's
pressure on this diagonal so moving my
knight from f3 to d2 like that's one of
the ideas that i would think about here
uh because the the knight can't take on
d2 without the bishop being in trouble
but as you see that's a mistake i make
plenty of those it's all right i i
i how many pieces am i attacking e4 with
not enough so i guess the night retreat
isn't ideal just yet but i'm trying to
put pressure all up on this e4 square i
mean i like your idea and uh well the
bar at least has gone back up into the
black territory but it's also
not so easy what does black do here you
do have you have three pieces on the
knight currently
there are three defenders but is f3
already
a threat here or what's going on
[Music]
hard to say with the bishop on e3 going
to be loose there as well
it's one of these moments where i really
need to think before i talk i i just
sometimes say things and then hope that
it all works out but i'm looking at this
position and they're like all these
pieces concentrated on the e-file the
bishops
and the emd files i should say the
bishops and knights there it's a very
compact structure so let's go to the
game position just take 92 back because
that wasn't approved of
by the evaluation bar here um and i'm
trying to figure out why exactly that is
and what could be better i mean b4 i was
just gonna ask you what if b4 does black
actually have any follow-up with his
pawn storm on the king side
or is he was he just trying to grab grab
some space um that's one of the things
i'm curious about
hmm
i'm also trying to figure this out like
you asked the question and i i wish i
had an immediate answer but i don't so
i'm being honest with you i mean to be
fair
today is a tough day because
sometimes i ask you questions which
which are like have to do with a general
chess understanding and and where do the
pieces go and what are the plans but
today every game is so concrete every
game is such a tactical mess
and being put on the spot well we see
the the evil bar but without seeing the
lines um i know that asking those
questions i will be putting you on the
spot a few times today or over this is
why classical chess the players have a
lot of time to think because when you
can make moves see oop the bar goes down
let's take it back let's find something
else
players often have a few moves in mind
before they actually make their turn
let's say there are four candidate moves
four possibilities that look about equal
and strength then you have to start
going down the branches you say all
right in option a there are three
different response i have to look at and
then i have to the first response i have
two different options so the second
response i have three options the third
response i have four options it branches
out in crazy ways right like a tree
branch so
that's how chess works and tell you to
sit and think and you can't afford to
miscalculate when you're at the board
for us we could say oh b4 maybe oh the
evaluation went down a little bit but it
still looks pretty good for white and
it's uh we're not as thorough because
we're not spending all our time and also
these players are the top players in the
world they are using all of that brain
power to process the position and you
see anish as he's trying to
figure out do i play b4 that's the plan
i've been going for it and from bitter's
perspective the one bad piece fiona is
this knight on a6 but how do we get that
piece back into the game white's pieces
are all well situated they're looking
really good in the center of the board
where much of the action is taking place
i would love to get this knight if i
could just throw my knight to like g6
i'd be a very very happy person but how
do i do that i'd have to move the bishop
then go knight c7 knight easy
it takes way too long and our opponent
would see it coming so it's about
improving our pieces maybe rookie seven
rookie eight but still i don't know
where that knight on a6 is going but i
also don't know what white needs to do
right now to
maximize the potential of position yeah
i think this is another game where plus
1.2 which is what the bar says and anish
about to make a move it looks like he
was reaching towards the the queen side
is it gonna be b4 what's it gonna be
uh i think a result here between the two
friends
a game where all three results are
possible it's not b4 instead anish
centralizes
the last piece that hadn't been
activated the rook from a1 which has
come
to d1
and well now robert we're back in this
situation where
what about vidit is he going to push one
of these king side pawns further is he
going to try and activate uh the knight
from a6 is he
like anish going to activate the final
rook for my 8 and just bring that to the
8 as well
so many things to consider here or 2 e h
rather which makes a lot more sense
so many options and you said push upon
on the king side if i play g4 then i
feel like i'm giving up this h4 square
which you mentioned earlier and if i
play h4 i'm already looking for tactics
you mentioned it is really great of you
to point out the bishop on f5 is loose
so if i can sacrifice my knight like
night okay it's not my turn anymore but
knight takes g5 just to show you what
we're talking about oh look not an
unreasonable move pawn takes g5 and f3
there are tactics in the air here and
it's a tactic that's actually a trade
white is not winning material you're
giving up a knight for one pawn and then
you're winning a knight for a pawn back
it's just a really interesting turn of
events so that's what i'm looking for
fiona you gave me the idea and that
leads me away from black playing h4
because now i'm thinking can i go knight
takes h4 pawn takes an f3 it looks
really sharp the king side is open for
both
whose king is worse off i'm not sure
black's pawn structure is worse but
there's so many pieces on the board that
attack is going to be real
yeah i mean this game is such a mess
we'll come back to it
we'll see well if it decides to go for
that or takes a more reasonable approach
but so many loose pieces so many tactics
in the air will come back here we see
that magnus carlsen has gone king g8 so
things shaping up to be very interesting
there
as
well and robert where would you like to
go back to next
i don't necessarily want to go to this
game but in the top right we see von
forrest against mama jarv we have chakra
on screen
some of those pawns are off the board so
we're talking about that what jordan
needs to do in order to try and salvage
a half point here if he can trade off
those queen side pawns and restrict
black's pieces he's actually doing a
great job of hanging in this game so
credit to him even though he made the
initial mistake he is still fighting on
and i think we have to go to the game
between report and pragnanda there's a
king on f8 there's a pawn on d3 for
black and yet the bar is saying
you know things are still really unclear
let's go there so we left off this game
not too long ago
or am i am i mistaken maybe we looked at
it during the break and i'm
i'm confusing that because while we were
on break we saw this interesting move uh
king f8 which robert hughes said that's
quite a deep move it's i think a move
that wouldn't be on our radar for a lot
of players myself included
in this position
i would never in a million years
consider king f8 but the idea uh it's a
simple one you want to play h6
ask that bishop where it's going to go
and you cannot do it while the king is
on g8 because then it runs into bishop
takes h6 with this problem with the ping
along the g file
and sometimes you can even do it here
because knight h5 hits the queen and
protects against the checkmate but it
gets really sharp and i'm sure
the lines were considered because like
queen g5 tries to trade queens uh
attacks the knight and then moves like
this and
there are positions where you play in
this manner but it's really hectic i
mean it's a lot to take in and for
pragananda you have to be practical uh
pragmatic i should say you don't have
that much time in these games so to go
to some wild variation like this is not
something he wanted instead he played
king to f8 as you said h6 is an option
queen runs over to b3 because if you
play h6 now there are actually squares
for the bishop to return to if their
queen was on g3 still g5 would trap the
bishop once over went to h4 so h6 bishop
h4 e4 played now
e3
d3 and we mentioned how f3
tries to break down this pawn chain but
not when your pawn e3 is under attack so
that's why
report when h3 here pragnan is back on
the clock and it seems like he just
wants to play g4 bishop g2 get his king
out of the center and then later he can
play a move like f3 when he's good and
ready
yeah and well we see that even the bar
has uh gone up a bit things for richard
maybe are looking up a little bit do you
think that uh king f8
uh while it looked like a very deep move
do you think it was maybe better to take
a more forward approach
i think so i think king f8 is one of
those moves you make that you know if
it's you're trying to figure out what to
do you don't want to commit yourself to
some over advanced pawn structure i mean
we looked here
at this moment to move e4 e3 d3 and
things do not look clear the move f3
certainly is available to white
and if you take on f3 here
so i take with the queen now project
with a knight and then go after your d3
pawn although now that i made the move
it says you're wrong so let's not make
that move
why is that wrong exactly
my tactical vision is not strong enough
to figure it out
um
where where's the issue
i don't know i'm gonna be honest i don't
know let me let me look i can look i can
cheat aha okay i'm cheating knight takes
c5 knight takes c i mean what
what what kind of move is that
oh my goodness giving up the piece and
it looks like the king but okay you
still have to show me i will take the
knight and you'll have to show me why is
my king
uh
not safe here
because the knight now can go to e4
as the
queen is no longer nd8 and so if you
save your bishop with a move like queen
h4 or something like that
i
i don't
let me let me let me look again and open
up
the moves here oh okay it says the best
move is f6 so you sacrifice a piece and
then just go f6 and after bishop f4
you play bishop f
what
okay nobody plays chess like this is uh
above my pay grade robert
yeah
this is ridiculous
why is f6 necessary just to play bishop
f5 i do understand that white can hardly
move that much is very clear to me the
king is stuck in the center there's a
pin here if you try to take this pawn on
d3 then you take this knight on d2 with
problems for the king rook takes d2
allows bishop takes d3 the rook is
pinned but
okay i think we see no fault with the
players when they can't find a
ridiculous sequence that the engine is
like yeah this is just winning for black
if this happened
let's go back to the live board because
we saw the players make a couple
of moves
or one move anyway the knight has come
into e5 and
well now again the question robert
the bar has shut up i
with my human eye my lowly human eye i
still like the look of this so black i'm
still not clear how is white uh going to
to get that bishop from f1 out and get
the king castled but
clearly the computers disagree
well the computers have
no fear whatsoever and it's all about
this with f3 because white is going to
have to play this move at some point to
free up his pieces
not right now necessarily but there is
going to be a moment where f3 is played
look at the king it can't move the
bishop it can't move and why can't it
move there's a the pawn chain that's
stopping bishop e2 from being played i
do like g5
it forced the bishop back to g3 so
there's no g4 for white and a move like
bishop h2 that's too slow like you're
putting your bishop back here you see
the evaluation oh it goes back to even
because of course it is zero
oh
this is so
it's so ridiculous it was like oh black
is better nope just kidding it's just
completely level
what no way and what that really means
is that with a hundred percent accuracy
the players can find their way through
this but
i was trying to go bishop h2 so i could
move my pawn play bishop g2 i figured
and i was using
some assumptions here that it'll just be
too slow because black's pieces are all
aimed
towards the enemy camp um
what other moves come to mind i would
say like queen c3 just attacking the
knight on
e5
uh i'm just trying to
put all the pressure i can on the square
and if you defend with me like queen e7
then
i could trade on the e5 square and then
we have to evaluate what happens here
let me guess it's gonna be zeroes at
some point no slightly better for black
and the reason why again your pieces
can't move f3 i take your e3 pawn is
loose so there there are definite
problems in this position for white to
figure out and even trying to liquidate
which says my king will be safer right
i'm trading pieces you still have issues
and the rook on a8 is very happy to be
there
as you say lots to figure out here for
richard report who was looking at the
position looking rather confused just a
second ago he's about
to make a move
uh i think queen queen b2 was his choice
so indeed putting pressure on the knight
on e5 we will come back to this game and
all the other ones after just a very
short break so don't go anywhere
[Music]
at tata steel we place artificial
intelligence into the center of our
innovation program so we can innovate
faster than ever before
advanced data analyzing techniques are
not only fun to work with but it really
helps me to work on sustainability for
example reducing dust emissions this is
a really important topic for me
we have developed the digital tools to
accurately predict the performance of
our products in the processes of our
customers
quantifying the performance of our
products is key in making our customers
and us successful
we achieve world-class processability by
using ai to forecast and control the
outcomes of over 2 000 simultaneous
reactions
we use cameras instead of eyes and
computers instead of human brains so in
the near future our factories can make
their own decisions
[Music]
welcome back as you've just seen uh
tomorrow we have a big conference here
the game changer uh uh talking about
a i and how
it's been used both in chess also there
will be people from tata steel so uh
well i'm very excited i won't be able to
watch it unfortunately since i'll be
here commentating but a woman i am
natasha reagan from england who
co-authored a game changer with matthew
sadler she will be here
taking part one of the speakers of this
event alongside peter heinelson a good
danish grandmaster and coach of uh world
champion magnus carlsen you can find out
uh find more information about this
event on our website tatasteelchat.com
and you can also find out how to
register i think today is the last day
to register to attend the conference
so head on over to
our website now to read more about this
really exciting a really interesting
topic of artificial intelligence in
chess and robert
it's very exciting here as well i think
uh first of all we're going to have to
go
to the game of our leader where
pieces are being traded off in geary
visited
yeah peace are traded off which might
indicate to some that this will be a
peaceful result but the game will
continue at least for a few moves i'm
just looking at all these games so much
excitement but let's rewind and vidit
came up with such a good idea he pushed
his kingside pawns we'll just rewind to
this point because he went f6 he went g5
he went h5 and then finally he showed us
his plan he goes queen h7 which now that
i see it i'm like that is so smart and
it's something that i would never have
seen myself that's why i love
commentating i love learning from the
best players in the world he puts his
queen on h7 and that means that this
bishop on d3 just like the bishop on f5
before is under some pressure and if you
try to play the move f3 now you're gonna
get in big trouble because the rook on
e8 is well positioned the bishop on five
is backed up by the queen so you can
make funny moves fancy moves like knight
to g3 as the queen and the bishop
the queen that excuse me protect the
bishop if you take the knight you lose
your bishop and now you see the problem
of playing f3 your bishop on e3 and the
e3 square are blacks for the taking so
that's why after queen h7 anisha i can't
do anything besides trade if you run
away black plays h3
you don't want to open up the h file for
the queen with the bishop staring down
from c7 and if you play g3 it comes
queen h5 in comes queen f3 that's a
checkmate attack on the light square so
fiona queen h7 was the key idea queen h7
such a stunning move demonstrating
really full board
awareness
with that queen swinging over there
after the h7
square was freed and using that pressure
along the the b1 h7 diagonal we've had a
few moves so let's see how anish uh
dealt with all of this
he decided that i don't want to see h3
happen i'm going to trade everything
knight takes e4 black took back with the
bishop if you take with the pawn on e4
now we see that white's pawns have some
mobility bishop c4 is check the king has
to move your king h8 in comes d5 and
unfortunately for vidic you're not quick
enough to launch your attack white is
ready to push this pawn to d6 and now
that's a protected pass pawn if you take
on d5 white simply takes back b7 is
under attack knight d4 becomes an option
white's pieces are just coming into the
game and that's not good news for black
your attack isn't strong enough to move
h3 white can ignore it with a move like
knight g3 i believe and there's not
gonna be a checkmate h6 g2 the pawn is
an umbrella for the king you can't bring
your queen to checkmate because the
pawn's already on the square the knight
blocks the diagonal and you see from the
evaluation bar that white is well ahead
as he can go after the black king so
fiona indeed so instead uh vidit
deciding to capture
uh on e4 with the bishop
and now we solve these traits the queens
came off the board as well and maybe we
need to take a moment to stop here in
the current position after
h3 because
well it seems like robert the bar uh is
telling us the development developments
have favored uh vidit i think even from
a human mind even from a human
perspective if we didn't see the bar it
felt like black was under some pressure
but he has solved all of that
in a really nice way
white is worse and it's not worse like
oh it's going to be easy draw and it's
worse
if you're not careful as white
look at where the pawns are and look at
where the pawns are cemented most
importantly dark square dark square
these two are also on dark squares
though they can move but importantly
this d4 pawn we talk about pawn chains
how they're only as strong as the base
pawn this pawn on b7 is impossible to
get to this pawn on d4 that could be a
problem as this knight will reroute
itself and so what black is looking for
as this game continues is to get this
knight in a position likely via c7 and
then potentially over to e6 and then d4
is a target that black would like to
exploit and if this knight comes to e6
or the k i can't draw my arrows the king
comes up to g6 watch out for some
further expansion from these pawns
black has so much to operate with and
white is kind of stuck likely going to
move the bishop and try to trade rooks
along the e file and even once the rooks
come off because the pawn's a dark
square black can attack that pawn and
white is stuck to the defense
so after the last white move king f1 i
loved your plan of first of all
activating i think that night on a6 we
talked about it a while ago the knight
isn't doing anything there so we want to
bring it into the game i think we want
to do it via c7 indeed and then come to
e6
which means we would have to move our
bishop from c7 that bishop doesn't have
any squares that we really want to go to
but what do you think out of d8 and b8
would probably rather choose d8
yes
i mean
like we're just doing it temporarily so
it's kind of a means to an end and if we
go bishop to b8 bishop d8 i'm not sure
how much of a difference it makes the
one difference it could make is if you
allow some pawn break that's not ideal
but here there isn't a clean pawn break
to have so i think that both moves
bishop to b8 and bishop d8 uh they both
make sense i'm trying to figure out why
maybe bishop d is better actually
because you can play f5 you are
protecting your pawn tactically on g5
and that creates an additional option
for black which is really good news for
vidit as he
he can i don't know if he will but he
can try to push for a win in this
position
and i think he well he certainly will i
think it will be
a relief to him to have gotten rid of
all the pressure that was on his
position and he knows i think that only
he can be better both players are
short-ish on time 27 minutes for niche
22 minutes for vidit we're only on move
24. uh but thankfully for vidit i mean i
think he's handled this position so well
and here well he is pressing uh without
having to take too many risks at all
because his position and there are no
obvious weaknesses his works are doubled
on the e-files so um things are looking
great for vidit
he has precisely zero to risk and that's
why i would play on if i were him he
knows that and you know he's having a
good tournament so there's no point of
just accepting a draw until that draw is
completely guaranteed if anish can say
trade all the rooks and bring the king
to d3 and
something like that where there's no
possible progress to be made so we'll
see if anish can find those type of
moves in the next few but for now vidit
can push forward without any danger
whatsoever absolutely we'll come back to
this game for now let's bring back the
bird's eye view robert one of the first
things that my eye is going to here is
the grandelias against carlson game
second from the left top where niels
after playing rook d2 he has now decided
to go all out i don't know if that's
where you want to go first or if there's
anything more pressing happening
no we could start there and that's a
really good game to go to because now
niels is trying to lash out his last
moves were rook d2
and magnus played bishop a6 he can get
his bishop to c4 at some point also
opens up the b file to attack the queen
and the bishop behind it so f4 was the
choice of niels because the bishop no
longer hits the e4 pawn
that said it's looking like a position
where the clock is going to matter there
are 16 tough moves to make this is move
24 f4
and
white's king is open black's king is
open
brook b8 already has the direct threat
of trying to win this bishop on b3 so
after rook b8 queen a4 is actually the
only square the queen has yes
i was like oh you need to stay
protecting the bishop you have no choice
and after bishop b5
the queen has to go back to b4 so
in a way that queen is on the verge of
being trapped but has just enough room
to survive if the bishop comes back to
e8 somewhere along this line then c4 is
opened up and you see the evaluation go
up in white's favor that's where the
queen needs to be able to go with the
protection of the bishop so magnus for
sure is not going to allow that no he
definitely won't
um
but yeah rook b8 looks like a very
tempting move to start with you want to
get on with your own
uh with your own business here on the on
the queen side
and the question will be after uh queen
b4
how do we proceed
from here
well magnus knows he's at least a draw
he can go bishop a6 bishop b5 and make a
draw he likely does not want to draw
here one idea is still rook h3 trying to
get this piece active and this bishop
now is in some trouble because the pawn
of c2 is pinned so
really really interesting position this
bishop can go anywhere bishop d3 bishop
e2 bishop f1 all put pressure on the
queen and the bishop behind it so like
let's say bishop f1 funny looking move
if the queen goes to a4
maybe i haven't really made any progress
my bishop is just on the other side i
don't get to promote though bishops the
other side don't get me a new queen
they don't but maybe
can we increase the pressure on the
bishop from from b3 with the other work
we'll just say okay my bishop on f1 is
hanging you can have it i'll go for your
bishop
and bringing the other rook which we've
been talking about robert you were
talking about it even from h8 that was
in the game despite not having made a
move maybe now it's the time to activate
that
absolutely because bishop takes f7 check
queen takes f7 it looks like white
steals a piece after rook takes f1 but
where is this queen on the diagonal it's
queen a2 hitting b2 if the bishop ever
could move which it can't without being
lost anyway queen b1 is checkmate so
this would be a blistering attack and
black's king perfectly safe on
g8 white's king about to be checkmated
down here so this is really a moment
fiona where after move like bishop f1 i
would even consider rook takes f1
because i give up my queen but now white
has lasker compensation of rook
bishop and pawn for a queen and there's
real pressure here that's building in
the position because black's king
doesn't feel that safe and white's king
feels a lot safer without that rook
barreling down at it i like that
suggestion a lot and i think if niels
gets the opportunity to give up the
queen for this i think he would be happy
because here the bishop pair comes to
life and more importantly we can stop
worrying about getting checkmated at
every turn
this this rook i mean coming to h3 now
or in the near future it's going to pose
some serious problems for neil's in this
position but we shouldn't forget the
black king does feel some of this heat
here the bishop on b3 pinning that
knight if you can increase the pressure
on the knight that would be a problem f
takes e5 he went f4 for a reason he
wants to open up the board because what
black needs is to keep this pawn chain
intact if this pawn on e5 were to take
on f4 it's not a free pawn rook i
believe can just take on d4 here now you
still remain upon up for white you have
an open d file you have a bishop that's
open on this diagonal all of white's
pieces improve and the extra material
leave niels ahead if magnus were to make
the mistake of taking on f4
well i don't think he will do that but
it seems like he hasn't quite made up
his mind will it be rook b8 or the other
options will come back to this game uh
in a short while for now let's bring
back
the bird's eye view one more time we see
that in ghee riveted in the top left
corner one pair of rooks
has come off the board
he was saying that's what anish was
probably looking for
i see one thing uh one bar which has
dropped almost all the way to the bottom
and that's on the top right corner in
the game between jordan and mamedyarov
robert maybe we go and see what's been
happening there
we should uh this looks like a position
that we
kind of foresaw in a way not this exact
one obviously but because there were
pawns remaining over on the queen side
the minor pieces with that pawn
it's going to be a problem for
the white side and if we just go back a
few moves or i mean honestly many moves
here
takes
bishop a6 knight came to d6 that was
good the bishop came to c5 he took the
pawn on a5 that's why he moved his
bishop so he could get this pawn
and h4 was played
h5 this is protected by a bishop looks
all fine and we're getting to this
moment here where jordan played c4
and after pawn takes c4 he gave this
check
and the king went to f8 because if the
king took
on h7 after queen takes f7 you have
three threats at once the knight the h5
pawn and the c4 pawn and this is exactly
what jordan would need i mentioned this
a long time ago right if those queenside
pawns are traded white has
some problems to deal with just because
two pieces a bishop and knight can team
up on a square and there's only one rook
but here it's safe and sound enough
because the king on h7 doesn't have the
best shelter so this would have been an
accomplishment and instead of this
shock play king f8 he realizes he needs
to keep this pawn on c4 bishop g6 and
now knight f6 so the big difference
fiona is after bishop f7 king f7 the
pawn remains on c4 and that pawn what a
difference
it makes
because well that is a pond that's only
three squares away from queening jordan
now tries to bring a piece in front of
that rook c1
attacking the pond but we see the bar
dropping all the way
so is there an immediate problem here
for for you for your den
and also what was you know
the move because it says zeroes which is
really surprising to me i wasn't looking
at the eval
until
now i saw a drop where is it dropping
from from zeros
like
you can give a check i mean you always
want to think about giving checks that
makes some sense but okay it's starting
to research but only slightly better for
black here
why is that why can't i go to g6 for
starters which is the square
uh that's
oh you're gonna check me oh and if king
h6 there's queen c1 and you get the pawn
so we actually just go to a position we
already saw king h7 queen 64 that's a
transposition
to the line we're just looking at so
basically king g6 isn't an option at all
and king e6 looks too scary for my life
suddenly it's reminiscent of
my media
but look at this if you're a rookie one
check
you lose the rook right so you know i
can't do that that would just be a
blunder oh i'm gonna checkmate you just
kidding i i've blundered myself but
queen check
can the king keep going i mean
is this going to be a vidit dubal type
of position where the king gets to e5
there's no rookie one because the queen
covers the square and you can can't
check on c7 there's a queen on a5 so
queen b8 check
i don't know i i want to go king d4 but
i'm a little scared so maybe
56 is also in the position and for now i
was going to say we stop any checks well
there is still one check on b2 i don't
think that's a new thing because we can
finally push the c pawn there is another
check in the position f4 i don't know if
that's anything sorry before yeah
in this position here
but now this king on g1 is really
open and the knight will come at g4 at
some point the c5 square for the bishop
or the queen it's one of these positions
where you know you have an engine and
tells you even so you probably follow a
string of checks and you know here queen
actually queen ca check will pick up
this pawn wow that's actually a very
direct
play
check if your king d5 or e1 check
happens oh no even worse queen f5 check
when you lose your queen
i mean it's easy to miss these things
when there is so many
i mean when the black king is so out of
the open you always feel like this just
has to there has to be something
for white uh in this case while you've
picked up the pawn maybe black still has
a little something because after f4 as
you were highlighting the white king is
suddenly
in a lot of danger
himself so even this position is far
from clear but
it looks like maybe queen b7 check was
the best opportunity for jordan and
instead well after rook c1
uh we see
saying you had your chance
to give the check on b7 that's not going
to happen any longer if you wonder well
why isn't didn't he defend the pawn on
c4 it's because after work takes well
this time once again we saw a similar
motive earlier today there is this
discovery with bishop takes f2 and the
rook is hanging at the end queen c7 such
a nice move and not only does it protect
c4 tactically it attacks g3 if this
queen were to leave the f3 square and go
to e2 to pile up more pressure queen
takes g3 is an option because the f2
pawn is pinned and it's like queen c3
just going right for this pawn bishop
takes f2 check is a problem the queen is
on a square that means it can get forked
by a knight after king f2 knight e4
check is a huge huge issue for white
yeah and while this pro this position um
is a big problem we see jordan there
at the board
i think he understands of course he is
in trouble it's not even easy like to to
find a move because
after shark's queen c7 well there are no
more checks
and
we just highlighted you cannot take on
uh you cannot take on c4 you cannot go
queen c3 which are two
uh
logical moves so a spot for urine where
it's suddenly even becoming difficult to
to make moves
but you know we we kind of excused his
mistake of not playing queen b7 check
but the more i think about it i mean
queen c7 isn't that difficult of a reply
to see it defends the pawn and in
general you want to be behind your past
pawn so you can push it forward some
more
so
and it defends the seventh rank there's
no more queen b7 because the queen is
here guarding the king so
while we
want to give players the benefit of the
doubt jordan is obviously an amazing
chess player he won vikings a last year
if he's going to repeat for his title
queen b7 check even if you don't see the
entirety of the follow-up because
obviously we didn't
nobody could sit here but i see
everything unless you have spent a large
period of time trying to work through
those complications but rook c1 you know
he needs to find these queen b7 check
moves i think that's the ultimate
stories he's capable of finding it it's
difficult sure a queen b7 czech and if
king g6 trying to hide we said queen to
b1 check and queen b7 if the king just
goes back to a square like f8 then queen
c8 check you think you're just repeating
the position a bit
yeah and uh funnily enough i see that
our producer was just wondering about
the very next thing i was going to ask
you or but if we go back to the the
current position on the board and that
was going to be my next question to you
could jordan's
idea have been a rook b1 here we're
trying to bring the rook into b7
it makes sense but i am going to stop
your threat by putting my bishop on b6
which opens up the pawn to start running
your queen still can't leave the
protection of the g3 square and my next
one is going to be c3
and then c2 and
[Music]
yeah
i was just saying i don't want to rush
putting my pawn on a light square
because especially as long as the king
is on f7 maybe
that's right so i i think c3 you know if
you're king g2 i play c3 and
you can't pile up pressure against my
bishop
yeah and here well
i i was uh sort of saying c2
tongue-in-cheek i take your point i
definitely don't want to do that
immediately maybe i can simply start by
getting my king out of the pin uh along
the f i'll try and find the safer square
for the king and then activate the
knight
and like if rook c1 i mean i don't
really see that many moves for white so
rook c1 then bishop d4 happens and
just
everything is defending each other
yeah i mean this uh looks like a
very uphill battle here for jordan
things are not looking good we'll come
back to this game let's go back to the
bird's eye view
of robert with three more than three
hours into the game all the games are
still going and all of them
are
so so wild
look at the duda game that's karjakin
how did that even happen
there's a king on h8 a king on h1 no
pawns in the g file
of course we've been looking at the
geary video game that looks like it's
stabilizing for a niche and then we see
grendelius carlson magnus still thinking
that's in the second from the left from
the top row um dubov he's up a pawn so
he's going to try to turn that extra
material into an even bigger advantage
and then panko still in some trouble
against caruana there and
wait reporting prognonda all the pieces
are gone what
yeah shall we check in with report
pregnant and then do that karyakin
sure let's go there that makes the most
sense and
we can't forget a robot report because
he lost his first round then he won two
in a row before drawing shanking with
black and suddenly he's the one with the
huge advantage because he has an extra
pawn the extra pawn that wasn't too
relevant for most the early stages of
the game after prague went 95
queen b2 fiona this was such a nice
moment by report to play rook a1
rookie won a very nice move uh seeing
what are the active pieces in black's
position what can i fight against well
what i want to fight for is right since
i don't have too much other too many
other options as well the bishop on f1
so let me alleviate the pressure on the
a file try and get those rooks of the
board and black maybe also didn't have
too much uh of a choice here
no because the knight on e5 needs the
defense of both the rook and the queen
so bishop d7 connects the rooks but your
rook on e8 gets distracted over here so
after bishop d7 i take your rook you
take back and i have two attackers on
your knight on e5 i simply win a piece
and
white's king is still in some danger but
a knight is a knight and fiona another
problem is this knight can't move
because bishop d6 would be a pin and a
win of the queen yeah and suddenly i
mean i don't know how it happened in
this game suddenly the tide is turning
and white is taking uh the upper hand i
feel like maybe starting really with
this move king f8 uh prague
it feels like he slightly lost the
thread uh of the position and i mean you
know you asked me on day one do you
prefer the material or do you prefer
to be material down and play with the
initiative and very often i mean this is
the story of my life you know i've
sacrificed upon it looks like i have
some nice
counter play some nice initiative and
then my opponent plays some great
defensive moves and suddenly here i am
upon down and my
initiative is gone
that's what happens when it fizzles out
and it was stubborn defense by report
but king f8 that as you were saying it
seemed like that was the start of a bad
trend for pragnanda and he still has
chances here let's be completely clear
about that if you look at this position
this e4 and d3 pawn that's keeping him
in this game and white doesn't have an
easy time trying to promote his past
pawn because you need to play b5 and c6
but as soon as you play b5 the c5 pawn
is loose if you try for f3
then the e3 pawn is under attack so even
at this moment here
it looks like bishop g2 somehow was a
mistake
and fiona
the only other plan i see besides bishop
to g2 which you probably want to play at
some point anyway
is
was there just some kind of king march i
don't see why you can't do that anyway
but maybe the king belongs towards the
center of the board that seems i like
that suggestion a lot i mean in this
game we spend so much time talking about
how the white king wants to castle
king's side get that into safety but
suddenly now with so many pieces having
come off the board indeed if we compare
the king if it can get to c3 and we
compare that to the king being on g1 of
course we would much rather have
the king on c3 supporting our queenside
majority
and i'm i'm wondering after the game
bishop g2 why you can't do that anyway
the reason why is that black retreats
the rook let's say rook to e8 after king
d1 there's rook a8 and this is the only
fully open file and you see the
evaluation turn in black's favor here
because rook a1 check already threatens
to win the game and if you play king c1
you're not in time because the rook
comes to a2 so this isn't oh my gosh
it's crazy how important a single move
is in chess and this bishop g2 move
which was i would have played
immediately and that's what i i thought
was a good move now i'm starting to
realize that black gets some activity
along the a file which is the only open
file on the board so prague
he should bring his rook back he should
bring it over to the a file and he will
be the first to the a file which is the
only fully open line on the board
yeah so i mean things still anything
could happen here the time is ticking
down both players now under 20 minutes
only 11
minutes 40 for richard report now just
on the 20 as i said for prague and we're
only on move 26 robert so 15 more moves
to make for prague 14 more for which i'd
we'll come back here uh let's bring up
the bird's eye view for just one second
and then yeah i think we're gonna have
to go
to do that karayaki and what are those
bishops both doing in the enemy camp
they're creating threats of sorts the
king is not thrilled to be on h8 nor is
the king really that thrilled to be on
h1 so both kings are in danger pieces
staring at them and when i look at this
position fiona it's easy to forget
there's a pawn on c3 like that's a
pretty advanced past pawn
yeah i mean that pawn looks uh mighty
mighty scary and well uh black he is
still
i'm counting that correctly black is
still up his pawn um it's difficult to
count upon sometimes when they are so
scattered around the board
but it is still an extra point for
karjakin and the question is can yan
shishtov make something happen here with
the bishop pair and the black king
looking uh maybe a tiny bit awkward in
the corner on h8
yeah jan schistov here
he has drummed up all the counter play
that
and more than he probably thought he was
going to get but here you see
at least go back just a few moves
because i i saw the eval bar at some
point was like oh black is doing really
really well and it says minus one and a
half but you look at the pawn structure
and if you cut the board in half black
has
from the a to the d files black has
three pawns to whites one and play a5 c3
is you know happened in the game but
then you look at the e through h file
white has four on three and a bishop
pair so you know that white's trying to
open the position and that's why f4 was
played and f5 was played and
karjakin plays f6 because he can't allow
f6 to happen his king will be in danger
and then e6 the knight is in a perfect
spot fiona knights are the best block
haters because they stop the pawn's
progress and also look over the pawn and
attack its defender but that is a
protected pass pawn of fiona so at first
glance
even though i see the evaluation where
i'm gonna ignore it i would say white
has really serious compensation and if i
were playing the game i don't think i
would know that white is any worse yeah
i completely agree with you and i i
guess that means that sergey karjakin
must have handled
this position pretty much perfectly
let's see what he did so he started with
g6
so attacking the base of the pawn chain
duda says let me defend that with my
pawn and now the king steps out of the
way
king h8 and king h1 both kings going to
the corner that way they're as safe as
possible given the opening of the g file
rook g8 and rook f1 the rook stepped
away from the f6 pawn that's why the
rook came to f1 and this is why karjakin
took at the moment you can't leave the
tension anymore because f6 is
uh in some trouble g5 trying to close
the position is going to get you in
potentially more trouble after h4 it's
not about pawn count it's about the
quality of the pieces let's say you keep
taking pawns g5 you keep taking pawns uh
you have how many extra pawns i don't
care because look at my past pawns on f5
and e6 yeah those pawns i mean
we can
potentially see two pawns appearing on
the six soon and they are very likely to
defend to decide the games in the game
in white's favor so
that's not what karjakin did instead of
g5 he took on f5 we saw those pawns come
off now the bishop dropped back 2d6
rook b1 hitting the queen on b6 the
queen drops back putting pressure on the
pawn on h2 which is under attack
so that was defended by removing the
bishop for me too which went to h5
and now sergey fighting for that uh open
b file
and the moves started happening quickly
i saw them make a bunch of moves there
and because look at the clock under five
minutes for jkd so to get to the live
board bishop h6 rook b1 rook b1 and
queen to c4 now all of a sudden duda
needs to find moves in a tactical
skirmish it's move 30 so his 31st move
coming out he has four minutes remaining
fiona for 10 moves plus the 30 second
increment he gets every single move he
makes not gonna be easy to navigate uh
the complications here that's an
understatement robert we're going to
take our last quick break before the
first time control which is coming up in
40 minutes all games are still ongoing
it could be a huge
hugely decisive game today with a lot of
games uh
looking like one player might be winning
so don't go anywhere and we'll be right
back
[Music]
so
and robert we have our first result of
the day as the game uh between
anishigiri and with it ended in a draw
but it was far from a friendly draw
no they're talking about the game
they'll resume being friends that the
game is done but they both were trying
their best anish he had a you know hit a
good position out of the opening vids
knight was awkwardly placed on a6 but
what vidic did on the king side you can
just tell he's in great form and it's
not just about his results he was
leading the tournament heading into the
round it's the way he's playing the
defense he showed against duboff that
was no fluke in this game he could have
been in some trouble not getting
checkmated but he threw his pawns
forward played queen h7 came up with
some really nice ideas and so anish's
advantage was neutralized and then it
was bidid who
maybe he had a slight little something
but in this final position
as i look at it it seems like a draw was
definitely the result that was going to
be had yes i'm very inspired to play uh
by vidit who first pushed his kingside
pawns and then this knight queen h7 move
but for now we're gonna go back to the
bird's eye view because we're only half
an hour away from the first
time control
um and well let's see robert where would
you like to to start
well i see a rook on h3 for nils sorry
for magnus against niels on the
top line there it looks like fabiano is
up two pawns on the king side but white
has an extra pawn in the center of the
board but it still looks very good for
fabi uh jordan is trying his best but
it's a bit
too late i would say
and i mean look at report brought his
king to d2 he blockaded the pawn it
brings knight to c3 where it attacks e4
and covers the a2 square we just looked
at duda against kayak and we can come
back there at any moment and dubois
remains upon ahead and he will try to
win that game but look at shanklin's
activity
maybe we start by very quickly updating
yesterday against fabiano we haven't
seen that in a really long time and then
we can go to grand alias against carlson
where the players repeat it twice but
then the third uh hurdle magnus said no
i want to play on and rent a rook h3 so
we'll get there in a moment but first
let's have a look at yes panko and
karana
well quickly rush through to see how we
got here c5 was played we saw this
moment knight takes knight takes and
bishop to g2 knight e7 knight f4 and
coming up here
where fabiano played king to b8 and then
b4 was played by andre you typically
don't push pawns in front of your king
but there's a problem for black along
the diagonal so b4 was actually a really
really nice move
yeah and fabiano well if you don't know
the rules here you might want to look
them up and the pawn on b4 is not can
not only be captured by the pawn on c5
but also the pawn on c4 which is what we
call ample song so that's what fabiano
um
did and now andre first swapping the
rooks on d8 then we're capturing on b3
with the pawn but now while fabiano has
this three versus one queenside majority
you were talking about
and it became a clear palm majority in
just a few moves rook c8 rook c1 going
for this pawn but after queen a5 can you
really get away with taking let's see
what happens bishop takes c5 it would
seem you stole a pawn you're happy about
it but then black has this tactical shot
knight to c4 where your queen no longer
protects the bishop if you take this
knight on e7 free pieces love them no
not free after all knight d2 is check
it's also checked to your queen so black
wins material there's a really nice
sequence that fabiano had and in the
game we saw
uh let me revert back i think queen a2
was played we saw a trade and then
followed him played c4 so he's getting
his knight to c4 uh by trading and yes
panko
moved his bishop
around and look at black's pieces fiona
it's a pawn ahead and the two on none on
the queen side over here and these
knights look perfectly placed kind of
everything seems to be going right for
fabiano
absolutely and fabiano i think this
position here also look at the time
situation
i failed to it was such a crazy day that
i i failed to notice how far down the
players on the clock only three minutes
for andreas panko to
navigate this position bobby firmly in
control and i think uh he is heading
towards uh his first tata steel chess
victory uh in this year
there's only one concern for him right
now as this g7 pawn so i think andre
played bishop h3 to go bishop f5 where
he defends both his e4 and his g6 pawn
so if he can go 96 and attack that pawn
and win it then andre has some real
chances so i think that's the main
reason why andre remains very much in
this game is because that pawn on g6 for
white is very strong and the pawn on g7
is a target
indeed we shouldn't underestimate of
course the pawn on g6 we'll come back to
this game let's go back
to the the bird's eye view
and i think the other game well we said
we were going to check in oh we had
another result actually duboff against
shankland has ended in a draw and while
we see that anish and with it they are
still discussing their game
i mean there were so many interesting
moments there but yeah two games have
ended in draws let's go and check in
with world champion magnus carlson
okay let's pull up that game here he's
playing a really tactical skirmish
with neil's grandiose he decided instead
of making a draw he decides that he
repeats to gain more time we see that
both players are really in some time
trouble considering they have many moves
to make until we get to move 40. rook h3
played he wants to play on f takes e5 f
takes e5 and there's no rook f1 there's
a bishop covering the square and if you
play rook f2 thinking you're just going
to win this night here magnus is going
to sacrifice material he is going to
play rook takes b3 and after queen takes
b3 he's going to play bishop c4 and his
queen has only
two options to go along the third rank
or to go to a4 if you go along the third
rank let's say somewhere like queen to
g3 there you see it queen b6 happens and
you can't protect your bishop on b2 in a
nice way if you play pawn to c3 you
defend the bishop for now but after pawn
takes you can't move your bishop queen
b1 would hurt queen takes c3 you're
opening up the position the queen the
rook everything is falling apart yeah
it's all collapsing here so it looks
like rook f2 is not something we want to
play because rook takes b3 just looks
absolutely
crushing
but if not work f2 then what
how do we
[Music]
not thrilled about it but still trying
to make up its mind what if i just move
my bishop if i'm magnus like a bishop a6
because you're threatening this bishop
on b3 the problem for white is that pawn
c2 is pinned because the queen on c7 so
a move like bishop a6 or one of these
funny moves i would definitely not play
bishop f1 that looks like the worst of
the bunch
but
you have moves with your bishop to
attack the queen and the b3 bishop
behind it
let's have a look at bishop a6 for
example
i think you have to take on f7 i have to
take on f7 here because otherwise the
bishop on b3 will be lost
so let's see bishop takes
can't take with the queen
wait a second and i don't want to go
with the king
so queen takes doesn't work because the
rook on b8 is hanging
and king takes what's the problem there
maybe there's no problem but i i don't
really like my king on
amazon at very least there's rook check
here there's also rook to g2 trying to
win this pawn and the queen behind it so
what is the insane engine move
well it's process of elimination we made
uh two of the moves it has to be
something like king h8
just move your king out of the way
because after queen a4 the queen is no
other safe square so queen a4 is
possible then we have the same situation
we saw earlier where the queen slides
into a2 but hold on i see that you i'm
don't have time to take on a6
you can have that bishop enjoy it queen
a2
i'm trying to hold things together but
i'm i'm struggling
as c4 i guess well i there's all sorts
of things wrong but on-pass song seems
to be the most convincing
uh
this rook is so helpful on h3 and rook
on h3 is uh
is a monster magnus was reaching out
magnus by the way five minutes on the
clock this was move 30 so 11 moves to
make
four magnus
but yeah we haven't found anything too
convincing at the moment for white
i mean king h8 if he if magnus plays
that instead of king takes f7
i wouldn't be surprised because he's
magnus
also he carlson come to asic's uh robert
instead he's gone to e2
okay
so he thinks that that's a better square
for his bishop and he's probably right
he's magnus
so bishop e2
should bishop b2 once again i think we
have to take on f7 right
i believe that's the case but now king
takes f7 is forced after bishop f7 uh
because you still can't take with the
queen the rook needs the defender and if
bishop f7 you move your king to h8 now
white can give up the queen for the rook
and then take a bishop so you have two
bishops and a rook for a queen if we
just do quick math that's five points
for the rook three points each for the
bishops that's what 10 11 yeah 11 points
for the white side and only 9 for black
plus the king is in trouble on h8 so
that wouldn't work out at all for magnus
so he is getting ready to bring his king
up into the board and fiona one of the
problems we saw with the king being on
f7 was this rook on d2 joining the party
the bishop on e2 cuts off its path
yeah that is true
let's put the position on the board
needs his thinking as well what could be
the alternatives
or is he just thinking how to follow up
here
i think he wants to make that next move
relatively quickly and i don't see any
moves for this queen either a sacrifice
and take this bishop but i don't think
it's going to be good enough so queen a4
is the only place for that queen to go
to but how do i mean would this rook can
come here as well
rook b3 is a crazy move one thing i'm
wondering after rook b3 am i never in
time to create anything against your
king let's say rook b3 if i take on e2
i just will not be in time or
you you might there's no i mean check
and queen c3 is the checkmate that's
where the knockout will happen so rook
g3 at
i guess right now would stop that you
cover c3 and your king can escape to d2
i
both kings look like they're in danger
white king does look a little worse
by a little i mean a lot worse but still
there's going to be some opportunities
for white to go after black's king as
well yeah i mean this game i think
absolutely all three results still
possible
magnus has got to be a small favorite
but especially with this time situation
i mean 10 moves to go on each side and
the position is so wild
i think maybe robert we have time to go
away one final time but i think this
game will very likely be our main focus
as we
lead into the first uh time control
let's see well yes pengo did put the
bishop on f5 in the second from the
right on the top line there and fabi
activated his rook we see that jordan
unfortunately for him you know the
evaluation hasn't changed he still will
fight on he has some chances especially
if mama jarv has a top right board there
if he allows that rook to sacrifice
itself for the pawn and the bishop there
will be some chances if the rook can get
rid of that pawn somehow even if it
costs material rapport is doing well his
king is on c3 but pragnanda he's taking
a page out of five minute karwana's book
we see fabiano's work on h2 his works on
a2 causing all sorts of problems for
white's position and then duda against
cardiac and who knows what's happening
nobody does but it looks really fun that
is really well i don't know if you want
to check in with dudan kariaki no if we
stay with gwandelius i'll leave it up to
you robert
let's go to dude versus karjak and we
saw that uh jkd young chistov duda was
in quite a deal of time trouble and
wait a second what do their last few
moves have been
so
this queen
went to a2 to attack the rook the rook
went to c1 the knight was the c6 and
then rook g1 because the knight went
away from the safety of the king the
knight comes back to e7 this is really
important
if you allow rook takes g8
king takes g8 and the queen comes to g2
it's checkmate on g7 that's why having
the knight on e7 is so important because
when
the knight is there if you take on g8
the knight captures back and attacks the
bishop so there's no time for white to
go queen g2 you simply lose your bishop
and that would win block the game so
that's why
karjakin is bringing his knight back to
e7 and then dudes bring his rook over to
c1 but what a resource by ian sheshed of
duda i think karjakin does not want to
repeat it felt like he was the one in
control here
but suddenly how do you keep making
progress if you can't bring the knight
from e7
and your pawn on c3 is attacked
and queen h4 you have to watch out for
that as well
like if you play queen b2 you're just
attacking this rook you're protecting
the pawn so this queen h4 looks very
scary here
how do you even defend that pawn
how is this equal
zero zeros
how
well i guess the pawn can't be defended
so that probably means we have to stop
queen f6 in a different way
is it something insane with rook g5 and
there being some problems with your own
work hanging on c1 what's going on here
rook g5 bishop takes
pawn takes queen has to take i guess to
defend the rook on c1
now take on e2
and now it looks like checkmate it looks
like checkmate but you have knight g6 oh
my goodness
take on g6 there's queen takes h2 check
and mate so instead of taking on g6 the
pawn you take with the rook and then you
make a draw this way because the king
can't go to f7 there's
f8 rather there's the maiden f7 and king
here we just go back and forth so of
course we saw all that the players see
every single last possibility um you
know in these positions but that's not
that is something that the players can
and will find so karjakin is thinking
here uh because queen b2 it feels like
you're
unnecessarily getting yourself in
trouble it's not really a position where
white has any hope of um
sorry black has any hope of winning
after queen h4 you just happen to make a
draw there that's really the maximum so
it seems too risky what an insane line i
will see what sergey comes up with if we
go down this path
let's bring back the bird's eye view one
more time uh richard reports his king
robert is making progress
he won king of the hill his king is on
d4 and it's actually attacking some of
prague nando's pawns and we see the
evaluation bar is going up up and away
because the king is a really strong
piece there it can't easily be attacked
and now it reports rook
if we pull up the game quickly that can
go to a2 because both players are in
some time trouble they're on move 32
so they still have eight moves to go but
rook a2 can be played and white can use
the open file to his advantage
and what uh what a defensive effort this
has been by by report
he was on the back foot the entire game
but he sat tight
and as soon as
there was some wiggling room we saw him
bring the king out could have done so
one move
sooner but it wasn't taken advantage of
by black and now it looks like
uh richard is the one
firmly in control that put upon
on uh e4
is under attack
how does black hold on knight f6
let's discuss
i'm gonna start pushing my pawns
i have a
three of them over here it's a convoy uh
so one thing that we should give report
so much credit for is he played bishop
g2 which i guess according to the
engines isn't best but i like the way he
played this knight b1
the knight went to d7 and maybe that's
the critical moment that rook a8 just
was the move and i'm not entirely sure
why
probably didn't go for it but it's
probably because after rook a1 check
it's just one check the king can go to
d2 the rook is protected
i mean knight d7
king d2
king ah
i wonder if he thought knight c3 was
going to be played here but reports i
don't care about your rook coming to
this is actually really nice he went
rook d1 giving up the f2 pawn so he
sacrifices a pawn and in his head
probably wow this has to be pretty
decent for me i'm gaining my pawn back
but what reports is it's not about the
material right now look at my pawns
your pawns are stuck e4 is weak and
after the rook retreated which is i
think the final mistake because rook
takes d2 i guess keeps black in the game
somewhat brooke here king up and now
white's pieces are the ones that are
dominating
wow
i can't hear fiona so uh i don't think
anybody can hear fiona i don't know if
you've been talking but
[Laughter]
so uh let's go get that fixed um well
producer maybe you can help out please
but either way
white is now in the driver's seat
so
we will uh check back in
i'll just keep talking that's fine
and report
he has made his move here
oh sorry he's writing down the move
tonight f6 was played but he can just
push his pawn and start
going towards the other side
the battery is dead
okay that just leaves me
me and my thoughts
and you everybody
just the two of us you and i
now but in all seriousness
this is really nicely done by report and
prague has put up some good defense he
was a little bit too passive robert i'm
back
you're back
back from the dead oh
i was like am i just gonna have to keep
talking here i was talking as well and i
was wondering like why isn't robert
responding to it no anything i'm saying
if fiona talks and nobody hears a word
is she really talking
some deep questions robert i'm back and
i'm going to bring us back to magnus
carlsen because i think time has been
ticking down this is also very
interesting but richard report in
control and i was reading in the chat
that niels apparently
has found the defense but
is this really over yet let's see
queen b7 lining up the
queen with the rook here
i think queen b4 is the only move
because you can't move your bishop you
get mated down on b1 so i think queen
goes back to b4 and i wonder if magnus
is going to repeat not three times to
make a draw but he's repeating just to
gain more time on the clock as we're
approaching 40. yeah well we'll see he
started now with uh queen c7 queen a4 is
back
it's an interesting one because both
players are low on time and when your
magnus
part of you i think wants to
to maybe uh pounce in that situation
where your opponent is on time but on
the other hand you yourself have to take
more of a gamble so
uh a double edged uh sword
and
yeah well queen b7 is one option to get
closer to the to the time control
but
what is the idea for for black here how
do we break down white's defenses do we
break them down at all
rook h to b3 is the move that still
comes to my mind but i'm trying not to
tunnel on that one alone so the bishop
one e2 is under attack there's no
immediate threat that
magnus has
rook takes b2 i'm thinking about as well
because after rook takes b2 if you take
there's queen coming into c3 so there
are many options here for magnus to
calculate even something as simple as
retreating his bishop to c4 is possible
and he only has three and a half minutes
yeah of course if he retreats the bishop
to c4 he will have to make sure that his
king is safe because
we've been talking a lot about all the
trouble that the white king on c1 is in
but the king the black king is out on f7
as well and the rook uh if the bishop
moves the rook is ready to come to f2
with a jack maybe to go to g2 attack the
pawn on g7
and i think there is a small chance that
we might see a repetition here as um
as both players could be in trouble and
it's not so easy you cannot repeat often
enough to get to move 40 and then have
the extra 50 minutes to figure things
out
but you can tell by magnus's face he
really does not want to make a draw here
he he's trying to
find a win he's trying to find a way to
crash through but you're right fiona his
king on f7 is in danger white's up a
pawn but that's not the important part
it's about the king safety and rook
takes b2 i want to put them on the board
very quickly if king takes b2
queen c3 check is the idea because your
king can't go to c1 you get mated on a1
however it appears that you can just
retreat your king give up your rook
because in comes the queen this king is
in trouble the rook on h3 is hanging for
good measure so rook takes b2 would not
be a good move it just it was move
canada i suggested didn't work through
it now i did it's not good i make
mistakes it happens
and while you were figuring this one out
magnus he hasn't made a movie at two
minutes now on the clock we're on move
34 which means that magnus still has
seven moves to make
and i agree with you i think magnus does
not want to repeat but if he finds
nothing convincing
uh i think he would rather take the
repetition than suddenly finding himself
on mu 40 with a position where he could
be the one in trouble
yeah because bishop c4 your point is
very well taken the rook comes to g2 and
then you have to defend your pawn with
like rook h7 so you're moving backwards
and there's still some pressure that
white used to deal with but now there's
pressure that black also needs to take
care of so magnus he's going to keep
thinking he could play rook to b3 he's
trying to not just calculate and like
see the position he's trying to assess
it and he made a move he's dropped a
bishop back to not just c4 but to b5
okay
and have we had this position before
right here we had bishop on b5 no so the
no so this is a new position we saw the
bar dropping
back to like equalish territory
but why
why why why one of the things while we
were looking at this pawn on g7 so one
of the things to wonder can we ever give
up the queen and go for the pawn on g7
because it's not just upon the queen on
c7 is
undefended so that is one option we
could also move the queen nince is about
to make a move already and he has gone
rook g2
he has indeed so rook g2
gives up the queen to win it right back
bishop a4 rook g7 check the king has to
move and no matter where it moves you
lose your queen on c7 and it's very
important square because the rook also
helps save the
white king so
someone is standing right in front of
the camera
and new angle for us
but what else can magnus do here g7 is
under attack you really do not want to
play the move h7 which allows the queen
to come to b3 and then swing to the king
side
i
do not know robert i'm not sure you
because you can't defend obviously with
rook g8 it's not a move you want to move
anyway but in this case the bishop from
b5 would just drop
what happens if you go back with the
with the king i guess that's not
something you want to do either
well magnus has made a move magnus has
gone
for rook h7 defending uh defending the
pawn that way
wow what that's a brave choice by the
way young troops of duda and siri
karaoke have drawn their game that one
is over i'm gonna quickly flash the
board and come right back to the carlson
game just to show you how the
game conclude wait rook g4 there's no
way that was the move because that uh
was the move was that the final move of
the game
i
very much doubt it what could have
happened maybe i think they repeat it
and then maybe no wait
like it says rook g4 bishop e3 rook g7
bishop a6 rook g4 that
looks like it could be a tgt error
um
i i don't know let's figure it out let's
there's a work on g4 on the board so
okay robert i suggest we come to this
after we've made move 40 elsewhere and
try and
figure out what was happening maybe
we'll get some player interviews to help
us as well but for now let's come back
to niels grandelius and magnus so rook
h7
is on the board not a move magnus wanted
to make of course to
bring that rook back to passively defend
when it was doing so great on h3
and now well the question is what after
queen b3 check b3 is available again to
nils after the the blackbook
dropped back
and
well i guess magnus can block the queen
and the queen
can venture to the king side that's
a bit concerning for black but it could
be concerning for white because your
queen is leaving the side that your king
is on and niels has
just made a move
queen b3 and quickly bishop c4 was the
response by magnus
and we're on move 36 so both players
have to make four moves before they get
an additional 50 minutes i like your
suggestion of uh queen
g3 trying to bring the the the queen in
on the king side and
i mean
anyone's game this one now robert
yeah queen takes g7 is actually a threat
uh because the queen and the king are in
the same line for example if you make
some bad move like b6 covering the g6
square there's moves like queen takes g7
check and if you take the rook takes and
the queen is lost
behind the king so you have to be really
careful here for magnus
after move like queen g3
you probably queen b6 that way you cover
the g6 score and threaten the checkmate
of your own so neil is a tough choice
here fiona does he go for the attack or
does he put his queen back on a4 that
way he can meet a queen to the b file
with queen to the b file of his own
actually the bishop was hanging with
check but
still yeah i'm also curious as if after
queen g3 the movie you suggested queen
b6 can i then swap queens as as white
queen g6 jack who will that favor
we might find out because nils has just
gone queen g6 queen g3 and magnus has
gone queen b6
okay
so queen g6 check that would be
the smart move i like that move it saves
your king by trading off the queens and
then white can't be in too much danger
from a point of view of checkmate but
all of white's pawns are on
bad squares so i think that niels will
play queen g6 check and he should be
able to hold that position for sure yeah
i think it will just be such a relief
here
as
in neil's shoes when you've been under
so much pressure i think to get the
queens off the board also you might not
have much of a choice because the bishop
on b2 is under attack
so
i'm not sure i'm even seeing too many
alternatives
actually none yeah queen g6 check
really really nice move here for white
and niels there he goes queen g6
queen g6 on the board which is going to
force the queens off let's remind
everyone and niels is still a pawn up
although his pawns are quite scattered
uh scattered and
well we also have opposite colored
bishops
on the game so although the pawns are
weak and the black pawns are restricting
nielsen's bishop
to me it feels like there is not enough
here for magnus to press but what do you
think robert by his face he also
completely agrees with you
and he went rook c8 he doesn't you know
he doesn't seem like
he
feels that he can press and kneels he
looks a little nervous but it's because
he is under a minute and he is one move
away from the time control so as soon as
he makes this move he gains more time
and i feel like the move king to b1
getting out of the c file because bishop
d3 is a pretty nasty threat hitting the
c2 pawn hitting the e4 pawn so king b1
does not allow bishop d3 to happen
i like that move
a lot getting the king
into safety and
i already have to say i mean a really
valiant uh effort by nils let's not
praise the what's the
what's the expression
i'm not sure praise the something before
something or maybe i'm just making it up
to confuse you robert anyway let's
pretend that never happened and we see
there the clock ticking down for nils
who has just made his final move oh for
the time control but rook g5
and immediately we see uh the bar drop a
little bit
yeah i did not like that move because
bishop d3
is
a really
tough move to meet and it's the 40th
move so after magnus makes this move
bishop d3 he gains the uh many
i can't speak he
oh
gosh come take so
not too many emotions today was uh
we got more than we bargained for robert
they have increments since move one
and you gain more time after move 40 is
reached
i'm gonna try to work on that but either
way the pawn c2 is in trouble the pawn
e4 is in trouble the h2 pawn is in
danger so bishop d3 is not going to be a
fun move to face if you were niels
grandilius absolutely and magnus was
already reaching out and then dropped a
handbag but i think bishop d3 is about
to be played
um
and yeah niels who had just
done such a great job fighting all the
way back now
it's it's going to start all over again
his defensive task and it isn't going to
be a fun one
yeah that's the worst part is
perhaps with
all the best moves the game
should and will end in the draw but i
need to find all those best moves again
niels did such a great job of fending
off that attack and making sure that he
wasn't get checkmated and now he's on
the worst side of this position and
it's
yeah it's not going to be fun it's not
going to be easy niels can do it but
magnus carlsen is the best in the world
at winning positions just like this
yeah so well we'll come back here we'll
have plenty of time i think this is
going to be a long game
let's bring back the bird's eye view
maybe quickly see if
everyone has made move 40 maybe
where do you want to start robert
for its game maybe
sure rapport and prognonda it is move 41
and unfortunately for pragmata it looks
like this one is the about to conclude
in
reports favor b7 is under attack the
d-pawn is stopped
by this knight on c3 and once b7 falls i
think we can see what's going to happen
after that you have three pawns they're
just going to march up the board
yeah this one looks
like it's gone the players have just
made
move 40 here so
they might take some time but yeah this
one looks gone for pregnant and richard
report as you mentioned earlier he lost
the first
game but ever since then he's been on a
roll and it looks like he's gonna add
yet another winter's tally
one trick though just one trick here
that knight g3
threatens knight e2 check removing the
knight from the defense of the d1 square
so if you say i'm just going to take
your pawns and win the game you're going
to lose the game on right away because
92 check
if the knight takes on e2 d1 equals
queen the knight had an important task
from c3 so after knight g3 you don't
take this pawn on b7 you see the threat
you deal with it you blockade the pawn
and that way after knight e2 check your
king marches up to d5 where it is safe
for now and maybe will continue up the
board though this as long as pawn
remains on d2 fiona it's going to be
tricky but rook f2 looks like it's going
to take care of that situation yeah but
i really like that little trick you
showed with knight e2 so you always got
to stay on your uh
gotta stay on your guards look out for
tricks like that
but uh richard i think he's got this
under control
and uh well let's check in with the last
two games and then we'll go for a quick
break first uh maybe we can start with
uh jordan van furiste and mamedyarov
unfortunately for jordan it looks like
the end might be near the king on h3
is in bad shape queen to h1 checkmate is
the idea after rook takes c3 the king is
out in the open the queen just slides
into h1 and if you don't play rook takes
c3 and you try to find something better
all the problems still exist this bishop
probably can come to d2 to cut your rook
off the king is actually safe on h6 so
fiona this is going to be a loss for
the dutchman and this one will be over i
think as you're saying very soon and
that leaves us with only one last game
to check out and that is uh fabiano
carrana uh on the black side against
ciazepanko we really liked fabiano's
position oh and sorry uh well
jordan has just resigned his game so
that's a big win for shakia mamidyarov
who was part of the chasing pack uh
going into this round and since uh
visited through his game
amirov is joining him in the lead
yes three draws followed by two wins and
i think he's telling jordan about queen
b7 check
i i saw him like
kind of make a hand motion that seemed
to indicate some kind of long move and
well it was a nice
game by mama jar first defending and
then winning material and then
converting quite nicely and there was
that queen b7 check move that jordan did
not play and that's the reason why he
lost the game the pressure by mama jarv
was too much
and mamadiarov definitely a force to be
reckoned with here he could even have
gotten potentially an even bigger score
you remember the winning position he got
against duboff i mean he's kept us so
entertained there was the game against
dubois then there was uh the the g4 i
mean
always such a fantastic uh player to to
follow it's a joy to have him in the
tournament and well i look forward to
what's next
for now uh let's check
check
[Music]
okay
well that game we see here still two
extra pawns for fabiano but many pieces
have been traded that's not good news
for caruana as he is trying to win we
see the clock say zero as soon as
yesterpango makes his move it will show
his updated time that's how
she is working sorry go ahead sorry no i
was just thinking that this year i feel
the mantra has mostly been at the pawn
three squares away controlling the night
but i remember when you were here in
vikenze two years ago there was one
thing we talked about plenty and this
year i was waiting patiently biding my
time
when can we make that point but robert
here might be our first moment
it's funny because that's the first
thing i was going to say but i've
learned that not everybody wants to hear
about how when there's a rook pawn and a
bishop if the color complex the bishop
doesn't match the corner square then
oftentimes
if you trade off the material let's say
the pieces in red are off the board here
even though black still has this bishop
in this pawn it's a draw because you
can't kick the king out of the corner so
i thought it i'm glad you brought it up
i know that everybody was really waiting
for this moment here in the tournament
it took five rounds for it to happen
took five rounds but better late then
never on a serious note i think uh what
we've just highlighted is exactly what
fabiano wants to avoid he will want to
avoid the pieces getting traded off and
being left which is this apon and
and the bishop but it looks like yes
panko has done a great job
i'm not sure what's going on here it is
white to play i don't know how easy it
is to get the pieces off at the board
but my bishop is hit for now my first
instinct robert is to to give a
check and then i'm wondering can i
simply capture the pawn on c4 next
i believe you can so if the king moves
rook takes c4 attacks the bishop you've
gotten rid of one pawn and now it really
makes a difference i mean
it's not going to happen the pawns far
away from like the white kings and
checkmated but if you all you need to do
is trade the rooks and
that's that's that so black's work is
active you wouldn't want to trade them
so you'd try to find a way to continue
the game but this looks like it has the
makings of a draw
for sure and uh i mean kudos to
yesipanko we can maybe quickly see how
we got here because the last time we
checked in here
you were warning us about the dangers
still associated with uh white spawn
on g6 and well let's see what what
happened
okay so the rook came to h2 and that
active move apparently not loved by the
engine how can you
not like that move i don't know but he
takes this pawn but the reason why is
this here on
g7 so
temporarily down a couple pawns but you
win the f6 pawn and that's why
in time trouble well players were trying
their best but mistakes happen when you
don't have time to calculate and with f6
falling i already feel like this is a
position where white is holding but it
made it easier for yesopenko to capture
this knight to hurt the pawn structure
if the palm were back on b5 the
connected pawns could give some chances
here with the pawn split and the pawn
just captured now
that leaves
fabiano with minimal chances to play for
win
yeah and well we see as a panko he
decided to capture
on c4 immediately he says i don't need
that bishop you are free to take it if
you want and
yeah now with only uh the apon left
as you said it's gonna be uh very
difficult for fabiano but kudos to yes
panko are
very impressed by his uh defensive
effort today
that's right and we see his 43 plus
minutes they get 50 minutes five zero
minutes as soon as they reach mu 40 and
that's going to register after fabiano's
next move for him as well but yes panko
great defense spotting a weakness going
after it and it would have required just
extreme precision from carwano in time
trouble in a very complex position to
maintain the edge instead we're here
where it looks like yesopenko is going
to hold
indeed and uh
well it looked like we were going to
have a lot of decisive games some of
them we've seen some great defenses
but still three games going on here as
we just reached the first time control
a lot of intrigue can magnus carlton
overcome uh niels grendelius can
fabiano make something happen still and
then well rapport it looks like he is
well on his way to score another win
so all of that and more don't go
anywhere we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
i just want to say i know it's early
yeah it's early for all of us but fabi
you're looking fresh no thanks danny
chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're you're just
looking fresh man i love your new
haircut makes me good
[Music]
hey how's it going
i don't even recognize myself
the whole new me
[Music]
hey fob hey dan how's it going hey
robert hey man
you know i'm just trying out a few new
things here and there the day's
beautiful sun is out
right cool
hey danny yeah
forgot to mention that haircut's looking
real fresh on you yeah thanks man
cool
appreciate it you serious
what does a guy gotta do around you to
get noticed
what are you talking about
i
seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without him what more does he want
[Music]
i cannot get enough of that clip but
someday robert i'll have to watch it
with sound um but for now let's look at
the results here so far in round five
uh we had three draws
which they never tell the full story but
especially so today which was i believe
the most eventful day of the tournament
culminating in only one victory so far
for shakira mahmoud against uranus
we know how capable these players are of
putting up resistance of finding the
defensive resources necessary to hold
the half point and that's what happened
in many of these games i'm still
confused by the duda karjakin game we
didn't have a chance to look at that but
there's a rook on g4 a sky-high
evaluation bar and yet
it's a darker screen with half-half
written on it
yeah maybe we can go there
and and find out what happened
could it be that with the time taking so
low there was a missed opportunity is
this a dgt error let's try and figure it
out
so we last looked with the knight coming
to c6 back to e7
and then karjakin apparently played rook
to g4 so it's a mistake i don't
immediately
see why it's a mistake but let's try to
figure this out so rook takes c3
definitely is not the move because after
rook takes c3
you do steal the pass pawn but you allow
queen bee one check this queen is
start entering the position over here so
like rook c1
queen e4 check bishop f3 haha i blocked
your check and i'm getting your rook now
queen takes f5 works because your bishop
is pinned so once f5 falls e6 could be
next and that might be a bad turn of
events for white importantly tonight
covers ca and if i go queen f queen f3
instead of bishop f3
queen f3 that's a great question um
so it's just a trade here i can't take
on f5 with the knight because you're
gonna check with me in the back rank
but the queen trade
it might be what black
wants i say
with 100 certainty and zero percent
question in my voice
[Music]
because the f5 pawn is weak so that's
the good news
so may i just move my rook away because
you're my rook is hanging in some of
these positions
i could also
leave my rook because i'll take back on
e4 with the rook if you trade queen so
move like
a4 why not push the pawn up hey he
wasn't wrong
queen can't take on g4 because the king
is in line with the black queen and if
you take on e4 rook takes e4 bishop
under attack pawn under attack other
pawn under attack passport over here and
yet it's barely better for black
i mean what a what a mess but it looks
like
at first sight our impression is that
rook g4 was indeed played but we see the
bar
skyrocket but over the world it is a
different story and actually our
producer
bake is informing us that here the only
way for white to get that winning
advantage is by playing rook f1
okay well that makes sense because it
protects the queen
and the
uh eva bar uncertain at first goes back
up but the rook is under attack so the
rook needs to move i would imagine if
the rook goes back to g8
oh gosh
queen h4 now is even stronger
because now how do you defend um
yeah we get here and
wait but if you take on g5 take on e2
how that didn't change anything so
that's not the move you have
queen h5 just defending the bishop
unbelievable
wait so why does this let's just take a
moment here why is that different
than where were we
what what did we try to make here
queen h4
um
oh it might have been queen b2 that was
it yeah this doesn't work because after
this whole ridiculous sequence you can't
play queen h5 without losing your rook
on
c1 so that's the big difference is the
placement of the black queen
unbelievable so it looks like in the end
duda
was given an opportunity here but we're
not going to criticize him i think they
were down to their last minutes and not
so easy to figure out uh all these crazy
complications rook have one
is not a move that's going to be
immediately on your radar all right
you mean moving away from the past pawn
that's been approaching
doesn't immediately come to mind you're
saying that everyone in chat presumably
is shouting how could he miss that and
they're wrong
i don't have them open but i'm guessing
that's what they're saying are you
saying the chat's wrong
i would never say such a thing robert
i would not dare to i would not dream to
there
i mean i'm pretty sure that all of chat
saw that rook f1 was the correct move it
protects the queen it allows that
tactical sequence we were just looking
at so
only natural that they would find it
but instead well a draw between these
two players was agreed with the chat
writing how could he miss it
how could he miss work everyone
will forgive duda eventually
they will and we will um
but yeah back to the three games that we
have going on so we could have
potentially had another decisive
result there
for now it looks like rapport is the one
um
where the win is getting closer and
closer we see that richard has not
fallen for that cute little tactic you
pointed out that was threatened with
knight e2 he has blocked the d-pawn by
bringing his own knight back
and now that everything is under control
those pawns are going to roll you
mention also the rook can come back to
f2 and target and upon maybe we can
bring up the big boy for one second to
just highlight all of these things
for sure knight g3
knight d1 very important move just
because if you try to steal a pawn you'd
lose the game knight e2 check
distracting this knight away from c3 so
that this pawn will in fact promote if
you take the knight on e2 so that's why
rapport plays knight d1 and here the
problem is b7 is hanging rook f2 to win
this pawn
can happen if you don't play 92 check so
i think 92
king d5
if your rook went on e6 fiona there'd be
bishop to g8 but your rook is on
e6
yeah so uh unfortunately here for prague
who got his first win two days ago it
looks like uh richard is gonna take this
one richard with a great start to his
event and we'll move on
from here uh i want to see well we'll go
to the bird's eye view i'm curious is if
niels has made a move i um
i feel bad for nienz because
he did such a great job defending and
then i just on the last move and this
happens oh so often it is move 40
you make your last move and then
suddenly comes so if we just go back to
that moment after rook c8
on move 39 so niels here has one more
move to make
before getting the extra 50 minutes we
were expecting king b1 stepping out of
that c file
to avoid the trouble that is going to
ensue in the game because niels went for
work g5 which seems to make sense at
first sight we're attacking the pawn
on e5 but
bishop d3
and suddenly there's once again some
some questions being asked of our
king you know i wonder if at this moment
here fiona the the
the pawn e5 is under attack and you
can't take it without dropping c2 and
that's just losing because your king
goes to d1
you lose the bishop on b2 if your king
goes to b1 you're walking into
the diagonal the bishop so that means
this rook leaves anywhere and
you're going to lose something so where
do we put it we can put it here on g2
with check and just win this rook over
here because the bishop checks the king
so i don't know i mean king every rook
five check king e6 doesn't work because
then this rook comes to g6 with check so
that could be something that
you have to look out for from afar the
king can't go to e7 or e8 without
dropping this pawn with check so king g8
is the move and
you know we just showed why it has to be
the move but i wonder if like in the
distance that's like somehow a move you
miss because i don't i don't know
what niels
didn't see because bishop d3 is kind of
obvious for a player of his caliber yeah
and well now uh he's had to come back to
defend c2 passively from
f2
and the question for magnus is is he
going to to take the pawn on e4 or is
that running into some problems along
the e file
is rookie 1 a move here or
is there another way to get at e5
yeah because here there might be rook h4
and the big problem for white is that
when you play rook e2 and the bishop
moves somewhere like all the way back to
h7 you can't take this pawn e5 you'd
lose c2 you need to be able to take with
the first rank rook and even there there
would be d3 to consider so
white can't organize the pieces in a way
that wins the e5 pawn that easily
but somehow it's saying zero so bishop
takes e4 what looks like a free pawn is
the wrong move even though it just looks
so right
chess is
chess is not an easy game robert
yes i agree you know i just thought of
something though that
all right um bear with me for a second
if i go
here
and you're king b1 i'm just trying to
put the king here are there times where
you can play rook takes c2 i don't think
it's going to work but my plan
the time it works yes
i feel good about myself brook takes h2
i'm forcing you into a pin and when you
play rook c1
i protected this so if you we trade
everything let's just show what happens
here then white is a piece ahead and
going to win with this pawn and the king
is too close but what i'm doing is i've
tied all your pieces down and so i'm
gonna play g5
and you're gonna play a4 and i'm going
to
i think just play g4 here and you're
gonna play a5 and then i take
take and play g3 and you can't stop my
pawn and my pawn happens with check so
you go a6 i do not take your pawn
because then your rook is free to move i
go g2 and it goes to show that bishop
takes c2 would be a bad move because the
king takes and then once black queens
white queens in response and white ends
up a piece ahead and with a winning
position so you leave the rook
and once a7 happens you queen with check
the king moves out the way and then this
bishop takes and covers the promoting
square
robert i am so impressed because i know
you're very good at just but there's no
way you could have calculated all of
this i mean it's such an incredibly
close line
it wins by one tempo but uh the the
speed at which you saw the idea and the
fact that it's actually working
it's just a mind-blowing uh variation
here really really nice stuff
and rook h6 played by magnus i think
kind of to elaborate on what was
happening in my mind is when i
commentate right i can feel free to make
mistakes i don't feel insecure if i make
a mistake whatever as a chess player
everyone makes mistakes from the newest
player to magnus carlsen so i often try
to think in terms of ideas and i'm
noticing that if the king is on b1 right
there's a bishop here it's under attack
but i understand that if i can
get this position here that your rook is
pinned and i know i can immediately
attack it and went upon the same time
and the only way you can defend it is by
rook to c1 so i was visualizing this
position and as i even said out loud i
was like oh it probably doesn't work but
i was trying to come up with the idea
because i didn't really care if it
didn't work i wanted to show everybody
how nasty this kind of pin can be when
the king can't get out and it's a very
simple path forward from here once i got
this to
this position in my head it was about
calculating one by one by one and taking
on c2 too early would be a mistake and
the only other way white can get out of
this is moving the king but then you
lose the rook without getting anything
in return and i also passed d-pawn and
if you move your bishop where can you
move it to to a1 that's not very
impressive i can move my pawn to g4 and
once your king b2 to get out of that pin
we trade everything here and your bishop
has no way of stopping my pawn i go g3
and this pawn e5 comes in very handy
protecting the d4 pawn and the bishop
can't come and stop this pawn so i'm
just going to go g2 g1 equals queen and
yeah i mean really nice to to hear these
hear about the insights into the the
thought process how you get to this
first it's an idea and then once the
idea formulates then
comes in the the actual move by move
calculation which turns out to work here
for black uh i mean i'm still impressed
this was such a nice line and while it
goes to show king b1 uh there might be a
few candidate moves here but kim b1
seems to just lose by force
yeah but that's like the move you want
to play to step out of the pin so if
king b1 doesn't work
a rook g3 type of move
is available black is threatening to put
more pressure on
c2 so if you play a4 for example
uh that's a problem because rook comes
to c6 the only way to defend the c2 pawn
is rook g2 and then i take your pawn on
e4 kicking your rook off the second rank
and your rook cannot afford to leave the
second rank as the c2 pawn is mine
yeah so uh actually this position might
be a lot tougher for niels than we even
thought at first
um well he's still thinking we're going
to go to an interview we're going to
hear what shakira mamedyarov had to say
after his victory over jordan van forest
[Music]
you just uh beat jordan from for race
with black in your pet line the open uh
roy lopez uh what's an easy factory
uh okay first of all
uh he surprised me move a4 is opening i
see this move first time
uh and okay i mean i think after if i
played not so bad i mean i played
i tried to play very
quickly because when you start to sing
you can do big mistakes something and i
i just tried to play first
a4 before i mean i played not so bad but
i
i'm not sure when his play knight d4 is
idea 94 knight
f3 e6 it looks very risky
uh i think it was positioned was equal
but he started to play very risky
and then knight f7 came was it a
surprise to you yeah i mean
when i played c5 i calculate black is
better position after he when i play e6
of course i can take d4 his positions
near equal but i think why not bishop v8
because of the bishop v8 is looks two
bishops very good pawn center
maybe i'm
not right maybe i'm wrong but it just
looks very nice and positions looks very
good and i think why not to play bishop
v8 and save these bishops and to play
for
win
um i saw the database that you played
the open roy lopez before jordan fun for
race was even born
does it help you to to have such a pet
line that you know from the inside
okay i mean is normally a royal opus one
time is boring one time is interesting
it is different
different operands and these
of course is my opinion today he tried
to play very interesting for this reason
this is very nice very interesting game
but if somebody will play
very boring
positions is absurd and normal to play
boring position yeah is your second win
in a row yeah so things are going well
in the tournament
uh okay before the tournament i got some
my field was not very good and still is
not very well because i had some a
little bit grip out saying in grip we're
saying otherwise john in russia you say
his cause oh like a slow or like yeah i
mean i had some problems but
still i am not very well
but thanks
for uh argenzers and also is our arbiter
and doctor
he helped me some
thing and okay my feel is i hope
after few days my fault will be much
better but for now as i'm happy with my
results
and i hope
i will will continue to play interesting
chess interesting games and also uh good
results
and vacancies one of the few tournaments
where there's no big dress code so now
you can you can actually play in a
hoodie and put your head hoodie on top
of your head
does it help you to to recover no
really
my feel is not very good for this reason
i do it here i mean normally it is not
very nice again i mean
which when you do it is not good for
your operands and i don't like this but
sometimes really is not easy for me i
mean i feel not very good i try to safe
i think it's like i am not just playing
like boxer
i mean it looks very interesting very
good but not good but it is i do it
because my feel is not very well okay i
won't take much more of your time so
thank you for being here thank you thank
you thanks
always great to hear from shakhtar
mamedyarov
of course not
tough to hear that he's been having
trouble with
the flu we hope of course robert that he
feels better soon and well there's the
explanation behind the hoodie
he hasn't been feeling great so
in those spots very often you want to
dress more comfortably more warmly as
well and
the hood up and turns out to actually
have a
health background explanation
i heard that it helps you to feel better
when you beat super grandmasters at
chess
just a little birdie once told me that
i'm not really sure because it doesn't
happen very much for me but for mama jar
if it happens two rounds in a row and he
is tied with vidit in the lead with
three and a half out of five he's
playing great chess and i just want to
say a little story quickly about mama
jarov um
i don't think i've ever been beaten as
badly as when i played him in this blitz
tournament many years ago where i just
was like looking at my position i don't
really remember the game very well but i
remember that i looked at my position oh
it should be pretty decent and then just
got absolutely smashed and i was like
yeah this guy is a lot better than i am
and i am extremely impressed so
mama durov has our utmost respect we
were
somewhat critical earlier about the draw
offers but not about the player or the
players themselves it was about the fact
the offer exists mama jarov so much
respect for him and he is now with two
wins in a row at three and a half out of
five
and i'm uh so thrilled to see
him up there i mentioned a few days ago
you know when i was growing up uh he he
is what i think uh two three years older
than i am so i in those youth events i
would look up at him i think shakira
memoration if i'm not mistaken the only
player in the history of just to have
won at the world junior championship
twice which is such a strong event um he
loves the game of chess as well i think
it's always been so nice when you go to
an event you will very often find shahia
surrounded by let's say entertainment
like the european club club surrounded
by amateurs you know at the tournament
bar he will be playing blitz against all
comers he loves the game he loves blitz
and we haven't heard so much quite as
much from him the last couple of years
after going up to number two in the
world it got a bit quieter so i'm so
happy
i had to see him here in the joint lead
after five rounds and looking at the
chat he has certainly
won
a lot of new fans
he's also i think number five in the
world right now so he somehow flies
under the radar if you haven't already
watched it watch his lessons on
chess.com he did a video series and he
put a lot of care into it you could tell
he was talking about some of his finest
games that meant a lot to him he's a
very friendly face and a very friendly
person that always provides entertaining
chess so good on him the term is still
early everybody else of course has a
shot to win this tournament but right
now mama jarv joins the lead with vidit
absolutely and well robert
we still have the same three games going
on we're gonna go back to the bird's eye
view i believe uh niels
no nils has not made a move yet so still
considering his options after rook h6
but things are not uh looking great
there maybe we can go back to jesse
panko against uh fabiano
sure thing that game
it
has changed a little bit and now a lot
because especially takes that knight on
b6 and we're talking about how the rook
pawn doesn't match the bishop the
queening square is a dark square the
bishop's on a light square so you would
think let me just take on b6 with the
pawn that should solve all my problems
the answer is no for many reasons um
you see this position here that if white
were to give up this knight for the pawn
that is still a theoretical draw it's no
fun i've been on the defensive side of
that before it is horrible to experience
but these players andre gasopanko he
knows how to defend a rook against a
rook rookie bishop but that means that
at the very worst case he can give away
his knight and still hold the draw
yeah i'm always curious i
i wonder if anyone has the stats of at
the high level
um does everyone hold it it's really i
think one of the toughest drawn
positions uh to hold even i my feeling
is even if you know
the technique very often suddenly your
king is pushed back you need to find the
only way you need to be so confident so
i'm curious to see if it gets down to
that i hope for yasipanko's sake i hope
for him it doesn't have to get down to
that
um but if it does i'm curious to see how
precise is his technique
and he probably won't have to because
the good thing about having a knight
against a bishop is you can put a knight
on a dark square and the bishop can't
kick it out so if you play b5 at some
point try to play b4 it's not going to
happen and white's going to orient his
pieces in a way that stops it a trait of
rooks the game is quite an easy draw
because the king can sit on b2 the
bishop can never king kick the king off
a dark square we keep talking about the
limitations of a bishop if the knight
and bishop are traded for each other
that is still a draw the king sits in
front of the pawn it can be instructive
uh some of these end games are people
who are not well versed but the king is
perfectly placed for yesapanko so i
don't think he's going to have to worry
about even
for a second thinking about defending
rook and bishop versus rook he's not
going to sacrifice his knight he won't
have to
agreed i think
now that we're down to only
five
how many
i can't count anymore seven pieces
seven pieces on the board um and um i'm
so sorry
robert
you know what i think it's time for a
break i have just
couldn't count to seven then the next
second i i spilled my water on the floor
so i think it's time
oh well i guess it is you say so
you're in charge of that so we'll be
right back everybody for more from round
five from vicenza
[Music]
this year's sec is going to be one for
the record books and one that uh people
will not forget anytime soon oh nice for
work a5 love that c3 i love what shocker
is doing so resilient that is textbook
right there yeah that's incredible
perfect play that's just over and dinghy
wren all you need to do was hold on the
bullet he moves on to the quarterfinals
but what a match this was done my head
is spinning and where's the mate richie
seven
no no oh my gosh
look at this final position and this is
just insane
this is indefensible with 10 seconds on
the clock a king man
i don't see a move
i don't see a move and neither is
jeffrey he's not okay this is over
desperation but you can't crush anyway
too many pawns and it's going to be a
four point lead and
what wesley's incredible ending by
wesley i mean this is resignable and the
worst thing is that neil is going to win
this with three seconds like he's going
to take on d3 he's going to go five
and he's going to win the game
i'm speechless in our final score 18 to
nine knee hall exactly doubles rehard
report score i'm watching the black
benjamin
somebody's gonna fly here
nah
oh wait wait wait second second oh he
flags again
oh my gosh
rook takes c4 and he's trying to give
away everything
oh there it is renegade rook time but
the pro here's what what black is gonna
do no no you're gonna get i think i'm a
specialist in defending against it's
just king d6 and it's over already
it's over before it began
yeah he tried but ikaro basically you
know in two moves played instantly just
took your idea and said yeah that's not
gonna work around here
that's a really surgical move you would
never guess that this came from a bond
class oh my god yeah that he just did it
folks yeah i'm fat beat
oh no
oh no we have our semi-finals set
nakamura against ding and nihal against
wesley
can you take him go 95 again relying on
that defensive knight oh look at western
i have no checks here
oh my god bishop takes you for a 92
interposing with chuck
and what an incredible win by wesley he
gets that two points
wesley so wins the first semi-final
he's got five seconds he's gonna play
instantly in exchange here whoa bishop
c1 it was a mouse now he was going to d2
oh it was good at d2 but it was still
bad rook h7 check would have been
terrible yeah oh my goodness icaru saves
the match with a win in the last game
and we're going to overtime
oh
oh everybody's dream come true more
games no ding ones checkmate
i don't know if he does he's got 12
seconds he's got no time i don't see the
win i don't know if i agree with the raw
we're good
we keep going
unbelievable hikaru survives
will think c97 at b6 that is his only
chance to keep this endgame going
he has has the time but he misses it
he misses it and he collapses rick b7
king f7 king e6
yeah oh my goodness that but
rook a5
okay
the black is not gonna give up the e4
pawn and in that case white's not
winning that game
ding overlooked it
ding missing that tactical shot which
would have given him the chances and now
he doesn't see a movie carl might pull
this one out i mean ding has to give up
the pawn and then move the knight around
he car is not losing this game he's got
more time on the clock and ding sitting
back basically admitting defeat and it's
that's it the match is over ding resigns
yeah and hikaru nakamura wins the
armageddon against dingley ren to make
it to the sec finals oh what a move
finds him
two seconds
on the skin of his team without a
six-inch
no but one second wesley's just gonna
flag your twin g6 all the pawns are
falling it's over oh my god
and hikaru nakamura for the fourth
straight time he wins the speed chess
championship with one of the most
commanding matches in sec history
welcome back round five here at the tata
steel chess tournament and roberts what
a day it has been some absolute
incredible action but we still have
three games ongoing
and somehow only one decisive result
despite how fascinating the games have
been we see the three games on screen
here yes apenko against carowanna that
game it's looking like it should be a
draw without too much difficulty
although that king on a3 for yesapanko
you could make a mistake in a position
like this and get your king in some
serious danger
yeah so that is one that looks like with
some precise player sepenko uh should be
holding the draw but
of course fabiano will try and keep try
and create some threats against that
king as you just mentioned
then the other thing i notice richard
report he still has his winning
advantage
he is i think putting the finishing
touches making sure he doesn't allow any
black counter play but what i see is a
neil scuandelius against magnus carlton
we were very concerned about neil's
position and it looks like
uh
the eval bar at least is back firmly in
the middle of the board
yeah that is the most surprising
development of all and we'll keep an eye
on all three games but in the time that
we were on break it looks like niels
played this move rook to d1 we already
showed you the issues with king b1 a
rook sacrifice and the rook takes back
there you see the engine agreeing rook
takes h2 the rook is pinned the only way
to defend that rook is bringing the rook
to c1 and then the g pawn is too fast
it'll just run up the board then we will
take on
c2 as showed earlier after a6 rook takes
c2 very important and do not take the
rook a second time you push g2 ukraine
with check and black wins the game white
is one step too slow so instead of all
that fiona we saw the move rook d1
played
and
one imagines when bishop takes e4 which
to my eyes looks like the obvious move
the eval bar says not so fast that was
wrong yeah i mean that's what i've been
uh confused about ever since the break i
had the bar as well i didn't have time
since we got our dinner here during the
break that was my top priority as i
didn't have time to figure out why is
bishop takes e4 which looks like
that's the natural move the bishop is
said there is a pawn hanging
why
is that
not good
well
it was very strange to see the
evaluation part take a dip after that
decision bishop to b5
apparently was the best plan and
it's unclear at first why that is
and i'm still honestly a little bit
confused it's that deep of an idea but
it looks like in the game continuation
and maybe that's the easiest way to
explain so if we can bring up the live
board and we can analyze on the side
that in the game there's a bishop on e4
rook on e1 and this
setup here is tough for black because
the bishop can't move without dropping
e5 pawn so white gets active play
whereas after the move bishop to b5
sure you're down a pawn you didn't steal
this pawn on
e4 but black will have so much play and
will be able to target that pawn in the
future without giving white any counter
play so in a position like this the
bishop can swing over to a4 this rook
can try to swing over to c6 maybe you
try to use the b file at some point if
white's not looking out for it so it's
essentially like sitting on the position
and making sure that white has no active
choices
well active choices you just mentioned
it niels grandelius he was given a
chance to activate his work so what he
did after bishop takes e4 is play rookie
one uh targeting the the pawn on e5 so
magnus went
rook h4 uh defending the bishop on uh on
e4 and then neil said okay now it's my
turn to strike and let's just start
pushing
the a pawn
and now we see finally that bishop from
v2 robert that
wasn't in the game for so long but it's
move 46 and finally that bishop gets to
activate itself via a3
and that's really all that niels needed
to make his position be better and the
rook went back to c8 the bishop can come
to a square like d6 go to e7 to hit this
rook on
h4 and at first it looks like black
might have blundered because after
bishop e7 you're attacking this rook and
if the rook moves anywhere off the
fourth rank you lose the bishop on e4
and you play rook g4
h3 happens and again where is your rook
going if you go rook f4 i take your rook
you can take on c2 check first but
either way once you eventually take on
f4 you lose this bishop on e4 so the
only move fiona is rook g2 you are
defending your bishop tactically but
this also liquidates and there's no risk
at all for white
yeah and um
well it looks like niels has actually
managed to survive
the worst here and
this game seems to be steering towards
adrona which is really really impressive
by nils
but before we come back to this game and
the others speaking of the swedish
number one we have his portrait video
ready so let's go and check that out
2010 when i played in the c group it was
fantastic i mean that was really the
first time for me that i played
you know on the same stage let's say as
all the top players and i had them so
close up and i could just go there and
watch their games and so on and for a
young boy of course it was fantastic
i do like to sit down with an actual
chessboard and analyze things and or at
least think about things but when i use
let's say technology or engines i try to
use the best ones
always
i think the next development we will see
this is a bit of a guess but i think
what they will try to do is because now
they are they are so incredibly strong
and so much stronger than all the humans
but rather what they will be
improving is uh to make them play more
like a human or make them play more
similar to how the best humans play
so i think we will have a
shift to the engines working in that
direction rather than just pure you know
strength improving
this year of course and last year was a
little bit
strange because of the pandemic
we don't have this vibe in in the
village of the
let's say
the festival i think we still managed to
keep some of that spirit alive and but
of course we are hoping for
you know back to
to the old way soon
great to hear from niels grendellis who
made his debut here in vikenzie back in
on the in the sea group i remember it
well i attended that edition as well as
a chess fan
drove here from france where i was at
university for the weekend
and i remember watching neil's in the
sea group he was sporting his dreadlocks
at the time
um and now he's made it all the way of
course to the the main stage playing in
the masters and robert it looks like
uh he might be taking half a point of
magnus carlsen today
yeah he's
made it a long way from the c group as
you're saying he's now drawing the world
champion and as a strong grandmaster
like niels grandilius drawing magnus
from the with the white pieces it's an
accomplishment but that's not the
ultimate goal in any individual game a
player of this strength can defeat
magnus carlsen obviously he's the magnus
he's the boss he's hard to take down and
in this one
magnus looks disappointed because he did
have all the chances but credits and
nils he played this rook d1 move and
magnus was unable to
make anything happen here there's as
neo-silence portrait make engines play
more like humans sometimes engines
suggest moves you're like what the heck
is that nobody in the world is thinking
in that direction but that's what was
needed for magnus to convert this game
because that's how good niels defense
was
yes and here i think we are heading
towards
a handshake coming up very shortly
because
the material is getting liquidated each
player is left with the rook and the
bishop the bishop
are of different uh colors so
this one shouldn't go on for too much
longer but yeah kudos uh two nils who
who withstood
a big assault by magnus said and what an
excited
what an exciting game it was all the way
from the opening
and both players can have the same
expression
it's uh
they're both sort of back in their
chairs looking like with their chin
protruding and here we see the last
touches on this game uh which should end
in a draw very shortly because it's rook
bishop and pawn for each side opposite
colored bishops it's not like there's a
pass pawn
neither pawn is advanced so neil's after
a really rough start he's able to draw
magnus carlsen and maybe this is just
the jolt he needs to get back in this
tournament and score some wins and
robert sorry i'm laughing but it's funny
how the players are and there is the
the draw offer and the smiles from the
world champion because for the last two
moves every time nielsen made the move
we saw him on camera after the move look
at magnus like
okay is that it can we make are we
making a draw now should i offer are you
gonna offer what's the deal and it's
funny that magnus took matters
in his own hand and although it was him
to move he just looked at neems and he
said
okay
so we call it the day and the draw was
agreed
and immediately as true chess players do
they go start talking about variations
and this game was so sharp there was so
much
to consider that the players were asking
what would you have done in this
situation i was thinking about this but
i wasn't sure and yeah you can see by
magnus is both his what he's saying
where he's pointing and his
hand gesticulations he's like i don't
know it's unclear
yeah i think a lot to be discussed here
after this game
um magnus certainly is going to feel
like maybe you missed some small chances
but the two of them
it's so nice to see them there at the
board they are great friends they are
from rivals scandinavian countries of
course i think a bitter sports rivalry
between sweden and norway but these two
they are great friends niels
was part of
team magnus for a number of years
and it's also good to see niels get the
drawer here he's had a tough
start to the event but hopefully the
store against magnus will set him back
on
on a new path here which is delayed
rounds to go
for sure and we see that
now five games are in the books the game
between
grendelius and carlson i'm sure that
will uh you know it'll turn to a dark
screen with the half-half on it that
leaves two games left
and fiona yes panko he's defending
against caruana there still looks level
although black has made a bit of
progress but it's the game between
report and prognonda because report just
sacrificed a piece with his last move
and with that king march all the way
into the queen side yeah so let's go uh
let's go there first
uh because it looks like he say panko
his defensive setup looks quite solid
and yeah let's
have a look at what is going on here
with prague throwing in the knight to f4
yeah we saw this line happening knight
to d1 to avoid check with the
distraction of the knight king came up
the king went up some more and after
bishop g6 the rook went to d7 because
when the king moves out of the way the
d2 pawn is under attack and knight f4
may say what in the world is that why
don't you just take that knight you're
about to see why after g takes f4 now
black has three advanced pawns and white
could easily lose this position i
understand that white is better
objectively but mistakes happen in chess
and those pawns are scary
they look very scary indeed so
uh richard has no interest
in capturing on f4 but after king c7 the
question is suddenly well now your own
bishop is hanging on g2
yes have that bishop enjoy it hopefully
it's good for you because after king
takes b7 it's even better for white this
pawn is rushing up the board d2 is going
to fall and black can bring the bishop
to say f5 and try to stop the pawns but
there are so many of them here
there are just too many um if we put
bishop f5 on the board i guess richard
will simply take the pawn because why
not uh that pawn has been there for a
while i think there's no one of the keys
to this position is for richard there is
no rush yes he gave up pawn uh but there
is nothing prag can do to to try and nag
at those pawns on the queen side or to
get rid of them uh so
they are going to roll up the board it's
just a matter of time here i guess
prague can try and take on h3
uh eliminating another pawn and
defending the knight at the same time
but
how do we start probably doesn't matter
b6 c6
i'm choosing louie
yeah let's go b6 sure why not and then
the c pawn can go this king can move out
of the way and then you push the b pawn
or the c pawn
it's all going to be winning
absolutely and in the game well we just
see the players um make a couple of
moves so this is all
happened
and uh well we were talking about
bishop f5 no sorry yeah well that was
we're talking without tonight on g2 and
we are going to an interview with neil
swandelius magnus golson um
how are your feelings right now
well i think mainly i'm quite lucky to
have survived that uh the game i mean i
was in i think quite big danger at least
practically and i found some i think if
they work they were quite nice defensive
ideas but i'm not sure at all that they
work so overall i'm quite happy of
course how do you estimate the outcome
of the opening
uh it was a success for him actually i
was a bit a bit surprised because i
thought this line would be quite
promising for white at the very least no
risk but he surprised me with this very
strong sacrifice and d5 where he
basically he gives a couple of pawns but
he has a long-term safer king and
and well it's at least practically very
very difficult for me
okay because i i checked with the engine
it says basically like plus two for you
for example instead of i think like
bishop a4 there's like check on b4 if
you're queen and there's a line at the
computer gives but like it says like
plus two yeah uh
i mean uh
it might be that mixed up but i think
this plus two it will it could quickly
turn around if i make something accurate
moves i'm not uh
it has to be analyzed of course but i
don't think it's as clear-cut as that
and for sure or not the position was
very sharp um
does it is it like good for you against
magnus to have like more sharp position
than a more uh strategic position let's
say i think the most important thing is
to have a good position
that doesn't matter so much what kind of
position it is and it was uh
quite uh
i mean quite quickly it became very
unpleasant for me and then okay it's of
course a nightmare against anyone but
especially against magnus um you know
magnus quite well you've worked with him
uh does it give you an advantage to play
against him
i don't think so i think it
it's the advantage is as big for him as
for me so i don't know i'm not really
okay um you've had a very slow start of
the tournament so far you're one out of
five
um
is this like the start of a fresh new
tournament for you yeah of course i mean
when you start with half out of all the
only thing you can do on the rest day is
to just imagine that you are going to
start a new tournament and
well this new tournament is so far going
quite okay so
there is hope
so
now we just played round one let's say
exactly
okay well good luck with round two and
thank you very much
always a pleasure to hear from nils who
clearly is quite happy with that the
with the draw against magnus and robert
i think it's very interesting uh to to
have seen neil's reaction
when he was faced with the question well
there was this move uh that said you had
a plus two advantage and to see niels
not be phased at all you know the
reaction wasn't oh no what did i miss he
said well if you say so i believe you
clearly but plus two and me having to
find all the precise moves on the board
is a very different story
yeah and that's the thing right when
you're armed with an engine and i'm not
going to name anyone a particular chat
sometimes decisions are made for you you
just see what it tells you but it's
often that even in positions where a
move will give you a huge plus you need
to find like six moves down the line and
only move and that's where it gets very
complicated so uh niels with a great
interview there of course he and leonard
are friends so they shared a moment the
joke about round two they both seem to
enjoy that but for it's true for nils he
needs to get into the mindset of one
game at a time the first four rounds
they're in the books it's already over
with you just have to keep going forward
from here by the way it's uh i zero but
mr jingles in the chat is uh was making
a joke uh a joke comment like a joke
question do you sleep with one pillow or
two
but funnily enough and he describes and
this is a complete aside but him and i
swapped pillows on the rest and he
messaged me not even on the rest there
as early as day two he said my pillows
are too big what does your pillow look
like i sent him a picture of my pillow
and he said great i will come and get
this pillow do you want one of mine in
return and he's very happy he's been
sleeping a lot better he said so a lot
better oh yeah the pillow
pillow gambit for for the win
oh gosh well i'm glad the sleep schedule
is improving just the getting good
night's rest is so important and for
report you know he's looking here like
he could use a little bit of rest it's
been a long game it's been a complicated
game and he wants to push his pawn to c7
it's on c6 generally speaking when you
have past pawns you should always look
to push them but don't always push them
right you just look to calculate think
about it and there he has in fact
decided to move his pawn up the board
yeah the pawn has made its way to c7
right now it cannot advance still since
the eight is under control by the rook
and uh the bishop
but there is plenty more pawns to be
pushed
and the rook you know if the knight
moves the rook can go to d8 uh white's
next one was b6 you can move your king
out the way play b7 and those pawns are
just way too strong here i'm trying to
even think of a way to complicate
matters for pragmata but with b6 next
maybe
that's
all you can do is come up with some idea
that
makes white's life difficult for example
i'll just give a random one if you play
rookie five you think oh the rook moved
i'm gonna go get a queen now after we
trade there's rook c5 check does rook
take c4 white is still winning thanks to
this past pawn here but now you have to
think i only have one extra pawn
black has some good play here
am i going to be able to convert this i
wouldn't rush these decisions if i am
report yeah and i don't think he will
rush it actually robert i just realized
that there was so much to discuss about
neil's interview that we completely
forgot to say that the other game we
still had going on uh ended in a draw
between um
fabiano carrana and andre yesipanko
you're telling me that this position is
a draw
breaking news
oh my gosh and how did it happen we just
go back a few turns the
knight went to a2 and fabian was like
yeah okay i've had enough let's just
take and then put his rook here and
allowed the trade of pieces because this
though black is up a pawn
for people who are newer to chess this
actually is a pretty cool moment because
black is stuck so you can move your rook
all along the fifth rank and then white
will move along the third rank and if
you move off the fifth rank anywhere
white can check the king away and take
the pawn so we'd have rook and king as
rook and king and of course that's a
draw so fabiano knew what he was doing
here he just said let's
get all the pieces off that way we don't
have to offer a draw there is no other
choice because lone kings and that was
that
a frustrating result for fabiano who was
clearly in control
in this game he had the upper hand but a
great defense by by yasi penguin
we're going to hear from fabiano quite
soon but for now let's go back to
richard report and pragnanda
greg is oh no let's go to fabi
fabian carano you just played a draw
with uh essie penko and looked like you
were better the whole game
yeah it was i mean i felt like i was
close to winning in the end game
um okay before it was extremely unclear
but he played a very strange move knight
d2
after that i'm certainly better i think
he can take on e5 and it's just an
unclear position
um
anyway i was kind of impressed with his
opening idea because it's
it's sort of a new way to approach this
with white he's just sacrificing the
pawn and
and getting very unclear compensation
and okay i was kind of kind of happy
with how i
played the opening because it looked
like i got a decent position
but yeah 92 and c5 i suddenly started to
feel like i'm significantly better
and
then i got unclear again because um
i missed this b4 stuff
but then queen a5 was very important
after that i thought i'm again again
better
um
although maybe i had something
uh a bit stronger earlier on but after
queen a5 queen a2 i thought the end game
is is much better for black but
uh somewhere he got a huge amount of
counter play and
yeah maybe um
maybe knight c65 wasn't the right way or
i was counting on a tactic which it
turns out didn't work which was to play
uh
bishop f5 bishop takes e4 and uh i'm
winning the second pawn but
uh
he has bishop takes c4 rook h4 and f3
rook takes a 4 bish b1 anyway it's uh
it started to feel like he had more than
enough compensation to make a draw so
it doesn't seem like it's your
tournament yet
like yeah i mean
all draws isn't very good um
yeah there's not much i can say about
that you know it's
it's certainly not uh not a great start
and um
i i didn't really get so many chances
but today was was probably quite a
decent chance to um
to move into well not the leaders group
but close to it okay thank you thanks
i'm ready
i we heard from fabiano there
who
well clearly he didn't know exactly
robert he felt he was better but he
didn't know exactly
where uh he missed his chance and even
to us uh watching with
with the evaluation by it wasn't
entirely clean we knew he was better
but there was never a clear cut way
no
there wasn't there was no missed win it
was just a better position that andre he
was able to find enough counter play to
end up holding that game so
fabi you know he looks fresh his play
leaves a bit to be desired and i know he
must be disappointed because he's had
plenty of good positions in this
tournament and
i'm trying to think like he had a really
nice position against karjakin earlier
against shanklin you know he never
really got too much going on for him so
it gets vita he neutralized easily with
black so there were a couple missed
opportunities today included so it feels
like he has left points on the table
for sure but
well we've all uh
been here or some of you might have been
watching this tournament when a couple
of years back magnus had a similarly
slow start with five or six draws to
begin with and suddenly he just went on
a tear one three or four games
in a row and fabio well he's capable of
that just happening any day
so
five uh draws to begin with certainly
not uh the result he was hoping for but
also nothing dramatic
nothing dramatic has happened
yeah and sometimes all you need is that
first win and it's easier said than done
to score that victory but he'll continue
playing his play has been good it's been
quite high level throughout this
tournament sometimes you see
a player just really struggle
even though his results have been all
draws we feel like he's been playing
well uh even if the results don't show
up as a win here or there
yeah absolutely and well speaking of
wins today it really looked robert like
we were gonna get
plenty of decisive results
somehow here we are and uh
mediev the only one who managed to
decide an advantage an advantageous
position in his favor richard report i
think is uh very close to doing
the same but where do you feel the the
missed chances
lay or what is your recap of the day
that's a great question i would say that
a dubai shanklin the draw seemed like a
fair result shannan held well the duda
karjakin game could have gone any
direction they both could have lost at
the same time like who knows um then in
report he's about to win it seems major
won his game that seems right um
yeah i don't know i i think that in the
nils
magnus game and the yes a pango karwana
game there were advantages for the
players but it was still very
complicated so it wasn't like
how could he miss this straightforward
win there were so many pieces on the
board still tactics to figure out so i i
don't really feel
that
there was like a huge missed opportunity
and the players should feel bad about
not winning the games they're generally
[Music]
not happy that they missed an
opportunity to play the perfect move
chess players tend to be perfectionists
they want to find the best move at every
turn and that will bother them more than
the result
yes absolutely yeah well i i think that
today sometimes this simply what happens
the games were
hugely exciting and i think that's the
point that we're trying to make for the
last couple of days it's not that we
mind uh draws i think today there was
none of the draws that we had a bad word
to say about there were no
anti-climactic draw offers and sometimes
that's just what happened again is wild
one side is pushing the other is
defending and the game ends in a draw so
i think we had a fair few uh of these
and well the last game still going
rapport against prime ananda we'll come
back to that after a short break so
don't go anywhere and we'll see you soon
[Music]
welcome back here round five at the tata
steel chest tournament and robert we are
looking at the last game remaining in
the masters section but just look at
those queenside pawns
we've been talking about them for a
while but they are getting closer and
closer
they are indeed the knight came back
hoping to stop those pawns from
promoting but the king can go to a7 it
can just go to b6 here and
no trades will favor black the part of
the issue is while black has an extra
minor piece white has three pawns for
the piece so even trades don't help as
those pawns are just so advanced
and the king is currently in check where
would you go to with that king
uh
b6 c's probably
probably c6 because there's no check for
black after king c6 your rook can't
check on e6 you lose the knight the
bishop checks on d7 i take your bishop
so i don't think that there's anywhere
to check from so i feel pretty happy
about that move
i like king c6 also opening up the path
for the the b-pawn
i wonder if there's any move for white
that is not good
uh probably not at this point
those pawns are just too
far
and
yeah
looks like he just played king c6
i think c6 is indeed
on the board um
we saw prague make a fast move there
knight b3 he is getting also very low on
time
we're only on move 52 so eight moves to
go
before he gets another 15 minutes but in
this position robert it doesn't really
make a difference
yes because i think the easiest
way to victory right now is rook to d5
trading pieces will win report the game
and you cannot afford to trade rooks if
you're black and where else can your
rook go the bishop is under attack so if
rook d5 you play rook anywhere the
bishop hangs rookie e6 is checked that's
for sure but after king b7 now your
bishop's under attack and i'm
threatening to get a queen so it's
unstoppable
and i'm just looking uh rapport with
this win
he will also join the the lead uh so
tomorrow going into the the sixth
round we it looks like we will have a
three-way tie at the top with mamedyarov
vetted and reports maybe not
the top three that people would have
predicted what three uh really really
exciting and interesting players and
great to see them there
they're having great tournaments so
rapport in particular lost his first
game the other two have won two games
drawn three reports won this will be his
third victory one loss and one draw so
really fighting chess from him and one
of the things actually i know it is day
five and somehow we haven't talked about
it yet but the regulations in case of a
tie at the end of the tournament were
changed uh this year so we're not gonna
find ourselves uh in the same situation
as last year where
there was this drama with jordan and
anish playing the play-off alireza
didn't know he couldn't join them even
in case of a win so this year uh
especially after what happened at the
world rapid and blitz which
a lot of people were criticizing if
players are tied here at the top
everyone tied for first will be
taking part in a playoff
and that's good to see because in many
events in the past instead of having a
playoff where
the play all players get to take part
it's usually two players
maybe three max but if ten players
happen to tie for first they should all
have a chance to face them especially in
a round robin tournament where you play
the same opponents in a swiss let's say
somebody loses the first two games then
their average opponent is going to be
lower in rating than somebody who wins
their first two games it keeps going
from there so i do think in a round
robin it's great that if there's a tie
the players will play for first
absolutely and well we're still a very
long way from a big tie in the end uh
five rounds down but eight still to come
meanwhile richard report i liked your
suggestion of rook d5 but
rook d8 also looks very convincing
with the rook now coming to support the
pawns
that's right rook c5 is a check it gets
behind that pass pawn but after rook c5
you can't even take c4 because the
knight on b2 the knight that was sitting
on d1 before has joined the party it
protects this pawn on c4 and that means
once the king was out the way b6 b7 is
unstoppable
yeah and we see the clock ticking down
there for prague who is about to drop
under
under a minute
but
there is simply no stopping these pawns
uh prague fought valiantly but
i think this is um the end the end of
the road as those
white pawns are going to be queens soon
yes and he's down under a minute on the
clock so if he is going to play on he's
do so quickly he
given is check on c5
and
report can just play king d6
stay away from your past b pawn and the
rook on c5 is trapped so it's not like
there's a next move that looks
particularly nice the rook can't move
the bishop and rookie stay stopping the
c pawn so if a king comes to d6 the
knight can't move either as the rook
needs a defender and that's that knight
on b3 so b6 b7
can not
be prevented
yeah so king d6 the move we're expecting
and the move which will signal
the end
of the game is there also something to
be said no
king d6 has appeared
i think that's convincing enough
and well
um
i think as you showed there's just
literally
literally no moves here for for black
no and we might see him resign right
here
he's out of
he's just out of moves i mean bishop
takes h3 does rook h8 check you to win
the bishop that way so there's just not
even a single move that i see that makes
particular sense
yeah and uh well 40 seconds on the clock
for for prague
um we'll see
what
what he decides um
i think we might just see a resignation
here because
the pawns are rolling maybe we'll see a
move like g4 bishop h3 but it will just
be delaying the inevitable
yeah yeah i do give pragma a lot of
credit for his fighting spirit um
he is
i often say there's no point of
resigning because you get a zero if you
resign on move 30 or if you resign on
move 60 and so
he's trying to find any last bit
of play
and he goes g4 you can just swap pawns
play b6 after that and there's going to
be two pawns on the
seventh rank over here and that's too
much but like i said the fact that
pragnanda he fights until the very end i
think that's good because magnus carlsen
has shown that if you just say let's say
you're on the better side of things and
you just agree to withdraw rather than
playing it out you're not going to score
those full points and magnus does that
better than anyone and on the other side
of things if you resign you're getting
the same zero as if you play on and
sometimes you may in fact survive a game
that looks like you have no hope in
and i i mean i agree with you i think
magnus in general uh in that respect has
been such a positive uh influence and
such a
a breath of fresh air uh to
to keep fighting and
he never wants to draw unless he has to
and um i think
the new generation it shows i feel that
in general we see a lot more fighting
chess we see games and
less soon i think there was a time when
very often the players felt like okay
this position is equal
let's just call it a day and i i think
that magnus really has been a
a great influence in that respect
i'm with you there and
you know we i want to give a quick shout
out before this game concludes to arjun
arigaisi because he won again today over
volatile merzin he goes a four and a
half out of five in the challenger
section so what a performance thus far
by arjun he's one of the numerous indian
teenagers who are making their mark on
top level chess and pragmata he may lose
this game but he of course is part of
that generation of talent in india
indeed and what a debut by arjun
in the challenges let's remind everyone
that the challengers there's a lot at
stake winner takes it all as the winner
from the
challengers qualifies to play
in the masters group of the following
year and um i think that's
what all the players in the challenges
group of course there are some prizes as
well but i think the big prize
is to to qualify to the masters group
and square off against the very best in
the world next year
that's right and we see
moves are being played here
trading on g4
and now report can play b6 and uh
prognanda in round four against neil's
grandiose he spent a lot of time just
verifying whether his decisions were
going to be the right ones and reporters
doing the same thing it is
a winning position both players know
that you can see the look on probably on
his face he's like reflecting on a move
30 turns ago of where could he have
improved but right now b6 has been
played and it's a matter of time before
pregnant resigns for sure but i do like
the fighting spirit that he is showing
he's such a young player he's hungry he
wants to get better at chess and he's
getting experience and there is an
argument to be made fiona that when you
play these long games you get more tired
but he's 16 years old so if there's any
time to play long chess games it's when
you're that young
i think so and especially with uh well
it's not just for prague but for all the
the young players not just the young
players young and old of course well
there's been a pandemic for the last
couple of years in case you hadn't heard
so it's been very difficult for them you
know they were at 14 year old
two years ago he had roughly the same
rating but then just hasn't had the
opportunity and we see him uh resign
here in this position after b6
so just he hasn't had the opportunity to
play as much as he would have liked and
i'm so glad he gets the opportunity here
today a tough game two days ago we saw
him get his first win against niels and
i'm fairly confident uh that's not gonna
be his only win of this event
yes but today is reports day rehard with
a nice victory i mean he was struggling
out of the gates but he found a way to
get his pieces out in that king march
from e1 over there to the queen side and
then up into the center that's in fact
what won him the game but really that
was at the start it looked like
pragnanda had the edge and then rihard
found some good moves and he
now is tied in the lead with vidit and
mama jarov
absolutely what an incredible comeback
from
richard after losing his first round
game to fight back in this fashion
and
we're going to take a look at the
results from today so we had two
decisive results my media was beating
eurodon van ferece and richard reported
beating pragnanda dos
both joining a vidid in the lead who
drew
his game against anishgiri from a
position of power towards the end that's
right it had some chances some small
chances to potentially play for more but
i think at that point
most of the action had dried up so a
draw felt like the right result and did
it he's still in the lead mama jarv
there with him and once this result gets
updated report who was a two and a half
at a four he'll jump forward to three
and a half out of five and
he is in a three-way tie for first with
magnus carlsen and andre yes panko just
a half step behind
wow and robert i mean i'm lost for words
today has been such an exciting it's
been such an exciting day but we aren't
done just yet we are gonna go on a quick
break and then we will be back with our
rapid recap of the day it's not going to
be an evil easy task which game
to choose but stay tuned you don't want
to miss it we'll be right back
[Music]
so
round five was a lot of fun but now it
is done we had two decisive games and
one of them will go for you right now
this is your round five rapid recap and
fiona it was jordan van forest with the
white pieces against chakriar mama jarv
we saw a bit of a theoretical discussion
out of the opening and both players were
moving quite quickly indeed well this
was one of the games that we had most
been looking forward to going into the
round it did not disappoint jacqueline
mediev he played the open
spanish which he has been playing since
before jordan was even born
yes but jordan he's full of good
creative ideas he strikes four with a4
and if the pawn went to b4 bishop e3
bishop b7 normal looking development and
here comes the move a5 so fiona what's
that all about
well a5 is certainly a new idea a5
opening up some lines for the bishop
from b3 we see the black king still
stuck in the center for now so that's
one of the ideas the question of course
when you make a commitment pawn move
like a5 is that gonna be a strength is
it gonna be a weakness
that's really a good point because the
pawn a6 stuck in place but that pawn on
a5 we can't forget about that if you're
not looking that pawn can be gathered so
the king castle got out of the way of
that bishop a4 pin we saw queen d3 the
knight came to c5 the bishop took it was
a trait over here and things started to
get spicy at this moment where after c3
97 knight two we saw it takes takes and
then bishop a7 so fiona an imbalance
it's a knight against a bishop white has
that knight and he tried to use it right
now jordan brought his knight indeed to
the center to
d4
said i'm not going to give up my bishop
pair so easily dropped his bishop back
to d7 and now things started getting
spicy jordan bringing the second knight
into the game into
f3 and after c5 it looks like the knight
on d4 is under attack but what did
jordan say
yeah the knight is under attack if it
moves then income c4 with a fork of
queen and bishop he said let's go e6 and
mama jarv he's too smart to make this
mistake f takes e6 would have been a
huge blunder because the knight the g5 i
don't care about my knight on d4
checkmate is more important if you stop
the checkmate with the move like g6 then
white can just take this pawn on e6
knight takes e6 forks the queen and the
rook white wins material and would have
won the game so no he was not going to
be fooled by this e6 move going to
bishop e8 was really nice this should be
a very nice touch indeed jordan still
trying to go for the same idea knight g5
anyway threatening checkmate on h7
shakira playing this move
f5 closing the diagonal and now knight
f7 a slightly surprising move
it was very surprising and black's
response was both brilliant and
surprising as well because bishop takes
f7 that's the move you want to play
let's trade three points for three
points and then i win your pawn but we
were talking about how the knight is
under attack and c4 is also a threat
knight e6 takes care of both at the same
time the queen's under attack that means
white has enough time to avoid this pawn
push to c4 and as you see white is
actually doing quite decently so instead
of this
rook takes f7 a temporary sacrifice
because after politics bishop takes no
longer do you have the e6 square and
fiona after knight f5 it was black's
turn to strike
indeed now black went c for forking the
queen and uh the bishop white has
nothing better than to capture
on c4 but very soon well now jordan is
going to find himself in a position
where he just has a material deficit
which is getting the two pieces and he
found a clever way to do this does he
take on c4 immediately no he takes on f5
first
right because taking on c4 allows queen
takes d8 check removing the guard of the
knight on e7 so if the rook takes queen
knight takes e7 white is ahead in
exchange and would be for choice so
instead of this knight takes f5 and now
after bishop takes a6 knight came to d6
the queen moved the bishop moved as well
and now the a5 pawn collapses but fiona
we were talking during the game that at
this point right here black is surely
better but how much better was the big
question well what you were pointing out
is if jordan could manage to get rid of
the queen side pawns then he might have
good chances for survival
but i think mamadiarov he did a great
job making sure that d-pawn was going
nowhere
he did he said i'm going to keep that
one safe and sound and we have to give
jordan credit because this moves c4 it
is a pawn sacrifice but it is a great
idea and to mama jarv's credit he reacts
perfectly after bishop h7 he doesn't
take because after queen f7 h5 e8 c4 all
under threat he makes us move king f8
and fiona this is where things went
wrong for jordan yeah now after in this
situation um jordan went bishop to g6
and uh well hitting hitting threatening
mate on f7 shakia said none of that he
interposed the knight on f6 and after
the exchange
on f7 this was the moment where we
talked about could jordan have saved the
day here instead of rook c1 the move
which he played in the game what was
queen b7 check
you know
creamy snapchat is the only move but
it's not just about the move the
follow-ups are really really wild
black's best try is to retreat this
bishop to e7 i think because after the
bishop comes to e7 here it looks like
rook c1 gets this pawn but there's a
tricky move knight d5 where white has to
be very careful free pawns are not
always free rook takes e4 would have
been a blunder because queenie won check
the king needs to stay attached to this
pawn f2 but after king g2 there's this
brilliant shot knight e3 check forking
the king and the rook that's a free
knight right pawn takes e3 queen e2
check now we for sure win the rook
there's nothing white could do and then
black would have gone to win this game
so instead of taking that pawn right
away on the c4 square white has this
move queen to c8 if black tries to keep
this pawn with c3 the queen comes into
f5 check it's all wild but there's pins
here attacks here
the h5 pawn is threatened as well so
it's a dynamically level position but
still extremely complicated yeah and
during the game while we were live we
were wondering why didn't urine go for
this check but after looking through
these lines in more detail i think it is
an understandable decision he went for
rook c1 but now shakira media found a
series of very nice moves starting with
queen sife c7 direct defending the pawn
on c4 indirectly because white cannot
capture it and there is a
discovery tactic if rook c4 bishop takes
f2 check
would end the game as the rook on c4
isn't
defended so here things got uh difficult
for jordan
they did he went king g2 renewing the
threat of rook takes c4 but it's too
late bishop comes to d4 and after the
queen ventures into enemy territory c3
it's on a protected square now that
bishop on d4 both protects c3 and
attacks f2 and after a few more moves
here it was clear that mama jarv would
not have enough so the queen went around
queen b7 check
f3 was played that's not a good thing
for this white king and after a few more
moves fiona the queen went to the first
rank and the queen can't take on d4
because the rook on c2 was hanging yeah
jordan all tied up here a few more moves
were played but it was soon at the end
queen f5 bishop e3 the king tried to
hide on
h3 but after
windy won
jordan threw in the towel here there's
just nothing he can do the king is safe
on h6 that pawn on c3 is going to decide
the game and the king on h3 it's
hopeless so you uh robert what a game by
shakhim amityarov
it really was an amazing game and i
normally don't do this but i just want
to rewind one second because i'm still
going through various possibilities in
my head at that moment when queen b7 was
possible right that's where according to
the eval bar things went away from white
and as you see it's creeping back up
it's creeping back up it's giving white
these chances and just one more
variation that came to mind here is
let's say bishop e7 rook c1 pawn c3
queen b3 check we're getting that pawn
knight d5 protects the pawn rook d1
looks really scary but then after king
e6 somehow this position remains pretty
good for black and i understand why
jordan did not play queen to b7 all of
these lines give black good chances the
pawn on c3 is scary so with all that in
mind the game did conclude in mama
jara's favor at the end let's get to the
very end of the game here with the queen
on d1 that was a win for mama jarv he's
in a tie for first and that was your
round five rapid recap
robert what a day it has been here the
updated standings are ready so there's
our three-way toy at the top with
shakira media if you've just seen the
racquet recap of the day proposing him
to the top
where he is joining vidiq and richard
rapport and behind them two players on
three out of five magnus carlsen and
andre yes panko
yeah it's a tight race at the top uh
three players in first and then as you
mentioned those two players just a half
point behind so in a single game there
could be new leaders if the current ones
uh lose and the people chasing wins so
fiona if we look at round six of course
magnus
it's gonna be your last day
i'm already sad
well i honestly forgot about that so you
reminded me that tomorrow is
my sixth and final day of commentary
daniel neroditzky will replace me but as
we look at these pairings magnus carlsen
against
richard report we have fabinho carwana
against aneesh geary i mean just all the
way down through and through these
pairings are awesome yeah i think we're
absolutely in for retreat here uh
fabiano against aneesh as you mentioned
also my medierov against grand alias
the russian clash duboff against pango
win it he will be playing against young
christian of duda who is looking to come
back to the top so so much action to
look forward to
tomorrow i'm really looking forward to
it here's the schedule so we'll be back
same place same time 2 p.m central
european time uh that's 5 a.m pacific
and
yeah robert
what a day
and uh i'll leave you
final words i'm i'm lost for worried
i think the most surprising thing of the
day is that we only had two decisive
results we saw seven fascinating games
where every single player in this field
was trying their best to score a point
games that ended in draws doesn't mean
that they were not entertaining they
certainly were so fiona two wins this
round mama jarov rapport their entity
first with gujarati who held nicely with
the black pieces against aneesh giri i
think the three players in first place
deserve to be there but with so many
rounds remaining eight to be precise
it's a long tournament ahead absolutely
a lot can still happen we might i'm sure
we will see some changes at the top but
agree with you the three players at the
top deserve to be there tomorrow we'll
find out can they stay there can they
increase the lead will players catch
them so much to look forward to we will
look forward to seeing you then thank
you so much for watching thank you
robert for being here by my side have a
good one and see you all tomorrow
[Music]
you